d'avancer le début de l'examen du projet
de loi accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable qui était
initialement prévue jeudi 3 novembre
nous l'avancerions mercredi 2 novembre
sans doute dans l'après-midi à l'issue
de l'examen du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
2023-2027
est donné de cette demande
nous pourrions fixer si vous en êtes
d'accord les délais 10000 d'inscription
des orateurs dans la
discussion générale de ce projet de loi
donc énergie renouvelable ou lalyte 31
octobre à 15h est-ce qu'il y a des
observations
s'il n'y en a pas il est assis il en est
ainsi décidé et
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi encadrant
l'intervention des cabinets de conseils
privés dans les politiques publiques
présentées par Madame Meliana Cécile
Monsieur Arnaud Bazin et plusieurs de
leurs collègues
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
au vu de l'heure de reprise de nos
travaux et en accord avec la Commission
et le gouvernement je vous propose
d'ouvrir la nuit pour cette séance en
nous assurant d'aller au terme de la
discussion de ce texte
ça peut être évidemment un peu tard
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues j'ai donc
l'honneur de vous présenter notre
proposition de loi encadrant
l'intervention des cabinets de conseils
dans les politiques publiques
ce texte est le résultat d'un travail
rigoureux de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat créée à l'initiative de mon groupe
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
et écologistique s'appuie sur quatre
mois
d'investigation 40 auditions et
l'analyse de 7300 documents nous
poursuivons trois objectifs en finir
avec l'opacité des prestations de
conseils mieux les encadrer et renforcer
les exigences déontologiques des
consultants il ne s'agit pas là
d'interdire par principe le recours au
cabinet de conseil mais bien de fixer un
cadre clair pour mettre fin aux dérives
constaté par la commission d'enquête
cette démarche est transpartisane elle a
associé tous les groupes politiques de
notre assemblée je veux ici remercier
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
d'enquête pour leur soutien ainsi que la
commission des lois et ça rapporteur
c'est Sylvie Kerman pour les
améliorations apportées au texte
c'est le plus ralyse sénatorial qui
s'exprime ce soir je crois que nous
pouvons en être fiers sur tous les bancs
de notre émission
je souhaite également remercier très
sincèrement le président Arnaud Bazin
qui était fut également président de la
commission d'enquête avec qui nous
travaillons de concerts dès le premier
jour la commission d'enquête a mis au
jour un phénomène tentaculaire
l'influence croissante de consultant
privé sur des pans entiers des
politiques publiques la crise sanitaire
la stratégie nationale de santé l'avenir
du métier d'enseignant la mise en oeuvre
de la réforme des aPL les états généraux
de la justice la liste des missions
déléguées à des cabinets privés est
tellement foisonnante qu'elle en donne
le tournis au point de se demander si il
y a un pilote dans l'avion
en 2021 la facture des consultants
s'élèvent à au moins un milliard d'euros
pour l'État et ses opérateurs est la
plus que doublée depuis 2018 en pratique
les cabinets de conseils n'ont pas de
problème de pouvoir d'achat une journée
de consultant coûte en moyenne 1500
euros à l'état ce chiffre ayant atteint
2568 euros pendant la crise sanitaire
malgré ce niveau de rémunération les
résultats ne sont pas toujours au
rendez-vous
Capgemini a par exemple reçu 280.200
euros pour une mission sur le handicap
alors que l'évaluation parle ce site
d'une valeur ajoutée quasi nulle par le
cabinet bien évidemment
contre-productif parfois fin de citation
BCG et Ernst and Young ont reçu
558900 euros pour organiser une
convention des managers de l'État en
décembre 2018 qui n'aura finalement
jamais lu
a reçu en novembre 2019 957000 euros
pour une mission commandée par la CNAV
visant je cite encore à aider la caisse
à se transformer en vue de la réforme
des retraites alors que celle-ci tout le
monde s'en souvient a été abandonné de
telles dérives sont inacceptables
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'argent public
et surtout dans le contexte actuel au
quotidien l'opacité règne sur les
prestations des cabinets de conseils qui
souhaitent rester excuser l'anglicisme
biais de Sin pour reprendre leur
expression à titre d'exemple la
commission cyruleique sur les 1000
premiers jours de l'enfant n'étaient pas
au courant que l'État avait missionné le
cabinet Roland berguerre en parallèle de
ces travaux ce cabinet a touché plus de
420 425000 euros pour un travail qui je
cite encore n'était pas à la hauteur
d'un cabinet de stratégie selon donc
l'évaluation de la dictée dans le même
temps les membres de la commission c'est
médecin et expert de haut niveau était
bénévoles et avait du mal à se faire
rembourser leur ferait de déplacement
pour se rendre aux réunions c'était de
quoi de mesure si notre commission
d'enquête a été un exercice de
transparence démocratique on constate un
retour à l'opacité depuis au-delà de
l'exercice de communication le jaune que
le gouvernement a publié la semaine
dernière et lacunaire et je dois dire
très décevant lacunaire lacunaire car il
exclut le conseil en informatique et ne
couve que la moitié du périmètre de la
commission d'enquête il ne concerne que
470 millions d'euros de prestations
contre 894 millions dans nos travaux les
chiffres parlent de même décevant car le
gouvernement se refuse à publier la
liste de ses prestations de conseils
alors qu'il s'agit d'une information
essentielle que nos concitoyens sont en
droit de connaître en pratique les
ministères traînent des pieds pour
répondre aux demandes des journalistes
entretenant aussi ce climat d'opacité
pour gagner du temps l'état refuse
toujours de communiquer des documents
malgré les avis les avis favorables de
la CADA le 21 janvier dernier un
journaliste de Next
demandait au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale une copie du rapport de
McKinsey sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignant facturé pour une somme
exorbitante de
496800 euros dis-moi plus tard il attend
toujours le 12 octobre le journal Le
Monde annonçait sa volonté de saisir la
justice face aux non-répons de l'Élysée
de Matignon et de la plupart des
ministères le gouvernement ne doit pas
avoir peur de la transparence bien au
contraire c'est pourquoi notre PPL
imposera la publication de la liste des
prestations de conseils de l'État et de
ses opérateurs ainsi que des bons de
commande et des évaluations de
prestations
ces informations figureront dans le
rapport social unique pour que les
fonctionnaires puissent débattre les
agents publics ressentent en effet un
profond malaise lorsque des consultants
viennent leur expliquer leur métier à
coups de post-it de jeux de rôle ou
encore de pepperwood c'est le cas à
l'OFPRA ou les consultants de wave Stone
chasse ce qu'ils appellent des irritants
pour réduire le délai de traitement des
demandes d'asile autre exemple pendant
la campagne de vaccination
mackinsey utilisant le logo de
l'administration pour rédiger ses
livrables et Monsieur Véran ancien
ministre de la Santé d'affirmer de
vendre notre commission d'enquête je
cite encore si vous aviez voulu les
documents estampillés machin c'est
présent dans le dossier vous auriez
trouvé une feuille blanche c'est étrange
pour une prestation facturée plus de 12
millions d'euros c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons éviter toute confusion entre
les fonctionnaires et les cabinets de
conseils qui n'ont qui ne pourront plus
utiliser les signes dist de
l'administration à l'initiative de
Michael Valette nous proposons de bannir
les expressions anglo-saxonnes
d'inspiration managériale comme
benchmark line management ou encore
qu'est learning conformément à l'article
2 de la Constitution la langue de la
République et le français y compris pour
les consultants certains ont résumé
notre texte à la PPL dites McKinsey
certes les pratiques de ce cabinet ont
choqué nos compatriotes en particulier
sur le plan fiscal 0 impôt sur les
sociétés pendant 10 ans alors que son
chiffre d'affaires atteint 450 millions
par an comble de l'ironie le 11 juillet
dernier sur BFM Business la directrice
générale de McKinsey rejeté la faute sur
le coup du travail en France qui reste
bien évidemment trop élevé à son goût en
réalité McKinsey peut remercier le
mécanisme des prix de transfert et le
paradis fiscal du dollaware il continue
d'ailleurs de candidater au public il a
été désigné titulaire de son Gourin du
marché de lugap attribué en plein été
mais notre proposition de loi va bien
au-delà de ce seul cabinet le recours au
consultant est devenu un réflexe pour
l'administration alors qu'elle dispose
des compétences en interne on a parfois
l'impression que l'État se fit davantage
au PowerPoint de ses consultants qu'aux
travail de César de ces agents au fond
le recours croissant au cabinet de
conseil illustre une certaine vision de
l'État un état en mode start-up pour
reprendre le titre d'un ouvrage évoqué
pendant l'audition de McKinsey en
délégance émissions stratégiques à des
cabinets privés létats risquent
toutefois de perdre de perdre en
souveraineté au bénéfice des
multinationales du conseil nous serons
tous d'accord pour éviter à tel risque
le gouvernement lui-même a d'ores et
déjà pris des mesures la plupart du
temps en réaction à nos travaux nous
gardons bien évidemment à l'esprit la
circulaire signé le 19 le 19 janvier
dernier le même jour de l'audition
d'Amélie de mon Chalain devant notre
commission d'enquête le hasard fait
parfois bien les choses monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement a besoin de
notre PPL pour mieux encadrer le recours
au cabinet de conseils vous le savez car
nous en avons nous avons eu l'occasion
d'échanger à plusieurs reprises sur le
sujet de manière franche et directe
c'est pourquoi nous vous demandons
solennellement d'inscrire notre
proposition de loi à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale sans en réduire
l'ambition nous avons un devoir de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français
qui se sont emparés du sujet et qui
souhaitent que les choses changent
l'enjeu dépasse même notre pays le 30
septembre dernier Radio-Canada annonçait
que McKinsey avait été payé 35000
dollars par jour pendant la crise
sanitaire au Québec dans l'opacité la
plus totale monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous avons ensemble le
devoir de fixer des règles plus claires
pour les consultants dans l'intérêt de
l'État et de nos politiques publiques ce
n'est pas qu'un souhait des parle
commentaires que nous sommes dans notre
diversité c'est une exigence devenue
populaire au fil des travaux de notre
commission notre débat de ce soir est
attendu et je fais confiance à notre
haute assemblée pour être à la hauteur
de cette exigence je vous remercie
la parole est à présent la madame Cécile
CUC Kerman rapporteur de la commission
des lois
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la Commission de loi
monsieur le ministre pardon mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi de nos
collègues Elia assassin Arnaud Bazin est
ambitieuse et profondément novatrice
elle a été nourrie par les travaux que
la commission d'enquête a conduit
pendant plusieurs mois sur l'influence
croissante des cabinets de conseils sur
les politiques publiques ces travaux ont
suscité de nombreuses réactions du
gouvernement et de l'administration
comme des consultants circulaires du
Premier ministre refonte de la corcade
de la direction interministérielle de la
transformation publique dont l'équipe de
conseil interne doit être renforcée
rédaction par l'organisation
professionnelle Syntec Conseil d'une
charte de déontologie spécifique pour
les interventions de conseil auprès du
secteur public et très récemment
publication par le gouvernement d'une
annexe au projet de finance pour 2023
vous me permettrez monsieur ministre de
ne pas utiliser ici l'expression de
jaune budgétaire mais je pense nous
irons bien
si ces initiatives vont dans la bonne
direction elle reste insuffisante
n'ayant pas le caractère général et
pérenne souhaité la commission des lois
estime par conséquent qu'une loi
instituant un cadre unifié contrôle et
sanctionner est aujourd'hui nécessaire
le texte proposé par nos collègues
Eliana Sassier Arnaud Bazin répond à 4
enjeux tous essentiels dans le cadre
d'une démocratie que l'on souhaite
mature un enjeu de transparence
vis-à-vis des parlementaires mais
surtout à destination des citoyens un
enjeu de maîtrise de la dépense publique
un enjeu de souveraineté à travers
l'action de l'État et enfin un enjeu de
probité
il a été consigné par la quasi
intégralité des membres de la commission
d'enquête et le fruit d'un travail
transpartisan la commission des lois a
donc tenu à conserver cet équilibre tout
en l'ajustant pour lui apporter une
plaine effectivité dans cet esprit elle
a sécurisé le périmètre de la
proposition de loi en choisissant une
rédaction plus précise juridiquement
préférant la catégorie des
établissements publics de l'État à celle
d'opérateur et en évitant les
chevauchement de compétences avec les
conseils de discipline des professions
réglementées de droit
elle a renforcé l'exigence de
transparence et clarifier le partage des
responsabilités entre administration et
consultants la Commission a également
rendu plus dissuasive l'amande
administrative qui serait exigée des
personnes morales ne respectant pas les
nouvelles obligations mises en place en
la portant à un montant proportionnel
alors chiffre d'affaires mondiale elle a
enfin apporté des garanties à la
procédure de vérification sur place et
créer un mécanisme de régularisation en
cas d'exclusion des procédures de
passation des marchés publics
cela étant dit j'ai bien conscience que
le texte adopté par la commission n'est
qu'un point d'étape et non un
aboutissement certains sujets importants
restent en effet en débat mais il
nécessite le temps de la réflexion que
permet la navette et les débats
parlementaires il en va ainsi du champ
d'application de la proposition de loi
s'agissant aussi bien des
administrations bénéficiaires que des
prestations de conseils concernés
pour ce qui est de la liste des
administrations bénéficiaires tout
d'abord la question de l'inclusion ou
non des collectivités territoriales se
posent c'est indéniable loin de nous
d'ailleurs l'idée d'opposer un état
friand de prestations de conseils à des
collectivités territoriales qui n'y
recoureraient jamais toutefois cette
question ne peut être réglé sans
consulter les associations des lieux
locaux et sans comprendre qu'elles en
sauraient les conséquences sur le
fonctionnement de ce même collectivité
territoriale nous n'allons donc pas le
faire au détour d'un amendement de
séance ce serait alors affaiblir y
compris les objectifs voulu de même la
question des seuils est récurrente y
compris pour les établissements publics
de l'État que nous avons intégré dans le
champ d'application de la proposition de
loi cependant en l'absence d'information
permettant d'établir la liste précise
des établissements publics concernés par
tel ou telle seuil il nous semble
prématuré à ce stade fixe d'en fixer un
dans le même ordre d'idée la liste des
prestations de conseils entrant dans le
champ de la proposition de loi
mériterait très certainement d'être
affiné
ultérieurement à ce stade le
gouvernement est quelques-uns de nos
collègues ont donc formulé un certain
nombre de propositions une partie
d'entre elles remettent en cause
l'architecture du texte en particulier
le rôle accordé à la Haute Autorité à la
transparence de la vie publique et le
recours à des sanctions administratives
où reviennent sur la substance des
obligations mises à la charge de l'État
en particulier en matière de
transparence c'est pourquoi la
Commission si opposera d'autres
suggèrent des modifications plus
restreintes nous ne les avons pas
retenues à ce stade pour nous concentrer
sur le cadre général nous pourrons pour
certaines très certainement y revenir
dans la suite de la navette
enfin certains auraient souhaité saisir
l'occasion de ce texte pour renforcer le
cadre législatif s'appliquant aux
représentants d'intérêt ils en ont été
empêchés par l'article de la par
l'application de l'article 45 de la
Constitution et surtout là encore la
volonté de préserver l'équilibre de
cette proposition de loi
issue du travail de la commission
d'enquête ce sujet demeure cependant
important et mériterait un texte à part
notre Comité de déontologie mène
d'ailleurs une réflexion sur les règles
applicables aux représentant d'intérêt
au Sénat
je crois que ce soir nous fixons un
cadre
nous coulons en quelque sorte les
fondations mais tout ne sera pas terminé
ce soir et après l'examen du texte ici
au Sénat il y aura besoin comme je l'ai
déjà dit de poursuivre le dialogue
d'améliorer pour rendre applicable et
effective cette proposition de loi notre
rôle ici n'est certainement pas
d'affaiblir l'État et à travers lui
notre République il est au contraire de
chercher à prendre les meilleures
décisions pour changer des pratiques qui
ont conduit progressivement à
externaliser une partie de la prise de
décision vers le secteur privé
nous sommes donc pas là pour tout
renverser mais bien pour mener
pleinement notre rôle de parlementaire
celui du travail de contrôle comme celui
d'initiative législatives et donc nous
ne doutons pas que l'Assemblée nationale
fera de même fera pleinement son rôle et
inscrira et examinera dans les semaines
les mois à venir cette proposition de
loi
pour conclure la commission vous invite
donc à adopter son texte enrichi de
quelques amendements pour poser comme je
l'ai dit les premiers grands jalons de
l'encadrement de l'activité des cabinets
de conseils auprès de l'État et de ses
administrations dans un délai qui nous a
été contraint par le temps nous aurions
certainement eu loisirs de mener plus
d'auditions certainement plus longtemps
mais je crois que nous arrivons là en
tout cas après le travail de la
Commission à un équilibre qui préserve
celui souhaité par les différents
auteurs de cette proposition de loi je
tiens à remercier bien évidemment les
services de la Commission des lois qui
m'ont accompagné avec un rythme soutenu
au cours de ces quelques semaines pour
pouvoir vous présenter le rapport et ce
texte de commission ici ce soir et
j'inviterai bien évidemment l'ensemble
de mes collègues a voté favorablement
et la parole est maintenant monsieur
Stanislas Guérini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente assassine monsieur le
Président Bazin monsieur le Président de
la Commission Jean-Noël buffet madame la
rapporteur Cécile Karman mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs le sujet qui
nous occupe aujourd'hui je veux le dire
clairement et stratégique
il s'agit de la capacité de la puissance
publique à agir à répondre efficacement
au grand défi auquel nous sommes
confrontés et nous choisissons ensemble
ce soir c'est la nous nous rejoignons je
vous en remercier
d'aborder ce sujet dans l'objectif de
renforcer la puissance publique et sans
jamais laisser ce sujet aux populistes
je veux le dire les populistes ne
cherchent qu'une seule chose créer la
polémique affaiblir le gouvernement se
faisant l'État et quand nous aurons
proposé des solutions ils passeront à la
prochaine polémique ça n'est pas
l'esprit des travaux que vous avez menés
ça n'est pas l'esprit du travail que
nous mènerons ensemble ce soir je
souhaite que nous examinions ce texte
dans l'esprit qui vous a animé de façon
trans partisane vous l'avez rappelé
madame la précisante Présidente ou
plutôt en étant rassemblé dans un seul
camp
celui de ceux qui souhaitent renforcer
l'État et sur ce sujet la philosophie du
gouvernement est claire est-ce que
l'État doit pouvoir faire appel à des
compétences dont ne dispose pas en
interne je crois que la réponse est oui
mais est-ce que l'État doit se renforcer
doit se réarmer doit développer ses
compétences doit se doter d'un cadre
renforcé pour recourir à des prestations
de concerne externe oui je réponds
également positivement à ces questions
là et je veux saluer en démarrant nos
travaux l'engagement du Sénat et de la
commission d'enquête transpartisanes
créées à l'initiative vous l'avez
rappelé madame la présidente du groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste présidé par sénateur Bazin et
dont les travaux ont été rapportés par
la présidente assassin vous avez mené un
travail en profondeur précis sérieux
avec des propositions concrètes sur le
sujet les membres de la commission ont
estimé que ces propositions
nécessitaient une traduction législative
le gouvernement en prend acte et nous
travaillons sur ce texte de façon tout
aussi attentive et exigeante et je me
présente ce soir devant vous avec la
volonté d'avancer sur ces sujets et à
l'appui de ses affirmations je veux dire
que nous avons agi concrètement pour
encadrer le recours aux prestations de
conseils d'abord vous l'avez rappelé
avec la circulaire du Premier ministre
du 19 janvier 2022 elle a fixé à la fois
des modalités de contrôle interne et un
CAP en matière de réduction des dépenses
de conseils à court terme nous sommes en
voie de tenir cet objectif c'est aussi
vrai des modalités de contrôle je le dis
devant la Chambre haute une mission
inter inspection portée par la première
ministre sera mener d'ici la fin de
l'année pour vérifier la bonne de ce
point de contrôle interne et faire le
point sur ce qui nous reste à faire
deuxièmement dès ma nominations j'ai mis
en place un nouveau cadre clair et
renforcé sur le recours au prestations
de conseils c'est l'accord-cadre
interministériel porté par la dUTP qui
entrera en vigueur en janvier 2023 et
sera d'utilisation exclusive pour les
services de l'État cet accord intègre
pleinement les recommandations de la
commission d'enquête en matière de
déontologie en matière de transparence
en matière d'encadrement des données ou
de renforcement des risques contre les
risques de dépendance des
administrations vis-à-vis des
prestataires troisièmement afin de
réarmer concrètement l'état j'ai aussi
initier le renforcement de nos moyens
humains vous l'avez souligné madame la
rapporteur en créant 15 postes dédiés au
sein de la diptp pour une administration
qui compte une centaine de
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui vous le
verrez dans les engagements budgétaires
dont vous aurez à débat dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finance j'ajoute enfin
un point très concret nous avons créé
cette année un document qui fait la
synthèse de l'ensemble des dépenses de
conseils de l'État et dont j'ai tenu
bien entendu à ce qu'il vous soit rendu
disponible avant l'examen de cette
proposition de loi ce document est
annexé au PLF 2023 je prends devant vous
deux engagements concernant ce document
d'abord c'est de porter un amendement
dans le PLF 2023 dès l'examen du texte
budgétaire à l'Assemblée nationale pour
que ce document soit gravé dans le
marbre et deviennent un jaune budgétaire
pour de bons madame la rapporteur une
annexe pérenne dans le cadre de l'examen
des lois de finances que nous aurons à
examiner chaque année le deuxième
engagement j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir dans nos débats c'est de
renforcer le volume
et la précision la granularité des
informations qui seront portées à
connaissance dans ce jaune budgétaire
vous le voyez nous avançons nous
agissons nous prenons des expositions
pour renforcer l’état en prenant en
compte les recommandations du Sénat et
c'est dans cette état d'esprit que je
veux aborder la proposition de loi qui
va occuper nos travaux ce soir dans un
état d'esprit constructif sincère dans
les finalités portées par ce texte et
exigeant dans l'effectivité et la
proportionnalité des dispositions que
nous allons discuter ensemble je vous le
disais je partage l'objectif premier de
ce texte meilleure maîtrise par la
puissance publique des moyens qu'elle
mobilise et celui de neutralité des
prestations de conseils sur la décision
publique qui doit rester pleine et
entière et j'aurais affirme tout
l'intérêt de disposer d'un cadre légal
clair et stable en la matière
un point de méthode pour nos discussions
ce soir je vais vous dire les axes de
travail que j'identifie pour renforcer
le texte et je prends l'engagement pour
les débats qui vont suivre de toujours
vous indiquer en transparence les points
qui me semblent soit inopérance soit
disproportionnée et de toujours faire
des propositions je ne porte aucun
amendement de suppression sentent contre
proposition d'une certaine façon que je
souhaiterais vous soumettre les trois
sujets que vous identifie sont les
suivants d'abord vous l'avez mentionné
madame la rapporteur le périmètre de la
proposition de loi établie par l'article
premier j'ai beaucoup parlé de puissance
publique j'ai fait à des saints car il
nous semble essentiels de faire en sorte
que le cadre proposé par l'article
premier s'applique également aux
collectivités territoriales qui ont reçu
aussi recours au cabinet de conseils
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter
dans discuter et des amendements ont été
portés en ce sens sur différents bancs
dans cette émission
le même sujet sur la question de la
transparence à la fois des prestations
et des compétences de l'État le
gouvernement porte des amendements afin
de recentrer en un article unique les
dispositions portées dans les articles 3
4 et 8 il s'agit de rendre j'aurai
l'occasion de vous présenter cette
proposition plus claire plus lisible et
donc plus exploitable les informations
transmises par le gouvernement sur le
recours aux prestations de conseil enfin
troisième sujet sur le mécanisme de
contrôle déontologique de sanctions je
souhaite que le contrôle exercer soit
proportionnelle à l'objectif poursuivi
je crois très sincèrement que c'est une
condition d'effectivité des mécanismes
proposés nous aurons cette discussion
pour les dispositifs qui concernent les
déclarations d'intérêts exigées pour les
consultants mais aussi sur les
mécanismes de contrôle de la ha pvp et
la question de la régulation des
mouvements entre secteur public et
secteur du conseil au fond je viens de
vous donner les trois champs sur lequel
j'aurais des propositions à formuler et
sur lequel je souhaite surtout que nous
ayons vraiment un vrai débat de fond
pour nous assurer de la bonne
effectivité de la loi madame la
Présidente vous m'interrogez au fond sur
l'avenir de ce texte j'ai la volonté que
ce texte chemine je l'ai dit
publiquement je le réaffirme ici devant
vous sur les modalités de son examen que
ça soit dans le cadre d'une niche
parlementaire dont la programmation est
à la main de chaque groupe ou sur le
temps réservé au gouvernement vous
comprendrez qu'il est important pour le
gouvernement que nous puissions examiner
ce texte et de voir de quel texte on
parle à l'issue des travaux que nous
aurons ce soir sur lequel la Haute
Assemblée aura à se prononcer mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
je souhaite que nous puissions
maintenant rentrer dans le débat au fond
je crois que c'est ce que vous et moi
attendons pour ce soir je vous remercie
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est un monsieur Stéphane
Ravier non inscrit pour 3 minutes
suivant l'usage
sur le président
la discussion générale n'a pas débuté
que vous agitez déjà le chiffon rouge
véritable point Godwin du il ne faut pas
faire le jeu du populisme ça traduit
quand même une certaine fébrilité manque
de sérénité du gouvernement mais que
cela vous plaise ou pas ce texte doit
marquer la fin des très mauvaises
habitudes pour l'état où une
collectivité territoriale fait appel à
un cabinet de conseil pour un soutien
technique ou un état des lieux ponctuels
c'est légitime y avoir au cours de
manière systématique et en devenir
dépendant c'est inacceptable or le Sénat
a relevé un phénomène tentaculaire
équivalent à une facture minimale de 1
milliard d'euros en 2021 pour l'État et
ses opérateurs son non seulement les
proportions mais les méthodes qui
interrogent nous comprenons désormais
parfaitement ce que signifie la
un état colonisé par les cabinets
souvent étrangers comme les américains
McKinsey waxenture ayant pour seul
intérêt de faire de l'argent bien loin
des préoccupations d'intérêt général et
encore moins d'intérêt national la
start-up nation c'est l'externalisation
des missions régaliennes au profit des
grands cabinets de conseils la captation
de notre souveraineté par le secteur
privé et pas n'importe lequel celui des
plus fortunés des puissances étrangères
et des grands lobbys financiers qui
n'ont qu'une batterie le profit il est
évidemment vital de mener une réflexion
sur l'efficacité de nos administrations
l'effectif du ministère de la Santé
s'élève à plus de 11000 personnes et il
a fallu que le gouvernement mobilise
plus de 11000 jours de consultants pour
gérer la crise sanitaire c'est
insupportable cependant que nous n'ayons
pas possédé en interne les porte
flingues zélés de l'oswald sanitaires et
vaccinal ce n'est pas moi qui m'en
plaindrait ce sont les cabinets qui
proposent ces solutions numériques de
facilité il parle en termes d'efficacité
besoin de liberté publique à trop les
écouter les décisionsnières publiques
finissent par oublier les principes qui
font de notre état par ailleurs les
cabinets conseils parfois simultanément
plusieurs clients ils servent les
intérêts des plus offrants et renvoient
l'ascenseur à ceux qui leur ouvrent les
portes et le Directeur de l'innovation
de Pfizer a passé 25 ans chez making
chargé de la stratégie vaccinal en
France cette porosité entre intérêts
privés pose gravement problème parmi les
ex McKinsey ont conte un préfet le fils
du président du Conseil constitutionnel
une vice-présidente de la Région
Île-de-France un directeur des cabinets
de ministres le directeur général dans
marche et j'en passe 20 associés ont par
ailleurs fait la campagne du candidat
Macron en 2017 preuve d'une porosité
publique privée politique très
problématique qui ne peut qu'entraîner
défiance et suspicions avec le
développement de structure comme le
conseil de défense aujourd'hui sanitaire
militaire et en attendant
environnemental les migratoires nous
sommes sommets de prendre l'habitude des
sans même un contrôle parlementaire ces
manières d'agir de la part de l'exécutif
ne doivent pas nous installer dans une
forme d'accoutumance il convient donc de
rétablir les mécanismes de
responsabilité et de légitimité propre à
un système démocratique il en va de la
confiance des Français envers la
politique qui est fortement éprouvée
avec vous mes chers collègues je
participerai à une avancée sans moi
yveter dans ce sens
et vous en remercie
la parole est à maintenant Jean-Yves
roux pour le Rassemblement démocratique
social européen
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
président de la commission des lois mes
chers collègues nous avons tous en tête
l'esprit largement métallisé des
auditions de la commission d'enquête sur
l'influence croissante des cabinets du
Conseil privé ou notre collègue
rapporteur il y a un associé interroge
l'un des dirigeants de mackenze France
au sujet du contrat d'un montant de
presque d'un demi million d'euros pour
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant et accompagner la direction
intermissariat de la transformation
publique dans ses réflexions autour du
métier d'enseignant
un échange lunaire tend du point de vue
des montants évoqués que des réponses de
lui celui qui était auditionné alors je
peux le dire sans détour toute critique
que je pourrais faire sur ce texte ne
sera qu'accessoire et marginal regarde
la grande qualité et de l'intérêt
supérieur des travaux qui ont été menés
par notre assemblée sur un sujet
essentiel celui de la privatisation de
la décision publique par choix
volontaire vers des cabinets de conseil
les travaux de la commission d'enquête
nous ont placé face à deux questions
celle de notre vision de l'État et de sa
souveraineté face à des cabinets privés
d'une part et la bonne utilisation des
deniers publics d'autre part alors de
notre attachement profond à un État fort
et garant de l'intérêt général toutes
les mesures de cette proposition de loi
vont donc dans la bonne direction
qu'il s'agisse de la publication enfin
de la liste des prestations de conseils
auxquels l'État et ses opérateurs font
appel de l'encadrement plus contraignant
du recours au consultant ou encore du
renforcement des règles déontologie des
cabinets de conseils et des prérogatives
de la haute transparence de la vie
publique bien sûr un tel texte parce
qu'il s'attaque à un sujet d'ampleur et
complexe vient avec des difficultés je
pense en particulier à la détermination
de ce qui doit être qualifié de
prestations de conseils l'article
premier de la proposition dresse une
liste synthétique qu'il serait temps
d'allonger par le détail des principes
et des exceptions en ce sens notre
collègue Jean-Pierre corbiset avait
déposé un amendement en Commission
visant exclure du régime du contrôle des
prestations des entreprises d'ingénierie
délivrées au titre d'une expertise
technique cette précision n'était pas
apparue superflue mais nous comprenons
aussi qu'elle n'est pas été retenue les
auteurs de la proposition de loi et
Commission on fait le choix contraire de
rester relativement souple dresser une
liste exhaustive leur apparu impossible
nous y rangerons pour donner à ce texte
les chances d'une application rapide et
finalement c'est le lot de toutes les
qualifications juridiques que d'avoir
des zones grises et de laisser aux
acteurs voire au juge le soin de les
analyser et de trancher au cas par cas
toutefois il reste un sujet qui pose une
réelle difficulté nous nous plaisons à
rappeler que notre assemblée représente
les territoires d'autant que la
Constitution par son article 24 nous
allons donner la charge vous savez déjà
où aboutira mon propos j'ai consulté
quelques articles de presse sur l'examen
de cette proposition de loi je
n'insisterai qu'un le Sénat oublie ses
électeurs la critique est évidente mais
surtout fondée en particulier à l'époque
où la confiance de la destitution
politique tant à s'étioler je comprends
évidemment les arguments qui ont conduit
exclure les collectivités locales du
périmètre de ce texte pour ne retenir
que l'État et ses administrations
mais il donne le sentiment d'un refuge
d'obstacle notre président Jean-Claude
Ruquier a déposé l'amendement qui
permettrait de corriger cet écueil il
inclure et pour la première de cette
proposition les collectivités
territoriales et leur établissement
public à l'exception des petites
communes ainsi que les intercommunalités
à l'exception des comités de communes
nous aurons le débat tout à l'heure mais
j'espère que nous nous cacherons pas
derrière les faux problèmes légistiques
d'opérationnalités des seuils ou de
mécaniques juridiques pour refuser cet
aménagement
nos collectivités elles aussi méritent
d'être protégés de l'instruction
excessive des cabinets de conseils et
des consultants dans l'élaboration de
leur politique publique chacun sait ici
l'importance des décisions politiques
prises sur nos territoires le
renforcement de la décentralisation a
jusqu'à donner à nos collectivités un
pouvoir considérable notre pays nous ne
pouvons pas les exclure des réflexions
sur la bonne utilisation des données
publiques souvenons-nous du fameux
précédent des emprunts toxiques dont
beaucoup de collectivités ont été les
victimes et qui parfois encore le prix
les responsabilités étaient multiples
mais c'est aussi parce que des élus
étaient mal protégés contre l'avidité de
certains cabines du conseil ou
établissement bancaires qui n'ont pas pu
prendre de bonnes décisions toutefois je
peux aussi le redire le débat sur
l'inclusion ou des collectivités dans
rien à l'intérêt et à la grande qualité
du texte s'il faut l'adapter sans que
les collectivités soient incluses nous
l'adopterons mais dans cette perspective
j'invite notre assemblée à poursuivre
ses travaux en s'engageant dans
l'élaboration d'un régime encadrant
également les collectivités
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant au président Arnaud Bazin
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre sur le président de la
commission des lois madame leur
rapporteur mes chers collègues comme
Eliane assassy je souhaite remercier
tout d'abord l'ensemble des membres de
notre commission d'enquête que j'ai eu
l'honneur de présider que de chemin
parcourus depuis la réunion consécutive
du 25 novembre 2021 il y a bientôt un an
notre rapport était transpartisan tout
comme cette proposition de loi c'est à
la fois un gage de sérieux et
d'équilibre partagé sur tous les bancs
de l'hémicycle je salue également le
travail de la commission des lois qui a
amélioré le texte et je remercie leur
rapporteur pour son écoute et sa
connaissance du sujet
que les choses soient claires nous ne
légiférons pas contre les cabinets de
conseils dont nous ne remettons pas en
cause les professionnels mais pour mieux
encadrer leurs prestations et en finir
avec l'opacité déplorer par la
commission d'enquête
j'appelle aussi le gouvernement a
inscrire notre proposition de loi à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
nos concitoyens ne comprendraient pas
que ce texte se retrouve bloqué dans la
navette parlementaire cela ne serait pas
à la hauteur des enjeux soulevés par la
commission d'enquête je vais concentrer
mon intervention sur les aspects
déontologiques ce qui ne va pas vous
surprendre
la commission d'enquête a mis en lumière
trois risques les conflits d'intérêts
les camionnettes conseils conseillant
simultanément plusieurs clients dont les
intérêts peuvent diverger la porosité
lorsque les cabinets recrutent d'anciens
responsables publics ce que l'on appelle
le pantouflage et enfin le pied dans la
porte lorsque les consultants
interviennent gratuitement
pour l'administration ce sont par
exemple les cabinets McKinsey Boston
Consulting Group qui ont organisé les
sommets techforgo des choses France à
l'Élysée ces prestations étaient même
devenues banales alors qu'elles
servaient en réalité la stratégie
commerciale des consultants avec cette
proposition de loi nous faisons choix de
la clarté nous interdisons purement et
simplement le pro bono ce que le
gouvernement n'a jamais fait seul
resterait le mécénat
dans les secteurs bien circonscrits
comme l'humanitaire la culture ou
l'éducation pour plus de transparence le
mécénat fera l'objet d'une déclaration à
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
tout comme les actions de démarchage ou
de prospection commerciale des cabinets
de conseil dans la même logique nous
souhaitons que le cabinet de conseils et
les consultants remplissent des
déclarations d'intérêts sous le contrôle
de la Haute Autorité l'État est en droit
de connaître les autres clients de ces
consultants afin de mieux prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts et surtout d'y
mettre fin un état aveugle sur le plan
déontologique est un état en danger
l'enjeu n'est pas mince au regard des
récentes interventions des consultants
sur la crise sanitaire ou encore
l'évaluation de la stratégie nationale
de santé
des consultants on fait part de leurs
inquiétudes dans la presse les
déclarations d'intérêts seraient trop
lourdes et les forceraient à s'éloigner
du secteur public qu'il se rassure qu'il
sera sûr en tant que parlementaire nous
remplissons des déclarations d'intérêt
depuis 2013 la première prend un peu de
temps puis il suffit de l'actualiser je
pense que des bacs puissent 10 il
parviendront sans grande difficulté
[Musique]
dans un souci d'efficacité nous
souhaitons renforcer les moyens
d'investigation et de sanction de la
Haute Autorité cette dernière doit
pouvoir prononcer des sanctions
administratives en cas de manquement
déontologique des consultants ce qui
évitera d'engorger les tribunaux elle
pourra aussi les exclure de la commande
publique ce qui nous semble logique et
conforme au droit européen
vous voyez mes chers collègues que nous
proposons un dispositif duontologique à
la fois complet et cohérent mettant en
oeuvre les recommandations de la
commission d'enquête vous conviendrait
que la confiance de l'administration
envers ses consultants n'exclut pas le
contrôle ce qui justifie notre
proposition de loi je finirai en
évoquant les représentants d'intérêt ce
sujet n'entre pas dans le périmètre
notre texte comme l'ajustement rappeler
la commission des lois
je n'ignore toutefois pas son importance
ni la nécessité de faire évoluer le
droit en vigueur c'est dans cet esprit
que le Comité de déontologie du Sénat
présentera des propositions sur les
représentants d'intérêt d'ici à la fin
de cette année après avoir entendu les
professionnels du secteur nous l'avons
commencé depuis bientôt un an et les
associations c'est un engagement que
nous avons pris auprès du bureau du
Sénat et que nous tientrons je vous
remercie pour votre attention et pour
votre soutien à notre proposition de loi
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est maintenant à Emmanuel
Capu pour le groupe Les Indépendants
je suis le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
nous examinons aujourd'hui une
proposition de loi issues des travaux de
la commission d'enquête mené à
l'initiative de madame la Présidente
cette commission d'enquête trouve son
origine dans une polémique né à
l'occasion d'élection présidentielle
polémique concernant le recours du
gouvernement au cabinet de conseil
certains de nos concitoyens ont en effet
été interpellés par le fait que l'État
recourt à des cabinets privés pour
l'aider à définir sa stratégie
mes chers
que soit ses services l'administration
n'a pas et ne peut pas avoir en interne
les compétences requises pour faire face
aux situations qu'elle doit gérer
le recours à ses cabinets permet donc
d'apporter une expertise et de proposer
des solutions
c'est ainsi que 72% des prêts des 900
millions d'euros dépensés par l'État en
conseil durant l'année 2021
concerne des prestations informatiques
tous les responsables politiques savent
bien qu'ils ont eu recours aux
prestations de conseil
S ou qu'ils y auront recours à jour
et nos concitoyens Français préfèrent
sans doute que l'État prenne des
décisions éclairées
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
vise à imposer des obligations
transparence aux prestataires de
conseils lorsqu'ils travaillent au
bénéfice de l'État et de ses
établissements
afin de prévenir les conflits d'intérêt
mais aussi afin d'éviter les
allers-retours entre ces cabinets et
l'administration
pour cela le texte étant le pouvoir de
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie politique déjà en charge du
contrôle des principaux responsables et
agents publics ainsi que des lobbys
l'État n'est évidemment pas le seul à
recourir aux prestations de conseils nos
régions nos départements et nos communes
le font aussi très régulièrement
pour des raisons de périmètre d'enquête
cette proposition de loi ne vise
cependant pas les collectivités
territoriales
certains parmi nous s'interrogent
cependant sur la nécessité d'inclure les
plus importants d'entre elles dans ce
dispositif
en vérité notre groupe s'interroge plus
largement sur l'opportunité d'une telle
loi
nous comprenons parfaitement les
inquiétudes que l'activité de conseil a
pu susciter mais nous doutons que les
moyens proposés soient efficaces et
adaptés
l'administration fait appel à de
nombreux acteurs afin d'avoir un œil
extérieur pour résoudre les difficultés
auxquelles et les confronter
nous croyons les manifestement nous
sommes minoritaires qu'il n'est pas
malsain que public et privé puissent
échanger des idées et des personnes
par ailleurs quel que soit les conseils
c'est toujours mes chers collègues le
responsable politique qui décide
et qui est responsable des décisions
qu'il prend
également pour celle de recourir au
Conseil
nous ne sommes donc pas favorables à la
création de régime spécifique dont
l'application est confiée à des
autorités spécifiques qui disposeraient
de pouvoir d'enquête et de sanctions
spécifiques
enfin nous craignons que cette PPL ne
renforce des mots très français
bureaucratie
création de rapport
renforcement de la lourdeur
administrative
et mécaniquement
augmentation du nombre de fonctionnaires
ça peut intéresser certains évidemment
nous sommes convaincus que notre pays a
au contraire besoin de souplesse et de
simplicité les échanges publiques privés
sont monnaie courantes dans beaucoup de
pays
et dans ceux du nord de l'Europe
particulièrement
ils ne sont pas plus mal c'est
fertilisation croisées sont créatrice de
synergie qui améliore l'efficacité de
l'action publique
bien sûr nous devons être très attentifs
aux ressources de l'administration
elles proviennent de l'argent des
Français et doivent donc être employés à
bon escient
et sans abus cela va sans dire
mais nous croyons qu'il faut également
veiller à préserver son efficacité
si nous ne voulons pas travailler
nous-mêmes à l'impuissance de
l'administration
le gouvernement a annoncé son intention
d'encadrer davantage le recours aux
prestations de conseils par les
administrations publiques et c'est une
bonne chose
l'une des manières de réduire ce recours
la plus efficace
pour les libéraux que nous sommes
c'est certainement de réduire le
périmètre d'action de l'État qui pourra
ainsi se concentrer sur ses missions
régaliennes
ces missions les plus essentielles et
sur lesquels ils disposent d'une vraie
expertise
dans sa majorité vous l'aurez compris le
groupe est un des vendanges ne votera
pas comme Monsieur ravier ni comme
certains autres sur ce dont et
s'absiendra
la parole est maintenant Guy benaroche
pour le groupe écologie solidarité
territoire
et pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame l'auteur il y a
l'assassy messieurs les rapports
flash et des allers-retours trop opaques
entre les hautes sphères de l'État et
les cabinets privés avaient été
clairement érigés en objective par notre
président Emmanuel Macron
comme cela devient une habitude les
gouvernements du président de la
République en quelque peu déçu sur ce
programme malgré l'espoir de nos
concitoyens sur la réelle en côte du
devoir d'exemplarité mais comme pour
d'autres décisions de cette gouvernance
je cite ce n'est pas un échec ça n'a pas
marché c'est ce que dit couramment notre
président de la République c'est
lui-même qui l'a dit pour d'autres
sujets
la présente proposition de loi s'inscrit
dans l'histoire récente des révélations
journalistiques d'une augmentation
notable des dépenses liées au cabinet de
conseil depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron le groupe CRCE avait
alors demandé l'ouverture d'une enquête
sur l'influence de ces cabinets et la
présence proposition de loi s'appuie
monsieur le ministre sur les conclusions
de cette commission transpartisane
rendue au prêteur 2022
quels sont les reproches formulés à
cette explosion des recours que c'est
privé mais surtout quels sont les
propositions que portent cette loi pour
y faire face
tout d'abord ce n'est pas le recours
même à une expertise extérieure qui est
mis en cause mais bien les mécanismes
qui amènent la transparence nécessaire à
ces contrats et les montants consacrés
pour parfois des résultats plus que
discutables le désinvestissement dans la
fonction publique qui ne résulte pas
seulement de l'action de ce président
faut l'avouer mais aussi de ses
prédécesseurs contribue à ce recours
massif les sociétés de conseils sont
souvent perçues comme un moyen simple et
agile dans les moments de surcharge
ponctuelle pour pallier au plafond
d'emploi cela crée aux conséquences des
pertes de compétences au sein de
l'administration ou quelquefois
l'empêchement de la montée en
compétences l'exemple typique on est la
compétence informatique
certains ils voient d'ailleurs l'action
de pompiers pyromane qui ne donne pas
les moyens à l'administration de rester
compétentes sur ses prérogatives dans le
but de justifier ses recours coûteux à
une poignée de grosses entreprises de
conseils pourtant une grande majorité
des entreprises de conseils de moindre
échelle restent loin du pouvoir et des
pratiques de ces grands groupes
cette dynamique de recours décuplée au
cabinet de conseil est aussi critiquée
dans son manque de transparence résultat
d'études coûteuses il y a un assassin
nous la rappeler non publiée par exemple
dans l'éducation nationale
doublant de mission vous nous l'avez
également rappelé privée public par
exemple pour la prise en charge de la
petite enfance
cette opacité dans le recours que ce
soit dans la définition du besoin réel
ou dans l'effectivité réelle des rendus
et source de défiance de nos concitoyens
y compris dans notre système
démocratique au vu de toutes les
problématiques révélées par la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale qui
au-delà de marquer les dérives à pu
proposer 19 recommandations notre
collègue adopte souhaitait travailler la
proposition de loi que nous vous
proposons aujourd'hui si nous apprécions
ce texte nous pensons que certains
points méritent si ce n'est amélioration
au moins une discussion je tiens par
exemple au nom de mon groupe à regretter
les décisions d'irrecevabilité qu'on
subit nos amendements alors qu'il
concernait explicitement les pouvoirs de
contrôle et de sanctions conférées à
l’autre autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique au vu de faire respecter
ses obligations par les prestataires de
conseils et les consultants comme
indiqué dans le document de la
commission des lois qui fixent les
règles relatives à l'application de
l'article 45 un de ces amendements est
recevable s'inscrivez de plus dans la
lignée d'une de la mission d'évaluation
de la loi Sapin de menée en 2021 par
deux députés Olivier martex des
républicains et Raphaël Gauvin de la
République en marche dans sa proposition
numéro 42 du rapport d'évaluation il ne
faisait en plus que répandre à une
demande même de la SA TVP qui est
explicitement dans un rapport d'octobre
2021 à sa proposition numéro 12 demandée
de doter la Haute Autorité d'un pouvoir
propre de sanction administrative en cas
de manquement à l'obligation de dépôt
d'une déclaration d'activités la
sanction est en proportionnée à la
gravité du manquement et à la situation
de la personne poursuivie nous le
regrettons vivement déjà ce périmètre
nous apparaissait particulièrement
restreinte permettant pas une discussion
globale sur les lobbys et les liens
d'intérêt entre public et privés notre
groupe est certes minoritaire et
d'autres positions hélas parfois aussi
mais le refus de discussion au travers
de décision irrévocable d'y recevabilité
pénalise l'exercice démocratique
pour en revenir au texte à ces mesures
dovatrices nous y sommes globalement
favorables
pour autant la plupart des dispositions
de cppl sont d'ordre d'orbatives mais
certaines d'entre elles revêtent un
caractère réglementaire elles ont donc
pour objectif d'inciter le gouvernement
à opérer des changements dans les règles
déontologie c'est bien là que le bât
blesse tout comme dans lors de la
création de la hatvp c'est l'écriture
des décrets qui parfois ne suit pas
c'est pourquoi nous aurons à cœur de
discuter et d'entendre les gages que
dans le gouvernement pour de réelles
transformations de ce recours excessif
au cabinet de conseil les gages pour
permettre à la hatvp de pouvoir
fonctionner correctement et notre groupe
votera pour ce projet
merci chers collègues et la parole est à
Nicole Duranton pour le groupe RDPI
et pour 6 minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
chers collègues les pouvoirs publics ont
toujours eu besoin de s'appuyer sur des
compétences extérieures c'est une
réalité ancienne qui ne date pas
uniquement depuis l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 mais existe déjà
depuis de nombreux quinquennat et c'est
accéléré depuis 2007 RH informatique
gestion de données massives
communication analyse comparative les
besoins sont en réalité nombreux
pourquoi d'abord certains champs
d'expertise très spécial très
spécialisée le nécessite ensuite un
arbitrage apaisé appelle parfois un
regard extérieur
enfin l'urgence ou le lancement d'un
projet implique l'action rapide et
coordonnée d'un grand nombre de
consultants agissant uniquement dans un
laps de temps déterminé ce qui se prête
mal au processus de recrutement de
fonctionnaires pour autant le besoin ne
sera pas toujours aussi important que
durant la crise covid d'une part nous
avons vécu ces dernières années dans une
accumulation de crise globale tout à
fait inédite d'autre part chaque
administration travaille son
attractivité afin de recruter en interne
ses compétences je vous laisse également
souligner que nous nous ne sommes pas
les plus mauvais élèves en Europe
ainsi en 2018 un rapport souligne que
comparé aux autres pays européens le
conseil au secteur public apparaît
limité en France les chiffres sont cinq
fois plus élevés en Allemagne et 4 fois
plus au Royaume-Uni
la résolution numéro 111 a été
enregistrée à la présidence du Sénat le
27 octobre 2021 une commission d'enquête
a ensuite été constituée donc cette
commission dont j'étais membre a entendu
pendant quatre mois 47 personnes sous
serment lu les réponses à 131
questionnaires et analyser 7300
documents comme mes collègues l'ont déjà
souligné le rapport a été rendu le 16
mars dernier et je salue le fait que le
gouvernement ait pris en considération
les recommandations lors de l'élobe
l'élaboration du nouvel accord cadre
plafonnant les dépenses de conseil
renforçant la transparence et améliorant
l'évaluation par ailleurs le
gouvernement adore est déjà publié un
jaune budgétaire annexé au PLF 2023 et
intitulé recourt au conseil extérieur
il s'agit là d'un pas supplémentaire
vers plus de transparence
compétences souveraineté démocratie et
légitimité de la décision voici autant
d'enjeux que cette pratique implique et
qu'il convient de sécuriser le Premier
ministre avait déjà publié le 19 janvier
une circulaire portant l'objectif
ambitieux de diminuer de 15%, le volume
de prestations de conseil en stratégie
en 2022 toutefois les dispositions
concernant la transparence méritait
d'entrer dans le champ législatif je
salue le travail préalable en 2014 et
2015 des rapporteurs pour information de
la commission des finances sur la
communication de la Cour des comptes le
mercredi 12 octobre la commission des
lois a adopter à l'unanimité la PPL
cabinet de conseil tous les amendements
de la rapporteur ont été adoptés
également cette proposition de loi vise
à traduire dans la loi les
préconisations de la commission
d'enquête assurer la traçabilité de la
participation des cabinets et garantir
une meilleure information des citoyens
mais en aucun cas à supprimer le Conseil
notre groupe le RDPI souhaite apporter
quelques modifications au texte en
déposant 5 amendements le premier
amendement que nous proposons précise
dans l'article premier le seuil des
établissements publics concernant par le
chant de la PPR en effet il est
essentiel d'éviter de faire peser une
charge déraisonnable sur des structures
de taille réduite 60 millions cela
correspond au seuil des avances
obligatoires versées au PME dans le
cadre d'un marché public seuil déjà bien
connu des acteurs concernés le second
vise à exclure les prestations des
conseils internes à l'administration
pour éviter une sur interprétation par
le juge le troisième réaffirme
l'exclusion des prestations de gestion
RH et d'expertise informatique
concernant l'article 11 nous portons un
amendement pour que les modalités
d'enregistrement des actions de
démarchage soit définie par décret
l'objectif étant d'aligner le dispositif
sur les règles de droit commun enfin sur
l'article 18 il s'agit de limiter les
obligations d'audit souvent très
coûteuses au marché les plus sensibles
qui le nécessitent durant les travaux de
la commission a été développé l'idée
d'appliquer le dispositif au
collectivités territoriales en effet les
régions les départements les EPCI et
certaines villes font aussi appel au
conseil et cela s'inscrit dans la suite
logique des choses toutefois cette
extension du champ de la loi doit passer
par la fixation d'un seuil le
gouvernement est plusieurs collègues des
différents groupes ont déposé des
amendements portant ce seuil à 100 000
habitants ce chiffre semble tout à fait
adapté je sais que notre ministre
Stanislas Guérini aura à cœur de ne pas
dévitaliser le texte de la commission il
convient de rendre visible l'action de
chaque acteur des politiques publiques
d'empêcher toute dérive mais aussi de ne
pas tomber dans la surenchère
législative de ne pas ajouter
différents niveaux une surcharge de
travail et des règles confuses le groupe
RDPI est favorable sur le principe de
cette proposition de loi nous serons
très attentifs au vote des différents
amendements le texte issu des travaux de
la commission est équilibrée et
s'inscrit dans la continuité logique des
travaux de la commission d'enquête il
sera nécessaire de veiller à ce que le
dispositif puisse facilement être mis en
place par l'administration en l'alignant
le plus possible sur ce qui existe déjà
pour les représentants d'intérêt je vous
remercie merci chers collègues de la
parole est aux questions jean-Pierre
Sueur
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mais monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur chers collègues
je voudrais d'abord au nom du groupe
socialiste remercier très sincèrement
nos collègues Éliane assassin et Arnaud
Bazin pour avoir fait avec tous les
membres de la commission d'enquête un
travail tout à fait remarquable et ce
travail remarquable illustre une fois
encore mes chers collègues combien le
Parlement est particulièrement le Sénat
peut être
utile et efficace lorsqu'il exerce
pleinement la mission de contrôle qui
lui est dévolue par la Constitution donc
merci pour ce travail ce travail a
permis notamment l'ouverture d'une
enquête judiciaire suite à la découverte
du non-paiement d'impôt sur les sociétés
entre 2011 et 2020
par le cabinet mckinsee alors qu'il
réalise en France un chiffre d'affaires
annuel de plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros c'est inacceptable
impossible que cela continue ainsi nous
avons également grâce à la commission
d'enquête découverte que l'État avait
dépensions 2021 plus d'un milliard
d'euros on peut rester station de
conseils de cabinet privé
45% de plus
qu'en 2018 nous avons découvert que par
rapport à la crise sanitaire il avait
été fait largement conseil appel à ces
cabinets or mes chers collègues nos
services les services de l'État
disposent de compétences considérables
et il est parfois regrettable que l'on
fasse appel à des instances privées
alors que les services publics disposent
des compétences nécessaires
je vous l'ai dit aussi
que
un jour
j'ai appris
qu'un ministre avait fait appel à un
cabinet de conseils pour rédiger
l'exposé des motifs d'une proposition de
loi d'un projet de loi
c'est absolument
insupportable
si un ministre ne peut pas rédiger les
raisons pour lesquelles il présente une
un projet de loi alors c'est un
désespéré de la politique donc ne
mélangeons pas tout il est vrai qu'il
est des domaines dans lesquels il est
utile de faire appel à des compétences
extérieures à l'administration personne
ne le conteste mais encore faut-il que
ce soit ce que cela soit fait en toute
transparence alors mes chers collègues
nous avons déposé nous aussi quelques
amendements pour élargir le champ
alors je sais bien qu'on nous a dit
Madame la rapporteur vous nous avez dit
finalement il nous est apparu plus sage
de nous en tenir strictement au champ de
la commission d'enquête chantant cet
argument mais rien n'empêche le
législateur que nous sommes allés plus
loin absolument rien et si les principes
sont bons au terme des travaux de la
commission d'enquête pourquoi ne pas
élargir le champ c'est pourquoi nous
avons nous aussi penser aux
collectivités locales d'une certaine
importance chers collègues plus de
100.000 habitants nous avons pensé à la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations et
nous avons aussi pensé aux assemblées
parlementaires parce qu'en fin ne
serait-il pas logique que nous
appliquions à nous-mêmes les excellentes
règles qui ont été formulées dans le
rapport
c'est une question alors nous savons
déposé un amendement en prenant soin
dans sa rédaction j'insiste là dessus
qu'il préserve intégralement l'autonomie
des assemblées parlementaires
c'est-à-dire que c'est le bureau de
chaque assemblée qui décidera des
modalités de mise en œuvre en tout cas
il nous apparaît on pourra en discuter
bien entendu et diverses méthodes sont
peut-être possibles pour atteindre ce
but le but c'est quoi c'est la
transparence
et nous avons grand intérêt dans ce
domaine comment beaucoup d'autres à
jouer la carte de la totale transparence
à l'égard de nos concitoyens il est un
livre très ancien qui a connu quelques
succès et je terminerai l'assume
monsieur le Président et Madame la
rapporteur dans laquelle on peut lire
cette phrase la vérité vous rendra libre
je vous remercie
merci et la parole est à Monsieur Eric
Bocquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste pour
également 5 minutes
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
les cabinets de conseils privés acteurs
de l'ombre
omniprésent pourtant tentaculaire à
juger la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale ont été démasquées dévoilés
mis au grand jour les parlementaires du
groupe CRCE sont à l'origine ils ont
conduit par le biais de notre présidente
avec les membres de la commission
d'enquête c'est le président Arnaud
Bazin une investigation qui je le dis
nous a dépassé nous a dépassé d'abord
par la résonance populaire que les
travaux ont eu les cabinets de conseils
constituent désormais un objet politique
identifié et controversé nous devons
collectivement nous en féliciter elle
nous a dépassé aussi par l'impérieuse
nécessité de légiférer rapidement c'est
ce que nous faisons ce soir pour
traduire en acte les constats partagés
par les membres de la commission
d'enquête à l'unanimité
si le recours a des cabinets de conseils
est anciens son ampleur est inédite un
milliard d'euros en 2021 ce qui diffère
d'hier c'est surtout une croyance
toujours plus affirmée qui transaît
depuis le début du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron entre ceux qui savent
et ceux qui ne savent pas les sachant
étant les cabinets de conseils les
autres sont dans l'administration
le monopole de la vérité objectif est
rationnel incombait à des cabinets
connus pour appliquer à des problèmes
différents les mêmes recettes économie
d'échelle oblige
nous nous souvenons des mots de Nicolas
Sarkozy ancien président de la
République le 12 décembre 2007 dès les
premiers mots de sa présentation de la
fameuse révision générale des politiques
publiques je cite la réforme de l'étage
les promises je la ferai je la ferai
parce que nos finances publiques doivent
être redressées
ces mots matérialisés par le non
remplacement d'un fonctionnaire sur deux
ont porté un coup important à la
capacité de la fonction publique de
manière à bien ses missions chacun
reconnaît aujourd'hui que la dérive est
allée beaucoup trop loin il faut
consacrer le retour du politique comme
maître de l'action publique nous fume
bien les seuls à proposer dans le cadre
de l'examen de la révision de la loge du
28 décembre 2021 relative à la
modernisation de la gestion des finances
publiques la suppression de la
fongibilité asymétrique terme barbare
qui permet de redéployer les budgets du
personnel vers des dépenses différentes
investissements intervention ou
Consulting entre guillemets
permettez-moi cette anglicisme mais qui
interdit le mouvement inverse cette
logique libérale est mortifère je
souhaite que tous nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens défis ces mécanismes
libéraux de réduction de l'emploi public
au prétexte une prétendue obésité de
l'État
le collectif nos services publics
explique cet effet pervers de diminuer
le coût du service tout en maintenant sa
qualité on en réduit la qualité tout en
dégradant les finances publiques fin de
citation par le fait notamment de
rémunération beaucoup plus élevée pour
les cabinets de conseil
feignant de soutenir la proposition de
loi transpartisanes du Sénat le
gouvernement et ses alliés révèle leur
volonté de miner le texte quelque part à
grands coups d'exclusion et de
suppression on ne peut pas prétendre
encadrer le recours au cabinet de
conseils en même temps leur faire
béattement confiance on ne peut pas
prétendre encadrer les cabinets de
conseils et en même temps exclure des
consultants au titre de leur statut on
ne peut pas prétendre encadrer le
recours au cabinet de conseils et en
même temps saper les obligations
déontologiques que prévoit la présente
proposition de loi pour départ donnez
moi monsieur le ministre mais votre en
même temps n'est pas l'équilibre c'est
le laxisme c'est la poursuite de la
connivence entre le cabinet de conseils
et le gouvernement les contrats massifs
passés durant l'été et en se début
l'automne montre que vous n'avez tiré
jusqu'ici aucune leçon sur le fond des
travaux de la commission et entendez
bien vous limiter à des déclarations
d'intention
tout au long du processus vous n'avez eu
de cesse de miner les travaux de la
Haute Assemblée s'entend que la
situation vous échapper quelque peu
publication d'un rapport à l'assemblée
circulaire opportunes la veille d'une
audition du ministre conférence de
presse de ministre en pleine campagne
présidentielle et publication d'un jeune
budgétaire incomplet avant même le vote
de la proposition de loi les mots du
président alors candidats sont teintés
de vérité sur mckinsee on est mauvais
comme des cochons les enfants je prends
un instant car vous connaissez mon
appétence en matière de lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et toutes les formes
d'optimisation intolérable la commission
approuvé que mckinzey ne payait pas
d'impôts sur les sociétés depuis 10 ans
alors même que celles qu'on appelle la
firme réalisée plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
chaque année est captée de l'argent
public merveilleux Delaware qui compte
970 000 habitants et un million 600 000
sociétés enregistrées chers collègues
nous sommes fiers de ce texte fiers de
l'esprit de construction transparres
design qui nous a animé
c'est un point de départ bienvenue pour
celles et ceux qui pensent encore que
l'État peut et que l'État doit garantir
l'intérêt général
la parole est à présent à Madame
Nathalie Goulet pour l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
ministre le président et commission des
lois madame le rapporteur arrivé en 9e
position beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
dites je voudrais revenir sur sur nos
travaux avec quand même une petite
aigreur c'est pas avoir eu l'idée
moi-même de cette commission d'enquête
j'en ai une très grande frustration et
je remercie in assassy et son groupe
d'avoir eu cette idée que je n'avais pas
eu je m'étais limitée lors des rappels
au règlement à un débat sur le sujet et
voilà que la commission d'enquête est
arrivée le sujet mérite et les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête dont j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être vice-présidente en
sont le témoin mérite qu'on s'y soit
penché le sujet est important au plan
financier la part du privé dans la
décision publique dans quelles
conditions sous quel garantit c'est un
sujet qui n'est pas que philosophique
tant notre société est friante est
ouverte au conflit d'intérêt qui sont à
mon sens le pire cancer de la politique
encore une fois il n'a jamais été
question interdire le recours au cabinet
conseil mais de encadrer ses recours
pour plus de transparence afin d'assurer
une plus-value réelle sans l'interdire
on peut s'interroger sur le fait que
l'état de plus en plus recours à ses
cabinets y compris pour les politiques
publiques les plus sensibles c'est une
tendance à
ubériser le pouvoir régalien qui est de
mon point de vue relativement
inquiétante c'est une philosophie dont
certains dont je fais partie
non quelques en difficulté à accepter
placardiser la haute fonction publique
en lui préférant à prix d'or des
cabinets extérieurs privés c'est
dévaloriser ces paupériser la haute
fonction publique et les inspections
générales dont nous savons très bien
qu'elle regorge de compétences souvent
et rarement écouté ou entendu en page 39
du rap en page 39 du rapport vous avez
une déclaration de Martin Hirsch qui a
confirmé le que peuvent ressentir les
agents autant le fait de travailler y
compris dans le corps médical sur un
projet donné avec un regard extérieur ne
pose aucun problème autant le fait
d'avoir une sorte d'abonnement auprès de
grands cabinets de consultant et de
personnes pour lesquelles l'hôpital
n'est qu'un client
n'était pas perçu politiquement en page
très du rapport les agents de
l'offre-fra déclarent ainsi j'ai
l'impression que nous sommes
régulièrement infantilisés il faut
rappeler qu'un cabinet conseil pour ce
sujet fournissant une prestation pour
réduire les délais de traitement des
demandeurs d'asile des lait qui n'est
toujours pas réglé d'ailleurs
aperçu à 485 818 euros la valeur ajoutée
n'est pas immédiatement perceptible
moderniser ce n'est pas paupérisé comme
moderniser notre diplomatie n'aurait pas
dû être un petit matin d'un petit lundi
de Pâques de supprimer la fonction le
corps diplomatique ni de supprimer les
na ni le corps préfectoral au 1er
janvier 2023 je ne crois pas à ces
réformes en faux qui ne sont que des
réformes en trompe l'oeil d'ailleurs
jamais évalué donc le sujet n'est pas
uniquement technique il est politique et
donc c'est à juste titre le groupe CRCE
s'y est penché le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs été contraint de réagir face
aux travaux en toute transparence avec
des auditions ouvertes au public qui
sont toujours en ligne le 19 janvier
2022 sous la rubrique il faut sauver le
soldat Montchalin une
circulaire a été publiée le matin même
de l'audition même pas la veille pour
limiter le recours des ministères au
cabinet conseil circulaire insuffisante
mais attestant
de la gêne on peut se le dire on est
entre nous il est tard du gouvernement
face aux effets de nos auditions
publiques bon un mot sur le périmètre
alors là je suis prise d'une double
sincérité franchement sans triste
il est évident il est évident que la
question des collectivités locales se
pose se pose il n'y a pas il y a pas de
volonté de ne pas traiter la question
des volontés de des collectivités
locales mais pour les régions les
départements les grandes métropoles les
intercommunalités c'est un sujet
à part entière et nous ne l'avons pas
traité durant notre commission d'enquête
nous n'avons pas eu une seule audition
sur le sujet nous n'avons consulté
aucune des associations d'élus c'est
pourquoi notre groupe sur ce sujet
s'absiendra sur les amendements pour une
raison très simple 1 ça n'a pas été
traité lors de la commission d'enquête
mais surtout les associations des lunes
n'ont pas été consultés et donc de notre
point de vue il est tout à fait
inacceptable de les intégrer dans ce
dispositif sans avoir été entendu donc
notre commission d'enquête a clairement
défini le périmètre la loi a en cas
enfin la proposition de loi est cadrée
sur les travaux de notre commission donc
les collectivités locales je vous
l'accorde monsieur le ministre et
j'accorde à mes collègues qui ont déposé
les amendements c'est un vrai sujet je
pense que de ce point de vue là on
pourra avoir une autre mission une
mission flash monsieur le ministre vous
pouvez nommer quelque parlementaires en
mission sur le sujet on pourra
d'ailleurs travailler aussi sur les
centrales d'achat ce sera aussi
important sur les prestations de
conseils et le recours au cabinet
d'avocat le Conseil National des
Barreaux c'est vantés sur les réseaux
d'avoir obtenu un résultat et d'être
exclu du périmètre de contrôle voilà le
tweet mortifère
du Conseil national nous venons de faire
modifier la proposition de loi sur
l'encadrement des cabinets dit de
conseils cette proposition sénatoriale
prévoyait d'englober dans son périmètre
les prestations de conseil juridique oui
mais enfin monsieur le ministre vous
savez que sur les directives européennes
nous avons eu exactement le même type
d'irritant lorsque des cabinets
d'avocats montent sujet chers à mes
collègues du groupe communiste
républicains et citoyens et à Eric
Bocquet tout un tas de pyramides pour
faire de l'optimisation voire de les de
la fraude fiscale il était évident qu'il
fallait les rentrer dans les dispositifs
légaux donc bon le texte est comme ça
pour l'instant mais je pense que sur ce
sujet il faut travailler il faut
travailler avec les bâtonniers il faut
travailler dans le domaine réglementaire
et il faut améliorer les dispositifs de
transparence vous ne pouvez pas
consulter un cabinet d'avocat sur la loi
sur les mobilités en ignorant absolument
s'ils sont ou pas l'avocat de telles
compagnie de vélibres ou de tel autre
société pour lequel il y aurait sinon
des conflits d'intérêt du moins des
liens d'intérêt qui poseraient un
certain nombre de problèmes je pense que
ce sujet est un sujet extrêmement
important et qu'il faut le traiter parce
que encore une fois comme je l'ai dit au
début de mon intervention le conflit
d'intérêt et de mon vu le pire cancer de
la vie publique alors un petit mot sur
l'article 8 quand même qui va provoquer
quelques remue-ménères c'est des
nouveaux évidemment pouvoir de la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique bon moi je considère que c'est
une bonne disposition
et puis
il y a eu aussi un problème monsieur le
ministre pendant les débats auxquels
j'ai quand même été relativement
présente
toutes ces toutes ces toutes ces
prestations de conseils n'ont absolument
aucune coordination ni avec France
stratégie
ni avec le Commissariat aux plans
et je dois dire que ce défaut
d'articulation nous a laissé intentiner
songeur donc le rapport fourmi de 7300
documents 4 millions d'euros pour
McKinsey 41 millions pour 68 commandes
pour la crise sanitaire 485000 euros
pour l'étude sur la réduction du temps
des attentes des demandes d'asile dont
on sait très bien que ça n'a pas du tout
fonctionné sans parler de McKinsey agent
de liaison entre l'État et les agences
de santé publique pour 169
4440 euros n'est ce pas pour 5 mois
d'études tout cela nous semble pas du
tout raisonnable je pense que cette
commission d'enquête est une excellente
plus value pour notre Haute Assemblée
que c'était c'est une haute plus-value
pour le travail parlementaire et c'est
une haute plus-value pour le travail
républicain que nous menons je vous
remercie
si j'ai un collègue
et la parole la parole est à Monsieur
Jérôme bachère pour les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
Président de la commission d'enquête
madame la rapporteur du texte et même la
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
mais chers collègues pour reprendre
tolérant suffisant et insuffisant
c'était un latitude du gouvernement
lorsque cette commission d'enquête a été
créée lorsqu'elle a rendu ses
conclusions
à l'époque votre prédécesseur monsieur
le ministre
a fait fi un peu de nos remarques j'ai
même entendu à l'époque un jeune
essaillon porte-parole du gouvernement
que façon cette enquête avait été faite
par une rapporteur communiste je
l'entends encore à la radio le dire
oublions par la même que ce rapport avec
été adopté à l'unanimité du Sénat et
donc ici avec des collègues de tous les
dents bon c'est pas grave c'était une
erreur de plus et cette erreur elle n'a
pas été cessé de tenter de la corriger
effectivement cela a été rappelé par mes
collègues précédemment qui une
circulaire le jour ont commencé la
commission d'enquête qui un autre
rapport ailleurs qui le jaune maintenant
bon on voit bien que on court un peu
après tout ça on n'est pas très à l'aise
et bien nous rassurez-vous
on n'est pas là pour accuser les uns ou
les autres on est là pour faire notre
travail de parlementaires en lien avec
l'exécutif en lien avec l'administration
qui va donc devoir se priver un petit
peu de ses cabinets de conseils
rassurez-vous le Sénat et absolument pas
contre l'utilisation des cabinets de
conseil notamment en matière
informatique voilà des voilà des choses
que l'on apprend en faisant beaucoup
alors quand vous menez un seul projet
informatique important dans une
administration et bien vous n'avez pas
cet apprentissage mais ce n'est pas le
cas mes chers collègues de la haute
fonction publique française et je
voudrais juste te dire un mot à mon ami
Nicole Duranton lorsqu'elle dit oui les
Allemands ils font plus que nous et oui
mais la haute fonction publique
allemande c'est pas du tout la même
chose que l'autre fonction publique
française
sommes-nous en manque de haut
fonctionnaire en France de qualité je ne
crois pas combien de préfets sont en
dorénavant au sésat un petit peu être
ennuyé combien de personnes
recyclent-t-on parfois la ligase des
anciens ministres très compétents qui a
un inspection générale des finances
d'ailleurs le président de la République
lui-même a dit je supprime les nains
pourquoi parce que dans les cordes
d'inspection ça serait bien quand même
aussi qu'il y a des gens d'expérience
ça tombe bien c'est ce qu'on a c'est ce
qu'on fait et on les utilise pas dans
l'ordre de la RGPP et ici quelques-uns
peuvent s'en souvenir et bien c'est
simple on a beaucoup utilisé les cordes
d'inspection de toutes espèces qui ont
certes jamais eu autant de travail mais
c'était très important il avait fallu à
ce moment-là une fois que vous avez
mobilisé tous ces corps-là avoir de
temps en temps un peu d'expérience des
cabinets de conseils alors oui il faut
utiliser les hauts fonctionnaires alors
certes je comprends que ça plaise pas
tellement la dictée qui est telle une
préfecture ils avaient les crédits et
puis s'aperço que les ministères en font
aussi alors le préfet c'est la même
chose il s'occupe de représenter l'état
sur le territoire mais en même temps il
a pas l'éducation nationale il a pas les
agences de santé et puis il a pas non
plus les mystères des finances c'est des
défis ne lui répondent pas non plus donc
et bien la dictée c'est exactement la
même chose elle croit centralisée et en
fait il y avait des plaintes de dépenses
de partout c'est ce qui a bien révélé la
commission d'enquête et donc on voit
bien que il y a encore à faire monsieur
le ministre je suis sûr que de votre
bonne volonté car je crois que vous vous
avez compris que nous n'étions pas là
uniquement pour vous embêter mais pour
mieux faire fonctionner l'administration
française alors je vous ai entendu j'ai
entendu certains de nos collègues parler
des collectivités locales alors faut
quand même pas exagérer dans les
collectivités locales pour ceux qui sont
encore élus dans les départements je
suis pas sûr qu'il y a nos finances on
fasse beaucoup à peine au cabinet aux
honoraires comme cela non plus envie de
dire monsieur le ministre pas vous
pas vous quand ma mère me disait quand
ne commence pas à dire que tu as mal
rangé que ton frère a mal rangé sa
chambre alors que la tienne est horrible
voilà l'état de
l'administration centrale n'est pas bon
sur les cabinets de conseils à l'époque
donner des conseils aux collectivités
locales commencer par ranger votre
chambre avant d'aller voir chez les
autres ça me paraît de bonne politique
enfin un sujet qui est très important
pour moi qui sait les sujets de
souveraineté de donner parce que pour
McKinsey pourquoi ce sont-ils payer
aussi cher et 10 on a des bases de
données incroyables et c'est ça aussi
qu'on met à disposition c'est comme ça
qu'ils font les facturations qui
oublient de payer les impôts du coup et
bien ces données elles sont aux
États-Unis et du coup les lois
américaines s'appliquent sur des données
et y compris des données françaises qui
peuvent être sensibles et quoi qu'on
fasse qu'on ne peut pas les surveiller
alors juste un mot pour terminer je
crois que avec cette proposition de loi
comme dirait le président de la
République l'abondance est terminée pour
les cabinets de conseils
très bien merci la parole est à Monsieur
Michael valait pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur mon
camarade Jean-Pierre sur vous aurez
exposé la position du groupe socialiste
sur les grandes lignes du texte je me
concentrerai pour ma part sur l'article
7 qui impose au cabinet conseil
travaillant pour l'état de bien vouloir
s'il vous plaît employer la langue
française dans les échanges avec
l'administration et dans la rédaction de
leur document cet article est issu d'une
des recommandations de cette commission
d'enquête où j'ai siéger avec plaisir et
grâce à laquelle nous avons pu mesurer
ce qui se passe dans les coulisses de
ces marchés publics ou diapositives
après diapositive les cabinets offrent
les solutions adéquates que ne saurait
trouver par elle-même les
administrations
j'aurais pu dire pour me faire mieux
comprendre de l'écosystème qui nous
occupe et qui nous écoutent peut-être
que j'ai fait partie du board de la
commission qui a mesuré bien dessine
comment slide après slide les
consultants junior et seniors d'un même
practice font des propal pour offrir les
bons feedbacks et les killer Ling à leur
prospects publics chers collègues si
comme moi vous n'entendez rien à ce
sabire rassurez-vous la commission
d'enquête je remercie Eliane assassin à
annexer au rapport un glossaire du
vocabulaire dont les cabinets conseils
inondent leurs clients mais
inquiétez-vous et inquiétons-nous de la
situation qui a rendu ce glossaire
malheureusement indispensable
lors de son audition le PDG de la Poste
a déclaré que le recours trop
systématique au cabinet faisait courir
le risque je cite d'un nouveau
conformisme ce conformisme passe par la
langue et conduit un appauvrissement de
la pensée
ce globish qui n'est même pas de
l'anglais est en fait un instrument de
formatage nombreux sont les
fonctionnaires et les citoyens ils l'ont
dit à en concevoir une souffrance
certaine
la France a un rapport particulier à la
puissance publique et à l'administration
qui lui est propre Villers-Cotterêts
n'est pas Wall Street et ce rapport
entre la France et son administration ne
peut être appréhendée par les seuls
cadres de pensée outre-Atlantique ceci
correspondent parfaitement à la culture
anglo-saxonne et c'est une grande
culture mais ce n'est pas la nôtre et
elle ne permet pas de développer
souverainement notre propre vision de
l'action publique la légère modification
de la loi tout bon proposer dans ce
texte ne saurait être résumé à une
approche passéiste consistant à
regretter le bon vieux temps de
l'imparfait du subjonctif ou de la
marine à voile ce n'est pas non plus la
recherche d'une langue pure car une
langue figée est une langue finie c'est
un fantasme morbide que je laisse aux
réactionnaires on doit accepter
l'intégration et même avec gourmandise
de mots étrangers ou nouveaux lorsqu'ils
recouvre mieux que n'importe quel autre
une réalité que notre langue parfois ne
décrit pas
en revanche lorsque le mot existe en
français et surtout j'arrive au point
essentiel lorsqu'il est parfaitement
entendu de tous les citoyens il doit
être employé pour que les gens se
comprennent entre eux c'est un impératif
démocratique autant qu'un refus de
l'antre soi une récente étude du
creddock sur le sujet rappelle je cite
cette attachement magnifique à la langue
qui se décline à travers l'expression de
la nécessité de service public
exemplaires sur le sujet c'est ce
qu'exprime l'article 7 de la présente
proposition de loi dans un contexte où
les gouvernements de longue date ne
respectent ni la loi tout bon ni des
dispositions réglementaires prises en
application de celle-ci ni les
circulaires primo ministériels qui
s'imposent à l'administration les tchuss
France French tech business France
France Connect frenching pack start-up
nation bottom up et autres cluster sont
autant d'agressions creusant le fossé
entre le peuple et ses représentants il
faut en avoir conscience quand on est
payé par le contribuable on le sert dans
sa langue ça vaut pour l'administration
comme pour ses dirigeants comme pour ses
prest en février dernier l'Académie
française a publié un rapport sous-titré
pour que les institutions françaises
parlent français on en est rendu là tout
de même en juin dernier le ministre
québécois la langue française en visite
à Paris nous invitait avec émotion à ne
pas laisser son gouvernement seul dans
la bataille nous devons les entendre
nous avons une occasion rare de
renforcer utilement la loi tout bon
monsieur le ministre saisons là d'aucun
inscrirez sur leur slide de conclusion
que c'est Nao en ever pour réaffirmer
les principes linguistiques mais avec
l'audace dont nous savons faire preuve
au Sénat et sur tous les bancs et
beaucoup plus clairement nous pouvons
dire que c'est maintenant ou jamais je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues et le dernier
orateur et Monsieur Stéphane Sautarel
pour les républicains
et également pour 4 minutes
le président monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame la rapporteur je vais
d'abord saluer l'initiative des auteurs
de cette PPL et les assassin
dont on a pu mesurer la nécessité lors
de la commission d'enquête relative à
l'influence des cabinets de conseil sur
les politiques publiques à laquelle j'ai
eu l'honneur de participer c'est donc
avec la conviction de la nécessité de
cet encadrement que j'ai consigné cette
PPL pour laquelle je salue également le
travail de la rapporteur Cécile ku
Karmen
je ne vais pas développer ici les
risques que l'emprise des cabinets
conseils peut faire peser sur la
démocratie et la légitimité des
responsables publics chacun les connaît
désormais un moment de fatigue
démocratique forte que connaît notre
pays à un moment où la confiance est
pour le moins distendu entre les
pouvoirs publics et les concitoyaux
citoyens il convient un effet de
compléter notre arsenal législatif pour
encadrer ces pratiques en définir le
périmètre en piloter l'intervention la
rendre transparente en encadré les
pratiques et protéger les données de
l'administration je vais me borner ici
dans le temps qui met un parti à aborder
deux aspects de ce texte
l'interdiction des prestations gratuites
qui a déjà abordé à nos voisins et la
protection des données j'avais beaucoup
insisté leurs auditions comme lors du
rendu du rapport de la commission
d'enquête sur ce point majeur appelé
aussi probos ces prestations dénuées de
tout fondement juridique peuvent
répondre à une stratégie du pied dans
peu importe visant à développer un
réseau d'influence auprès des décideurs
politiques et de l'administration voire
à orienter des politiques publiques je
me réjouis que le texte pose le principe
de l'interdiction de prestation à titre
gratuit l'équilibre proposé qui vise à
autoriser des missions réalisées dans le
cas du mécénat d'entreprise au profit de
certains organismes ou œuvres d'intérêt
général me semble bon il conviendra bien
sûr d'un évaluer la mise en œuvre et la
porter pour s'assurer à la fois qu'il
n'y ait pas de dérive et que ces
organismes d'intérêt général ne soient
pas par ailleurs privés de cette
ressource
le deuxième aspect que je me souligné
concerne la protection des données de
l'administration s'il est essentiel
d'éviter toute confusion entre le
consultant et l'administration de
l'action publique comme le prévoit le
texte il est tout aussi essentiel de
s'assurer que les données de
l'administration utilisées par les
cabines et conseils soient protégés il
s'agit bien sûr d'une utilisation pour
une finalité autre que l'exécution de la
mission
confiée à la CNIL sans obligation
d'aviser le prestataire avant une
éventuelle vérification sur place le
contrôle de cette suppression de toutes
les données m'apparait une mesure
équilibrée comme la
htvp mobilisée pour éviter tout conflit
d'intérêt le recours à la CNIL
possiblement autorisé par le juge de la
détention des libertés me semble relever
d'un bon usage de nos autorités
indépendantes
cette PPL exemplaire en témoigne les
nombreuses réactions du gouvernement
suite à la Commission de contrôle dont
une circulaire
insuffisante de janvier 2022 qui a été
déjà cité comprend bien d'autres volets
qui vont faire avancer nos pratiques
démocratiques grâce à l'action du
Parlement l'examen détaillé permettra de
souligner chacune de ces avancées dont
je me réjouis par avance notamment en
matière de transparence et de
proportionnalité
éclairer les décisions oui et nous avons
besoin plus que jamais de dialogue et
d'expertise pour le faire avant de
s'accorder sur le diagnostic avant
d'engager l'action orienter les
décisions par des priorisations de
scénario bâti par les cabinets au
travers de chemin pré-ballisés non nous
ne devons pas être nous non plus des
dépossédés comme certains leçons dans
cette société aujourd'hui je vous
remercie pour votre attention et je vous
encourage bien sûr à accompagner les
débats et à voter cette PPL merci
beaucoup
la discussion générale est donc close et
nous passons à la discussion du texte la
commission commençons par l'article 1er
et Madame Muller
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord je souhaite remercier mes
collègues pour le travail remarquable et
inédit qu'ils ont accompli la commission
d'enquête du Sénat a permis de révéler
l'omniprésence des cabinets de conseils
au cœur de l'État et leur influence sur
des décisions stratégiques notamment
dans des domaines régaliens à ce propos
j'avais déposé des amendements visant à
exclure la dimension stratégique des
prestations de conseils pour prévenir
l'affaiblissement de l'État l'abandon de
sa souveraineté et de ses compétences
j'ai bien conscience des difficultés
rédactionnelles et techniques qu'ils
engendrent et j'accepte leur retrait
il faut le souligner de plus en plus la
vie quotidienne des Français est envahie
par des recommandations de cabinets de
conseils internationaux qui uniformise
les mêmes stratégies partout dans le
monde dans les domaines aussi importants
que ceux de la santé de l'éducation de
la justice ou de l'énergie à titre
d'exemple l'omniprésence du cabinet
McKinsey pendant la crise sanitaire
illustre l'ensemble des dérives que
cette proposition de loi devra encadrer
qu'il s'agisse du confinement des tests
PCR des campagnes vaccinales des aides
covides McKinsey a piloté toutes les
étapes de la stratégie sanitaire
d'autres pays ont décliné les mêmes
politiques et ont appliqué les mêmes
scénarios recommandés par ce cabinet
il serait urgent de stopper la stratégie
du copier-coller qui finalement nous
entraîne de crise en crise il serait
urgent de stopper la
déresponsabilisation des décideurs il
serait enfin urgent de retrouver une
stratégie qui relève du courage
politique et des intérêts de notre pays
merci
commençons par l'amendement numéro 19
présenté par Madame durante donc à la
parole merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement prévoit l'instauration d'un
seuil à partir duquel les établissements
publics de l'État entreraient dans le
champ d'application de la loi nous
jugeons en effet nécessaire de ne pas
faire peser une charge déraisonnable sur
des entités de taille réduite pour
lequel les enjeux sont limités parmi ces
entités figure notamment les chambres
départementales d'agriculture la
majorité des CROUS certaines écoles de
formation de la fonction publique
certains musées de tailles réduites
ainsi que certains établissements
publics fonciers concrètement nous
proposons de limiter l'application de la
loi aux établissements publics dont les
dépenses de fonctionnement sont
supérieurs à 60 millions d'euros ce
seuil correspond à celui des avances
obligatoires versées au PME dans le
cadre d'un marché public pour certains
certains établissements publics de
l'État avec ce
seuls les plus gros établissements
publics de l'État rentreraient dans le
champ d'application de la loi je pense
notamment à la CNAM à voies navigable de
France à l'Union des groupements
d'achats publics ainsi qu'à météos
France notre amendement prévoit
également la suppression de la Linéa 4
qui est
répondre qui répondant avec l'alinéa 2
les établissements publics de santé sont
en effet une catégorie d'établissements
publics de l'État
merci la parole à Madame la rapporteur
oui merci
bien évidemment ce sera comme je l'ai
laissé entendre dans mon propos
liminaire un avis défavorable non pas
parce que la question je l'ai dit du
seuil serait
devrait être balayé d'un revers de
manche tout d'abord vous l'avez dit nous
pouvons citer un certain nombre
d'établissements si ce seuil a été
retenu mais pour beaucoup d'autres nous
n'arrivons pas encore mais en tout cas
n'ont pas les éléments suffisants les
chiffres consolidés pour ça réellement
quels établissements entreraient ou non
dans le champ de l'application de cette
proposition de loi si nous retenions ce
seuil des 60 millions et j'entends
l'argument que vous pouvez donner qui
est certes un seuil connu encore
faudrait-il pouvoir l'expertiser pour
savoir pour en connaître la pertinence
dans l'application de cette proposition
de loi et donc comme je l'ai déjà dit en
commission comme je l'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire ce mon avis défavorable
parce que la Commission n'a pas souhaité
en l'état retenir de seuil
merci monsieur le Président pour ma part
j'ai mettrai un avis favorable sur cet
amendement qui porte donc les deux
dispositions je passe sur la première
qui font davantage légistique de
réintégrer cet établissements publics de
santé dans les établissements publics
puisqu'ils en sont pour porter sur le
deuxième point l'amende qui vise à fixer
un seuil qui dans mon sens va dans le
bon sens puisqu'il va dans le sens de
l'effectivité la proportionnalité de la
loi qui est portée je pense que ça
permettra de concentrer l'application de
la loi sur les établissements à la fois
qui sont les plus exposés au risque et à
la prévention qu'on doit avoir sur les
risques de conflit d'intérêt mais aussi
cela même qui sont les plus à même
d'intégrer la contrainte administrative
qui va avec la proposition de loi je
crois que ça n'enlèvera pas dans les
établissements publics concernés les
établissements qui sont visés je pense à
Lucas à luga évidemment vous l'avez
mentionné je pense à Pôle emploi je
pense à des universités je pense au plus
nouveaux établissement public de santé
je veux dire ici que ça représentera les
500 plus gros établissements publics je
crois que c'est là l'enjeu et la visée
de la proposition de loi et donc je veux
affirmer ma position favorable
sincèrement
qu'a pu vous demander la parole
pardon c'est une erreur donc je mets aux
voix l'amendement 19
la parole
explication de vote il l'a
merci monsieur le Président ce ministre
la déontologie c'est pas une affaire de
chiffre d'affaires
voilà que ça soit
un établissement qui brasse des sommes
considérables ou un établissement plus
modeste il doit absolument se garantir
de tout conflit d'intérêt voilà
je ne vois vraiment pas ce que la notion
de chiffre d'affaires vient faire
là-dedans enfin chiffre d'affaires ou de
budget de fonctionnement si vous
préférez donc la version de la
commission me paraît tout à fait
raisonnable ensuite on verra comment
fonctionne tout ça mais enfin encore une
fois c'est pas du tout une affaire de
recettes et de dépenses de
fonctionnement mais bel et bien une
affaire de déontologie de promotion des
conflits d'intérêts qui sont en effet le
cancer de la vie publique comme le
rappelait Nathalie Goulay il faut que
nous soyons transigeant et on ne peut
pas d'emblée réduire la portée et
l'ambition de cette PPL dès le premier
amendement je ne voterai donc pas cet
amendement
un autre rapide parce que je pense qu'on
a tous la volonté d'avancer dans les
débats et pas faire des longs débats dès
le premier à un moment simplement
indiquer que la position de gouvernement
elle porte pas sur une position des
vincées de contraintes déontologiques un
certain nombre d'établissements publics
mais simplement de façon extrêmement
réaliste la proposition de loi porte un
certain nombre de contraintes
administratives qui sont tout à fait
fondées et j'en soutiendrai l'immense
majorité dans cette proposition de loi
et simplement pour que cette loi soit
effective il faut qu'il y ait une
proportionnalité dans les contraintes
que peuvent absorber les établissements
publics je pense qu'il y a juste titre
les sénatrices Duranton mentionné un
certain nombre d'établissements publics
dont on voit qu'il serait en grande
difficulté très opérationnelle tout
simplement pour appliquer ce que vous
proposez et donc cet amendement devient
à mon sens pas moins de rire la portée
la proposition de loi mais au contraire
la renforcer je voulais clarifier cette
position
la présidente assassie à la parole merci
merci d'être président bon moi j'entends
bien
l'abonnement déposé par d'autres
collègues qui par ailleurs étaient
membres de la commission de notre
commission d'enquête et qui a validé
notre notre rapport donc j'entends bien
mais sont son amendement en fait
viserait à réduire la portée et donc
l'ambition de notre proposition de loi
et je voudrais quand même rappeler que
ce seuil de 60 millions d'euros n'a
aucune cohérence en fait il existe dans
le code de la commande publique mais
pour tout à fait autre chose c'est à
dire pour le versement des avances donc
sur le fond comme là comme cela a été
dit par le président Bazin on ne connaît
pas la liste des établissements
publics qui seraient exclus donc de
cette PPL on peut quand même citer
l'Institut national du service public
c'est-à-dire l'ex ena l'École nationale
de la magistrature le NF et certaines
agences de l'eau ou certaines agences
régionales de santé donc nous préférons
la clarté du texte de la commission et
je crois que la PPL doit concerner tous
les établissements publics de l'État
pour éviter justement les effets de
seuil
je mets le voile amendement 19 qui a
fait l'objet de la vie défavorable de la
commission et favorable du Gouvernement
quelles sont ceux qui sont pour
contre
pas adopté ensuite l'amendement 27
de monsieur Sueur qui merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement a pour objet de
préciser le périmètre de la loi en
mentionnant explicitement qu'elle
s'applique à la Caisse des Dépôts et
Consignation qui comme vous le savez n'a
ni le statut d'établissement public de
l'État ni d'autorité administrative au
public indépendante
avis de la commission
comme ça vient d'être rappelé la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations
effectivement ni établissement public de
l'État ni autoritaire administrative
indépendante cependant elle faisait bien
partie du travaux du périmètre des
travaux de la commission d'enquête et
donc pour ces raisons là ce sera un avis
favorable
gouvernement
je mettrai pour ma part un navet de
sagesse monsieur le Président
effectivement la Caisse des Dépôts c'est
un établissement
à part effectivement il fait déjà
l'objet d'un contrôle parlementaire
puisque
sa commission de surveillance est
présidée par un parlementaire en
l'occurrence qu'on pourrait envisager
effectivement le fait que ce contrôle
soit déjà existant qu'il puisse être
considéré un peu à part mais je préfère
la mettre un avis de sagesse si la Haute
Assemblée souhaite l'intégrer dans le
périmètre de la profession de loi
un petit élément d'explication parce que
quand on est écrit la Caisse des dépôts
en fait le texte qui le régisse et
dorénavant la Caisse des dépôts et ses
filiales et non pas la caisse des pots
seulement typiquement lors de la
commission d'enquête nous avons entendu
Philippe Val le PDG de la Poste qui est
dorénavant filiale de la Caisse des
Dépôts avec le contrôle exclusif et
c'est notamment tout cela parce que la
caisse d'EPO c'est bien mais c'est
dorénavant le groupe que les dépôts ou
la Caisse des dépôts et ses filiale
comme dit le texte donc moyennant cela
ça pourrait être corrigé dans une
navette car vous ne manquerez pas
monsieur le ministre n'inscrire à
l'Assemblée nationale
je mets aux voix ah pardon
non on a eu des avis
donc je mets aux voix
le l'amendement 27 avec un avis
favorable de la commission et un avis de
sagesse du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre est à l'opté nous avons
ensuite quatre amendements en discussion
commune nous commençons par le premier
rectifié le 1 rectifié de Monsieur
Riquet oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur collègue notre collègue des cas
souligner lors de la discussion générale
cette proposition de loi est la
bienvenue ses apports sont indéniables
je veux le redire avec force il lui
reste simplement un écueil que je vous
propose de corriger ça d'attendre par la
suite de la navette une partie de
l'administration publique a été oubliée
comme l'état donc relativité prennent
des décisions politiques qui tient pas
que la vie ne concitoyens et comme
l'état social de faire appel à les
consultants engageant ainsi les finances
publiques aussi n'apparaît pas tout à
fait absurde vouloir mieux encadrer ses
recours mais si nous savons qu'il existe
déjà des mécanismes le permettant que ce
soit par le biais les coûts régional des
comptes ou du contrôle par l'opposition
les mécanismes ça suffit à endiguer les
phénomènes parfois désastreux tel que le
recours aux emprunts toxiques il faudra
renforcer la transparence et le contrôle
y compris l'administration décentralisée
ces responsabilité du Sénat que de
répondre aux problématiques des
territoires c'est maintenant propose
donc d'inclure dans le périmètre de
cette loi les correctivités
territoriales et leurs établissements
publics à la section des communes de
moins de 10 000 habitants ainsi que les
intercommunalités à l'exception des
communautés de communes je pense que
c'est seuil étaient trop bas aussi ils
ont également déposé un amendement de
repli qui est le numéro 45 avant de
repli qui retient comme limite 100.000
habitants ainsi que l'intergalité à
l'exception des communautés de communes
merci président
ensuite le second amendement discussion
commune monsieur Sueur merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues il y a d'abord un préalable
certains pensent que la loi le projet de
loi doit
correspondre exactement au périmètre de
la commission d'enquête
ils disent on ne peut pas aller au-delà
mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi
nous sommes des législateurs nous
pouvons déposer des amendements et si
nous trouvons qu'on peut élargir le
champ qu'il faut le faire je ne vois pas
pourquoi on ne le ferait pas
c'est pourquoi nous proposons par cet
amendement de détendre les bienfaits de
cette loi aux collectivités locales avec
un seuil qui est différent de celui
présenté par notre collègue et amis
monsieur Ruquier dans son premier
amendement mais conforme à celui du
second amendement c'est-à-dire qu'il
nous paraît sage d'exclure les communes
de moins de 100.000 habitants mais
d'appliquer les règles qui sont fixées
dans le texte aux communes de plus de
100.000 habitants aux autres
collectivités locales et aux
intercommunalités de plus de 100.000
habitants
le 45 a été présenté par Monsieur
Ruquier et donc il nous reste le 44
présenté par le gouvernement
une seule président mon argumentation
sera assez similaire à celle qui vient
d'être portée par le testeur et le
président Ruquier au fond elle repose
sur la pression même qu'on a de la
proposition de loi soit on considère
cette proposition de loi elle est
punitive pour la puissance publique qui
s'applique je crois que ça n'est pas
votre cas et ça n'est pas mon cas ce
soir soit on considère que les
dispositions qui sont portées dans la
proposition de loi sont des dispositions
qui viennent renforcer les acteurs
publics qui sont concernés et à ce
moment là je vois effectivement pas de
bonnes raisons pas inclure dans le champ
de bénéfice des dispositions qui sont
dans cette proposition de loi les
collectivités territoriales je crois
qu'il y a pas de débat ici ce soir sur
le fait que les collectivités
territoriales ont recours à des
organismes de conseils ça peut être une
région qui a recours parfois pour
quelques centaines de milliers d'euros
quand il s'agit de bâtir la politique
stratégique d'attractivité économique ça
peut être parfois un département qui a
recours à des missions pour quelques
dizaines de milliers d'euros quand il
s'agit de bâtir le schéma directeur en
matière de politique sociale ça peut
être parfois une collectivité une
métropole quand il s'agit de réorganiser
des services je prends la des exemples
concrets effectifs de la vraie vie de
ces différentes collectivités et donc je
considère comme certains ici sur
différents bancs de l'Assemblée que
l'intégration des collectivités est pas
punitive à leur égard mais au contraire
permet d'étendre le chant de la loi et
de leur en faire bénéficier sur la
question du seuil je crois effectivement
vous m'entendrez souvent parler de
proportionnalité ce soir mais que il y a
une bonne forme de proportionnalité à
considérer que les collectivités au
dessus de 100.000 habitants c'est à dire
les régions les départements des 42
communes les plus importantes soit
concernées à la fois parce que elles ont
de la même façon que sur l'amendement
précédent la
capacité à intégrer les contraintes
administratives pour pouvoir répondre et
se mettre en conformité avec tes
dispositions de la PPL et parce que je
crois qu'elle a un champ prioritaire
pour regarder si il y a effectivement
vocation à les protéger de conflits et
la raison pour laquelle pour ma part et
au nom du gouvernement j'ai déposé un
amendement à 100000 qui est d'une
écriture un tout petit peu différente
par rapport aux amendements qui ont été
déposés considérant que les EPCI de plus
de 100 000 habitants doivent être pris
en compte et pas toutes tailles de PCI
c'est la seule différence entre les
amendements qu'on a pu déposer
alors la vie de la commission sur les
quatre amendements madame la rapporteur
comme je l'ai également déjà dit la
discussion sur les collectivités
territoriales et légitime donc la
question n'est certainement pas de
balayer très rapidement se débat là
cependant je veux également dire puisque
chacun pose préalable à mon collègue
Jean-Pierre sure que personne ne dit que
la loi ne peut pas aller plus loin en
revanche je vous ai proposé en
concertation avec les auteurs dans la
commission des lois un équilibre
politique qui respecte effectivement
l'accord tel que sortie de la commission
d'enquête et qui rassemble l'ensemble
des auteurs de cette proposition de loi
qui est un point d'équilibre et qui vise
en tout cas lors de cette première
lecture ici au Sénat à ne pas trop
déroger et ne pas aller sur des champs
qui n'ont été ni investiguer par la
commission d'enquête ni investiguer
j'oserais dire humblement par la
rapporteur de la commission que je suis
ensuite je souhaite dire également le
faire remarquer peut-être avec un peu
d'ironie vu l'heure tardive que il y a
effectivement c'est un vrai sujet il y a
quatre amendements avec des rédactions
différentes avec des seuils différents
avec des collectivités ou en tout cas
alors regroupement qui ne sont pas
toujours les mêmes j'oserai dire preuve
en est s'il en avait besoin que cela
demande un peu de temps un peu
d'expertise pour être au plus juste et
puis enfin et peut-être parce que nous
sommes ici au Sénat je veux notamment
attirer l'attention tout d'abord de mes
collègues qui ont déposé de tels
amendements mais également il a encore
avec humilité monsieur le ministre de
vous-même je crois que à l'heure où on
demande beaucoup de concertation à
l'heure où nous voulons construire en
partant de la réalité des territoriales
construire en partant de la réalité
vécue par les beaucoup qu'il serait
malvenu mais surtout peu efficace peut
opérationnelle de faire entrer les
collectivités territoriales par la voix
de tels amendements sans même
s'interroger y compris sur les
conséquences que cela aurait sur un
certain nombre d'articles ou sur un
certain nombre en tout cas de mesures
previp prévues par les autres articles
pour les administrations de l'État et
qui donc de fait ne rendrait pas
effective l'application de cette
proposition de loi aux collectivités
territoriales et donc nous proposons
plutôt de pouvoir effectivement mener
mission commission d'enquête bref quel
qu'en soit la situation en tout cas de
travailler en profondeur avec les élus
locaux les représentations des
associations de collectivités
territoriales c'est vrai question de
l'utilisation s'il y en a excessive des
cabinets de conseils dans les
collectivités territoriales et des
règles de le déontologie qu'elles
doivent s'appliquer qu'elles doivent
mettre en oeuvre et qui seront
inévitablement différentes à certains
degrés que celles que l'on peut attendre
et mettre en place pour les
administrations de l'État
donc
défavorable sur les quatre merci
monsieur le ministre sur les trois
amendements qui n'est même pas de
gouvernement
oui madame la rapporteur vous avez
évoqué deux arguments au fond ok je
voudrais répondre le fait que il y
aurait un travail à mener pour parfaire
les dispositions qui seraient encore
devant nous vous avez évoqué un deuxième
argument qui est de dire au fond qu'on
mesure mal l'impact
réglementaire peut-être financier sur
les collectivités des dispositions qui
sont prises dans le texte
je veux évoquer deux contre arguments
sur l'étude d'impact et sur l'impact qui
aurait lieu sur les collectivités vous
n'avez pas eu ces réserves-là sur les
établissements publics de santé
il y a
220 hôpitaux locaux dans le texte de
mémoire 3300 établissements publics de
santé qui sont concernés je crois pas
que la commission d'enquête sanatorias
se soit penché sur les conséquences vous
avez auditionné Martin Hirsch je crois
que c'était
effectivement la seule audition qui
était menée pour pouvoir évoquer les
conséquences sur les établissements
publics de santé et aujourd'hui vous
évoquez cet argument pour dire au fond
on n'a pas pu le faire pour les
collectivités et puis vous avez dit
vous-même madame la rapporteur le texte
n'est pas un point d'arriver c'est un
point de départ c'est à dire qu'il y
aura une navette parlementaire on avait
parlé à plusieurs reprises ce soir j'ai
indiqué que je souhaitais que le texte
puisse cheminer et donc il est tout à
fait possible possible dans le temps de
la navette parlementaire de pouvoir
travailler et je veux le dire devant
vous je suis extrêmement ouvert sur la
forme vous avez évoqué le fait de nommer
des parlementaires en mission pour
pouvoir avancer sur ces questions-là moi
je suis prêt à le faire et à donner les
moyens à l'assemblée de le faire dans le
cadre de la navette parlementaire pour
pouvoir effectivement par faire le texte
envoie exactement les conséquences
concrètes donc vous voyez que j'ai une
position très sincère face à vous pour
défendre cette position d'intégrer des
collectivités à ce stade du texte qui je
vous cite est un point de départ qui
veut dire que vous êtes favorable au 3
amendements
je suis favorable à l'amendement
présenté par le gouvernement pour les
raisons évoquées je propose le retrait
des deux amendements similaires en tout
cas sur les seuils qui ont été déposés
pour la raison que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure de cohérence par rapport aux
EPCI si le seuil est au-dessus de 100000
je propose qu'il soit aussi de 100000
pour toute taille de collectivité et
c'est inclus dans les moments 44 de
mémoire du gouvernement et donc je vous
propose de retenir cette rédaction là
donc propose son de retrait pour les
deux précédents et à vivre favorable
évidemment sur l'amendement
gouvernemental
alors
d'abord monsieur Richard te souhaite
expliquer son vote
c'est le Président c'est le ministre mes
chers collègues
j'ai été de ceux qui en réunion de la
commission des lois ce sont émus de
l'absence des collectivités locales dans
le périmètre
d'intervention de ce texte et je dois
dire que je me suis interrogé sur la
possibilité de présenter un amendement
j'ai un peu travaillé et je dois dire
que j'ai été excusez-moi le terme
j'étais sec devant
ma feuille blanche
j'avoue que mon entrée en matière
c'était c'était celle qui a été
pratiquée par votre amendement monsieur
le ministre dire les régions les j'avoue
que j'ai pas pensé à la Guyane
excusez-moi j'ai pas pensé voilà
j'aurais pu penser à l'Alsace parce que
c'est plus proche de moi voilà enfin
cette région que j'espère retrouver
bientôt d'ailleurs à la place du Grand
Est mais c'est à notre débat mais
l'autre entrée c'était naturellement le
seuil
et le seuil j'ai vu Jean-Claude requier
m'excusera mais on passe de 10000 à 100
000 on sait pas pourquoi Jean-Claude ça
pouvait être 50000 ça coûte 20000 le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
conséquences sont quand même
relativement lourdes pour les
collectivités concernées et donc
franchement j'ai été convaincu par les
explications qui m'ont été données par
Madame la rapporteur en commission
répété ce soir
il faut vraiment mener un travail
approfondie sur ce dossier il n'a pas
été mené quelle que soit les formes qui
pourraient
être celle de cette concertation
nécessaire dans le cadre de ce travail
approfondie il me paraît indispensable
que celle-ci est lieu deuxièmement moi
je suis vraiment très sensible à
l'observation tout à l'heure de le
président de la commission monsieur
Bazin je crois que la question de la
déontologie l'emporte sur la question du
seuil nous avons tous en tête en tête
l'un ou l'autre cas d'espèces dans
certaines collectivités qui vaut mieux
ne pas citer pas ce soir qui amène à se
poser des questions en termes de
déontologie indépendamment du seuil et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
qu'il faut faire un travail approfondie
sur ce dossier moi je voterai contre
cette extension aujourd'hui mais je
répète il faudra faire ce travail et se
prendre le temps pour le faire
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en effet la question est
légitime et c'est une des premières
questions que nous nous sommes posées
avec Hélène assassy après la fin des
travaux de la commission d'enquête pour
savoir ce que nous allions retenir dans
la proposition de loi dont nous
débattons ce soir nous est assez vite
apparu qu'il ne fallait pas inclure les
collectivités territoriales pour les
raisons qu'à rappeler la rapporteur mais
je voudrais insister sur deux points qui
sont à mon sens tout à fait déterminant
le premier point c'est que l'influence
des cabinets de conseils sur l'état
concernent à l'évidence des sujets
beaucoup plus vastes y compris dans le
domaine de la défense nationale ou dans
le domaine sanitaire elles intéressent
toute la nation tandis que les décisions
prises dans un département ou dans une
région s'ils ne sont pas négligeables
sont quand même beaucoup plus limités
dans leur conséquences et puis surtout
surtout pourquoi est-ce que nous sommes
là parce que nous avons constaté qu'il
nécessaire de renforcer la transparence
on a dit transparence contrôle du
recours déontologie mais le premier
point c'est la transparence et il nous a
fallu tous les outils d'une commission
avec tous ses pouvoirs qui ne sont pas
minces auditions sous serment
communication obligatoire des documents
vérifications sur place et sur pièce
pour savoir ce que de l'État dépensait
en matière de cabinet de conseils de
consultant il nous a fallu tout ça donc
pour avoir notre rôle de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement il nous a fallu
tous ces moyens nous avons prévu de les
entrer de les faire entrer dans la loi
mais que se passe-t-il dans les
collectivités territoriales il y a des
assemblées délibérantes il y a des
oppositions il y a des communications
obligatoires de documents quand j'étais
président du département du Val-d'Oise
j'ai fourni à mon opposition tout un
ensemble de documents et ils ont le
compte administratif les contes de
gestion par ailleurs et puis il y a
aussi l'encadrement par les services de
l'État par la trésorerie qui vérifie que
les décisions sont conformes à ce qui a
été voté donc il y a tout un appareil
tout un contre-pouvoir qui est déjà en
place dans les collectivités locales ça
n'empêchera pas de se pencher sur le
sujet mais veut dire que les choses sont
absolument pas symétriques et absolument
pas comparables c'est pourquoi nous
avons choisi de ne pas retenir les
collectivités territoriales
[Musique]
mort on a parlé je crois que c'est
Madame Goulet tout à l'heure qui
proposait pourquoi pas une mission flash
mais des parlementaires pourraient aussi
demander une commission une mission
d'information une commission d'enquête
sur le sujet parce que c'est un vrai
sujet on ne se le cache pas il y a des
collectivités parmi les plus importantes
qui effectivement ont recours à des
cabinets privés mais aujourd'hui nous
n'avons aucune aucune donnée consolidée
sur le niveau des dépenses de Conseil
des Collectivités
Territoriales puis monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi mais il y a quand même un
paradoxe avoir à vous voir très disposer
pour étendre la PPL au collectivité
alors que vous avez déposé plusieurs
amendements pour réduire l'ambition de
notre texte sur ses propres services
et enfin Madame Gatel
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame la rapporteur
j'aurais tout d'abord à mon tour me
réjouir du travail qui a été conduit par
les présidents assassin et basins je
trouve que ça illustre parfaitement la
capacité du Sénat à dépasser l'écrivage
à prendre le temps de travailler sur le
fond sur des vrais questions et des
sujets importants monsieur le ministre
moi je partage la nécessité pour l'État
comme pour les collectivités de recourir
à des expertises extérieures et en tout
cas il n'est pas dans l'intention du
groupe centriste de pratiquer une sorte
de chasse aux sorcières maintenant nous
sommes tous d'accord sur la nécessité de
plus de transparence
d'exigences et de contrôle monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison se pose la
question des collectivités il ne
faudrait pas que quelqu'un en nous
écoutant ce soir il a l'impression que
nous nous dérobions
et que nous voulons échapper à la
transparence c'est pas le genre de la
maison et cette autre chambre voilà mais
monsieur le ministre vous avez salué la
qualité la rigueur du travail qui a été
fait la qualité et la rigueur conduisent
avoir eu une expertise une évaluation
faire des propositions maintenant la
mission elle a écarté de son champ de
travail les collectivités maintenant
vous voyez bien que nous disons tous
qu'il y a un champ investiguer mais
pardonnez-nous nous n'allons pas décider
à la hussard à 24 heures enfin même un
peu plus de ce qu'il va arriver au
collectivité alors même que nous ne les
avons pas entendu et que nous ne cessons
vous comme nous y compris le président
de la République et les collectivités de
déplorer le fait qu'il peut arriver à
quelqu'un prendre une décision sur un
coin de table ou au coin d'un fauteuil
d'imposer puis après on se dit zut ça ne
marche pas donc monsieur le ministre
d'ailleurs si je peux me permettre son
malice je me pourquoi sur votre
amendement il manque les métropoles de
Marseille et de Paris qui ont un statut
particulier mais peut-être ai-je mal lu
la votre proposition et qu'on voit bien
qu'on a un éventail de proposition qui
nécessite monsieur le ministre avec
sérieux et avec exigence d'aller
investir mais ce soir je pense que vous
seriez le premier à recruter ce que nous
pourrions faire parce que l'enfer est
pavé de bonnes intentions donc que la
mission soit poursuivie ici ou que
l'Assemblée nationale prenne le sujet
moi je suis ok mais sincèrement on peut
pas décider d'un truc comme ça sans en
avoir parlé aux associations des lieux
merci monsieur le président
sur le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues d'abord vous dire
j'ai été maire j'ai été président d'une
intercommunalité j'étais président d'un
syndicat mixte j'ai été président d'un
département également vous dire que j'ai
pu constater des dérives en matière de
recours à des cabinets conseils et je
fais un pas par rapport aux enjeux
déontologiques je parle plutôt sur le
contenu de ce recours parce que il est
parfois fait recours parce que la loi
suscite ce recours à des cabinets
conseils à travers des exigences telles
que les rabboration d'un certain nombre
de documents stratégiques de
développement ou autre à travers des
documents d'urbanisme et que cela peut
avoir des conséquences particulières
tout d'abord la standardisation des
approches sur la manière d'aborder les
sujets on a des formes de peu de
copier-coller alors sinon matériel au
moins intellectuel un moment où il nous
faut repenser l'ensemble des concepts
l'ensemble des compromis sur les
différents enjeux de société
également et évoqué souvent par rapport
à des documents ou en tout cas des des
schémas qui ne sont comment exigés une
absence parfois une insuffisance de
maîtrise des travaux par les
fonctionnaires de la collectivité
territoriale parfois par les élus qui
conduit à une forme entre guillemets de
délégation de pouvoir il s'agit à
travers effectivement ce regard sur
l'intervention des cabinets conseils de
s'assurer que on n'a pas cette facilité
du recours au Cabinet des conseils et
que ce soit effectivement réservé là où
il est nécessaire d'avoir des expertises
en particulier techniques nécessaires
pour pouvoir mener et définir les
politiques locales
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre un mot pour pour compléter ce
qu'a dit Françoise guettal tout à fait
légitimement est-ce que j'avais annoncé
à la tribune de d'une double sincérité
très centriste nous allons nous abstenir
sur l'ensemble de ces de ces amendements
parce qu'effectivement il y a un sujet
donc il est pas question de voter contre
et en même temps le périmètre de la
mission et la nécessité d'avoir des
auditions et un travail plus précis fait
qu'on ne peut pas voter pour donc nous
obtiendrons
les discussions que nous avons sont très
intéressantes elles démontrent le fait
que ce texte est extrêmement complexe
d'un côté on dit la notion de
déontologie est une n'est pas une notion
de chiffre d'affaires ou de budget de
fonctionnement et donc on ne peut pas
l'appliquer aux établissements publics
administratifs de plus de 60 millions
d'euros de budget
seulement et de l'autre on dit on ne
peut pas
appliquer
cet article au collectivités
territoriales qui ont 100 000 habitants
c'est à dire un budget de fonctionnement
de près de 500 000 euros au moins
et on a dit aussi que la déontologie
elle commençait le conflit d'intérêt il
commençait dans c'était le cancer de
l'institution on voit bien et la
définition d'article le démonte qu'on a
une difficulté
à faire le périmètre et qu'il conduit en
fait un peu tout et son contraire sur le
même article c'est la raison pour
laquelle il me semble que ce texte n'est
pas prêt c'est la raison pour laquelle
je m'abstiendrai
non simplement sur quelques éléments qui
qui ont été apportées
je pense que jusque là
chacun a évité de caricaturer les propos
des autres donc il est important que
nous puissions d'abord continuer à
avancer ainsi donc voilà je pense
qu'aucun collègue ici
Nadi a aucun moment donné que la
question des collectivités territoriales
n'en était pas une la seule chose sur
laquelle je crois plusieurs alertes tout
d'abord
notre collègue Arnaud Basel rappelait
précédemment il existe aujourd'hui des
mécanismes alors je ne sais pas si on
doit dire de contrôle de régulation de
transparence ou d'information dans les
collectivités territoriales qui sont
différents de ceux qui sont mis
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des
administrations de l'État deuxièmement
cela a été dit par Madame Assassi par
Madame Gatel par un certain nombre
d'autres la volonté que cette question
des collectivités territoriales notre
collègue Richardt également
ne soit pas simplement entre guillemets
la roue tourne ou correspondant à tel
référence à l'article du code général
des collectivités territoriales mais
qu'il y ait plus largement une expertise
et surtout une réflexion avec celles et
ceux qui au quotidien les administres
c'est à dire les élus les élus locaux en
situation
d'exécutif aujourd'hui et puis mais je
le redis c'est à dire parce que je viens
d'entendre ce qui ce qui a été dit par
notre collègue Capu mais non aujourd'hui
cette proposition de loi
si on rentre les collectivités
territoriales effectivement je resterai
envie de dire je pourrais vous donner
raison tout un certain nombre d'articles
vont devenir
complètement incompréhensible mais par
exemple effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on
fait de ce que l'on exige à l'article 8
pour les collectivités territoriales
alors bon vous allez me dire monsieur le
ministre il veut de toute façon ils
veulent réécrire donc ça c'est pas c'est
pas trop grave mais j'ai envie de vous
dire je crois qu'il faut qu'on fasse
attention et qu'il y a justement une
cohérence trouvée jusque là que la
Commission en tout cas c'est c'est de
préserver c'est pour cela que je réaimer
des avis défavorables sur ces quatre
amendements
très rapide qui seront mes derniers mots
sur ce premier débat d'abord en
rebondissant sur le dernier point
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour les
établissements publics dont vous avez
choisi de ne pas mettre de seuil dans
l'article premier
en concernant un certain nombre de
mesures vous citer celle de l'article 8
c'est exactement la même question qui va
se poser pour certains établissements
publics de petite taille je veux
simplement notifier trois points sur les
sujets qui ont été abordés d'abord sur
la question des seuils je peux
comprendre le syndrome de la page
blanche au moment de rédiger je veux
simplement dire que le seuil et la
rédaction même que nous avons choisi
c'est l'exact
rédaction qui a été adoptée par cette
assemblée sur la loi de transparence de
la vie publique de 2013 exactement la
même donc d'une certaine façon je
voudrais enlever vos préventions sur ce
sujet là troisième point il me semble
monsieur le Président Bazin qui a un
argument qui est quelque peu circulaire
vous dites au fond il faut pas prendre
les mesures pour les collectivités parce
que nous n'avons pas une bonne
connaissance du recours aujourd'hui par
les collectivités au cabinet de conseils
mais justement la proposition de loi
dans les discussions que nous allons
avoir juste après sur les articles 3 4
et 8 permettent de faire plus de
transparence en listant les recours au
prestations par les cabinets de conseils
et puis dernier point vous dites au fond
ce sont pas exactement les mêmes enjeux
déontologiques pour l'État dans le champ
est plus large que pour un certain
nombre de collectivités c'est l'argument
que vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure
cet argument là pardon mais je ne peux
pas le partager les enjeux des
collectivités sont des enjeux de la vie
quotidienne des Français sur les
questions extrêmement centrales de
logements d'action sociale de transport
je crois que ce sont des enjeux sur
lesquels les enjeux de déontologie sont
tout aussi existants que ceux qui
concernent l'État et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je persiste à
émettre un amendement un avis favorable
sur ces amendements
je mets aux voix
mes chers collègues nous sommes toujours
d'accord pour finir cette nuit
nous sommes à trois quarts d'heure pour
ne pas encore avoir examiné 6
amendements
monsieur Riquier
mais je dis pour accélérer les choses
que je retire la bande-annonce numéro 1
et je retire le numéro 45 au profit du
44 entendu donc il nous reste
l'amendement 24 de monsieur Sueur que je
mets au bois
qui est pour
qui est contre
adopter
l'amendement 44 du gouvernement avec
avis défavorable de la commission qui
est pour
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté
nous avons ensuite
on est toujours sur l'Artic premier deux
amendements en discussion commune le 2
et le 3 de Madame Müller Brown
ils sont retirés merci
[Musique]
on finit sur l'article premier n'ont pas
encore d'ailleurs
avec l'amendement 22 de Madame Duranton
merci monsieur le président
c'est amant exclure du champ
d'application de la loi les prestations
de conseils en gestion de ressources
humaines nous considérons que ces
prestations à l'instar de l'aide
recrutement ne relève pas du conseil
stratégique mais vient essentiellement à
répondre aux besoins pratiques des
administrations
la vie de la Commission
que le projet de restructuration est
transformation peuvent en effet
comprendre un boulet relatif aux
ressources humaines et de fait supprimer
les mots et en gestion de ressources
humaines serait affaiblir la portée de
la loi le ministre
je peux mettre ou voir donc c'est un
monde monsieur bien sûr
juste un mot monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre cet amendement
consiste à déplumer considérablement la
loi parce qu'il y a beaucoup de recours
justement à des cabinets de conseils
pour des recrutements des évaluations
pour tout ce qu'on appelle ressources
humaines etc donc il est essentiel que
cela reste dans la loi
merci monsieur le Président chimiste
très très brièvement juste pour
illustrer je vous renvoie la page 244 du
rapport qui décrit ainsi une prestation
de site web en accompagnement ressources
humaines aide au recrutement d'un
analyse opérationnel à santé publique
France qui entrera en fonction le 23
septembre 2020
identification de profil recueil de CV
prise de contact proposition de profil
réalisation des entretiens avec SP avec
santé publique France matrice de
synthèse des candidats short listés donc
on est vraiment sur des sujets très très
délicats et pointus qui engagent des
politiques régaliennes de l'État c'est
pas du tout neutre
donc
je me vois le monde de Madame burnton le
20 avec un avis défavorables de la
Commission de vie favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre qui n'est pas adopté ensuite
deux amendements
en discussion commune mais monsieur
Segouin n'a pas d'autres signataires
donc il est pas défendu et donc
l'amendement 30 est présenté
présenté par nos collègues qui ne sont
pas en séance ce soir donc
c'est dommage puisque monsieur Capu
était avec nous jusqu'à il y a un
instant mais bien le blibler d'appliquer
le règlement nous avons encore un
amendement numéro 4 de Madame Müller
Brown
[Musique]
un numéro 5
également 6
il est aussi retiré
ensuite l'amendement 21 de Madame
Duranton
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vise à préciser la définition
des consultants au sens de la loi
l'article premier prévoit l'inclusion
dans la catégorie des consultants des
personnes physiques qui s'engagent à
titre individuel avec l'administration
bénéficiaire pour réaliser une
prestation de conseils s'il les termes
qui s'engagent renvoient assurément aux
personnes physiques ayant passé un
contrat avec l'administration
bénéficiaire les termes à titre
individuels sont quant à eux beaucoup
plus ambigueux et source de difficultés
d'interprétation une lecture extensive
de ces termes pourraient par exemple
conduire à inclure dans la définition
des consultants les agents contractuels
des droits publics où les vacataires
recrutés pour assurer des tâches
ponctuelles relevant des prestations de
conseils de telles agents sont en effet
des personnes physiques qui s'engagent à
titre individuel avec leur
administration d'emploi or il convient
de ne pas inclure les ressources
humaines internes à l'administration
dans le champ d'application dans un de
clarté et d'intelligibilité de la loi
nous proposons de substituer au terme à
titre individuel les termes en qualité
d'indépendant les agents de
l'administration recrutés par contrat
serait ainsi clairement exclu du champ
d'application de la loi alors que les
personnes physiques exercent des
activités de consultance au profit d'une
administration sans être employée ni par
celle-ci ni par un cabinet de conseil
serait quant à elle soumise au respect
de la loi
oui ce sera un avis défavorable puisque
là dans cette article le à titre
individuel s'entend ici par contraste
par rapport à ceux qui interviennent au
travers d'une personne morale et donc
nous souhaitons en rester à la rédaction
telle que proposée par la Commission
j'insiste une seconde mais il me semble
qu'on dénature pas du tout la visée en
parlant de consultant à titre
indépendant je crois que c'est vraiment
ce qui est visé par la TEC de loi et
j'insiste une seconde sur l'ambiguïté du
terme à titre individuel serait quand
même extrêmement dommageable que des
agents contractuels rentrent dans la
définition de la proposition de loi donc
j'insiste sur la vie favorable que pour
ma part je porte sur cette amendement
je n'ai pas de demande de parole donc je
mets aux voix l'amendement 21
de Madame Duranton qui a fait l'objet
d'un avis défavorable de la commission
et favorable du gouvernement qui est
pour
contre n'est pas adopter
l'amendement 7 de madame
suit le même
sort que les suivre les précédents le 8
aussi non le 8 et maintenu donc vous
avez la parole madame merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le midi chers
collègues alors cet amendement a pour
objet de s'assurer que l'expertise
sous-traitée par l'État au cabinet de
conseil repose sur de réelles
compétences le rapport de la commission
du Sénat ainsi que l'enquête publiée par
deux journalistes intitulés Les
Infiltrés ont révélé le manque de
rigueur et le caractère parfois
désinvolté inutile des travaux livrables
rendus par les consultants exemple de la
recommandation par McKinsey pour la
campagne sur la quatrième dose de
vaccination l'unique scénario porte sur
100% d'adhésion
le scénario de réduction des coûts
sociaux sur la baisse de 5 euros de
l'APL on voit ce qu'il en reste
aujourd'hui ou l'invention des masques
grand public qui a été de la part d'une
agence publicitaire une décision
publicitaire et non pas une décision
d'autorité sanitaire
si
la commission oui tout d'abord je
remercie notre collègue muerbronn pour
avoir retiré effectivement ses
amendements parce que c'est nous ce qui
nous en avions eux-mêmes saluer l'état
d'esprit de départ en tout état de cause
vu les rédactions proposées vous allez
presque à l'encontre de ce qui était
recherché en revanche j'aimais très là
un avis défavorable au nom de la
commission puisque cela nous semble
aller dans un degré de précision qui ne
semble pas utiles et pas effectif pour
ce qui est recherché à l'article premier
de cette proposition de loi
même avis qui est important c'est le
président pour la raison très simple que
l'ensemble des prestations de conseils
ne repose pas forcément et
systématiquement sur des données
chiffrées et donc et un problème à mon
avis d'application de cette amendement
là
je me vois l'amendement numéro 8 de
Madame de Madame Müller pardon avec un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
l'auteur de l'amendement très bien qui
est contre et pas adopté ensuite
monsieur benaroche Parlement 16 merci
monsieur le Président cet amendement
souhaite
renforcer en fait l'influence la lutte
contre l'influence des cabinets de
procès sur la décision publique
il nous semblait important que ces
cabinets de conseils privés indiquent
aux administrations les différentes
pistes qui sont envisagées lors de la
construction d'un projet
pourquoi c'est en fait pour ne pas
laisser une marge de manœuvre
disproportionnée au consultant dans le
choix du scénario proposé bien entendu
le choix du scénario reste toujours la
responsabilité des consultants mais le
fait de devoir pour un prestataire ou un
consultant par principe proposé au faire
état de l'ensemble des scénarios
envisagés permet aussi dans ce cas de
motiver la décision d'abandon de l'un ou
de l'ordre des scénarios ce qui nous
semble être une garantie supplémentaire
de la commission oui ce sera un avis
défavorable parce que à travers cet
amendement même si nous pouvons en
mesurer le sens il rendrait complètement
inopérationnel en pratique l'application
de cet article premier en effet la liste
des scénarios n'auront retenus
pourraient devenir illimité et donc
ainsi prêter quoi voilà prêter des
intentions qui ne pourraient jamais
cesser ni stopper et de fait même si la
volonté est effectivement d'aller vers
plus de transparence plus de
justification dans ce qui est retenu par
rapport à ce qui n'est pas retenu tel
que rédiger tel que proposer cet
amendement viserait certainement plus à
bloquer qu'à assurer plus de
transparence en la matière
ministre même avec un rapporteur
avec un avis double avis défavorable
commission gouvernement qui est pour
contre
attention
il est pas adopté madame Mélanie Vogel
nous présente amendement 28 merci
monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement vise à créer une
incompatibilité légale formelle entre
les cabinets de conseils qui
contractualisent avec l'État et les
cabinets d'affaires publiques qui
contractualisent auprès de clients
privés pour exercer en leur nom des
activités de représentation d'intérêt
auprès des décisions publics
la mission d'enquête parlementaire et
notamment son audition du président de
la Haute Autorité a bien démontré que
les cabinets de conseils intervenants
auprès de l'État n'étaient pas des
représentants d'intérêts au sens propre
et n'étaient donc pas inscrits en tant
que tel au répertoire de la Haute
Autorité sauf rare exception mais le
risque évidemment sans garantir l'égal
réaffirmée ce serait qu'un cabinet de
conseils se prévale de sa mission auprès
de l'État pour vendre auprès de ses
clients privés une influence supposée au
réel qui constituerait un avantage
induit et pourrait même s'apparenter
dans certains cas un délit pénal de
trafic il apparaît donc nécessaire et
utile d'établir légalement que les
cabinets de conseils qui
contractualisent avec l'État ont
l'interdiction d'effectuer toute action
de représentation d'intérêt auprès des
pouvoirs publics au nom de tiers et je
veux bien sûr préciser que cette
interdiction n'exclut pas du tout la
possibilité que ces cabinets effectuent
des actions de représentation d'intérêt
en leur nom propre en leur nom propre ou
via leurs associations professionnelles
mais simplement au nom de tiers je vous
remercie
David la commission oui ce sera un avis
défavorable parce que la question de la
représentation d'intérêt que vous
soulevez peut-être réglé par le cadre
créé par la proposition de loi en
matière de conflit d'intérêt des
cabinets de conseils un prestataire de
conseils qui utiliserait sa mission de
conseil auprès d'une administration
bénéficiaire pour justement faire de la
représentation au profit d'un autre
client d'un autre client pardon serait
de fait en conflit d'intérêt et donc
punissable par la Haute Autorité à la
transparence de la vie publique et donc
il ne semble pas opportun d'apporter la
précision d'une incompatibilité générale
entre ces professions
il y a pas d'autres observation donc je
soumets au Sénat l'amendement 28 de
Madame Vogel avec un double avis
défavorable qui est favorable
qui est contre
l'abstention il est pas adopté et donc
je peux mettre au voile l'amendement
l'article pardon l'article premier
issu de notre discussion
qui est pour
et contre
il est adopté
après l'article premier
passons à l'amendement 26 présenté par
monsieur Sueur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues il est apparu à notre groupe
que dès lors que les mesures proposées
par ce texte
sont bénéfiques et nous croyons vraiment
qu'elles sont bénéfiques pour l'ensemble
des services de l'État
il est logique que nous puissions aussi
les
appliquer
aux assemblées parlementaires
je trouve que dès lors qu'il y a une
bonne
série de mesures qui s'appliquerait à
l'ensemble des ministères je ne vois pas
pourquoi ces mesures ne s'appliqueraient
pas non plus ou s'assemblée par le
montant je précise qu'il ne s'agit en
aucun cas de remettre en cause
l'indépendance des assemblées
parlementaires de même que la loi qui a
créé les représentants d'intérêt
s'appliquent au Sénat dans les
conditions fixées par le Bureau du Sénat
en toute indépendance nous proposons
dans notre amendement que les
dispositions de la présente proposition
de loi s'applique au Sénat comme à
l'Assemblée selon les modalités qui
seront mises en oeuvre par le bureau de
chaque assemblée pour préserver
absolument cette indépendance
quelle est la vie de la commission
[Musique]
l'État au bureau des assemblées
parlementaires de mettre en place leurs
règles sont bases légales que là encore
au travers un amendement visé ainsi
imposer par la loi cette extension
j'oserais dire d'application aux
chambres parlementaires nous sommes un
peu rapides et en tout cas là aussi
prématuré donc la vie est défavorable
26 du président sueur qui est pour
il est pas adopté
je peux donc mettre voir
l'article 2
qui est pour
contre
le 2 est adopté nous passons l'article 3
sur laquelle on demandait la parole la
présidente assassine ensuite monsieur la
mini oui merci monsieur le Président
c'est amendement est très important car
en fait il acte le recul du gouvernement
sur la transparence des prestations de
conseils il faut d'ailleurs le replacer
dans son contexte évoqué lors de la
discussion générale nous sommes dans une
situation où par exemple un journal Le
Monde est obligé d'aller devant le
tribunal administratif pour obtenir des
informations en pratique les ministères
ne répondent pas aux demandes des
journalistes il refuse de donner les
documents et perdent devant la cadavre
mais il joue la montre ils savent que la
procédure judiciaire va prendre des mois
voire des années et qu'il reste
tranquille entre guillemets pendant ce
temps c'est notamment le cas du rapport
McKinsey sur l'avenir du métier
d'enseignement d'enseignant pardon que
le gouvernement refuse toujours de
publier d'une manière générale nous
assistons à un retour de l'opacité
depuis la fin des travaux de la
commission d'enquête sous des airs
techniques cet amendement supprime au
moins 4 garanties de transparence
prévues par d'autres premièrement la
publication des bons de commande qui
sont pourtant communicables selon la
CADA pour transmettre ces documents il
suffira donc de biffer le nom du
fonctionnaire en charge qui ne semble
pas ce qui me semble très abordable à
l'heure du numérique deuxièmement la
cartographie RH des ministères que nous
demandons afin que l'État puisse mieux
mobiliser ses compétences internes et
moins recourir au consultant extérieur
troisièmement l'inclusion des
prestations de conseils dans le rapport
social unique des administrations pour
les représentants du personnel pour que
les représentants du personnel puissant
débattre quatrièmement la consolidation
des données sur cinq ans le gouvernement
propose un délai de deux ans et pour
l'ensemble des établissements publics le
gouvernement souhaitant décentraliser
l'information de chaque établissement et
ainsi la rendrai pas les établissements
publics sont certes autonomes sur le
plan administratif mais ils sont surtout
rattachés administère de tutelle et donc
à l'état le gouvernement propose
également d'ajouter des exceptions à la
transparence pour éviter de certaines
publications donc je n'en reviens pas
dans le détail on y a déjà fait
référence nous pour notre part nous
demandons des informations basiques sur
les prestations de conseils qui ne sont
pas couvertes par le secret d'affaires
comme le résumé des prestations et leurs
montants et ces informations devraient
d'ailleurs être déjà publiées au regard
des règles de la commande publique elle
recoupe les listes de prestations
publiées par la commission d'enquête qui
nous soulevé aucune difficulté en
conclusion le gouvernement ne peut donc
pas se cacher derrière le secret
d'affaires pour refuser de publier les
informations cela serait nous
semble-t-il juridiquement infondé et
démocratiquement contestable
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame le reporter
mes chers collègues concernant cet
article 3 et par ailleurs je n'ai pas
encore fait mais je m'associe
complètement à tous les collègues qui
sont intervenus précédemment pour rendre
hommage à ce travail de grande qualité
de la commission d'enquête sur
l'influence croissante des cabinets de
conseils privés sur les politiques
publiques ce travail qui aboutit à la
présente proposition de loi de
nos collègues lien d'associent et Arnaud
Bazin cet article 3
préconise la création d'un document
budgétaire qui recense les prestations
de conseils par les administrations
publiques englobant l'État les
établissements publics les hôpitaux je
crois ça a été largement développé par
les collègues
en effet les travaux de la commission
d'enquête ont mis en évidence les
difficultés y compris notamment pour eux
l'état de chiffrer l'étendue du recours
aux prestations de conseils avec des
sommes importantes qui sont indiquées
dans le rapport sur l'importance en
augmentation qui
atteignent environ 900 millions d'euros
chiffres de 2021 qui ont été rappelés
par différents intervenants
donc cet article 3 va concerne donc la
création d'un document budgétaire annexé
à la loi de finances qui est appelée
jaune budgétaire
la notion de transparence meilleure
lisibilité des des données
mesure prouver par
par la commission mais redéfinie pour
respecter le domaine exclusif des lois
de finance
référence également à la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
donc concernant cet article 3 je me
râlirais bien entendu à la vie de la
reporter des collègues de la commission
des lois qui se sont investies sur ces
sujets je vous remercie
nous avons sur cet article un amendement
l'amendement 3 du goût 32 pardon du
gouvernement qui est la parole
oui monsieur le Président par souci de
cohérence et pour que nos débats
puissent avancer au rythme souhaitable à
cette heure tardive je propose de
présenter à la fois l'amendement 33 34
et 35 du gouvernement qui porte sur les
articles 3 4 et 8 de la proposition de
loi je dis par cohérence puisque
effectivement la proposition que je
souhaite vous soumettre c'est de
fusionner ces articles là je vais faire
en deux temps je vais faire rapidement
d'abord vous dire quels sont les
réserves que j'ai je ressens en lisant
le texte tel qu'il est écrit et dans un
deuxième temps conformément à ce que
j'ai dit lors de la discussion générale
je ferai la proposition de gouvernement
qui je veux insister sur ce point n'est
en aucun cas une proposition qui
affaiblit le texte mais qui a vocation
de mon point de vue et de celui du
gouvernement à le rendre plus opérant
plus efficace et au final effectif
d'abord je crois effectivement que la
dispersion des informations voulues par
la représentation
national dans différents documents n'est
pas de nature à rendre les choses plus
effectifs on aura des informations dans
un rapport au Parlement dit je
budgétaire on aura des informations dans
le document social unique on aura des
informations publiées au fil de l'eau
dont d'ailleurs la le réceptacle n'est
pas très bien défini dans la loi sur les
bons de commande et puis on aura un
autre rapport au Parlement remis sur la
question des compétences je crois pas
que la dispersion de ces informations
dans différents rapports dans
différentes temporalités soit de nature
à renforcer l'effectivité de ce que vous
voulez suivre au fond en tant que
représentation nationale un mot sur un
de ces objets qui me sont pas convenir
par rapport à l'objectif qui est voulu
c'est le document social unique je crois
que ce document social unique ce rapport
social unique ça n'est pas son objet
du rapport social unique il est défini
par la loi il est défini même très
précisément par la loi par décret autour
de 10 rubriques l'emploi le recrutement
parcours formation rémunération santé
sécurité au travail organisation du
travail qualité de vie au travail action
et protection sociale dialogue social
discipline je prends deux secondes pour
citer son objet pour bien montrer que à
mon sens ça n'est pas l'objet d'y faire
figurer l'ensemble des prestations de
conseils c'est un document qui est
d'ailleurs rédigé par les RH des
ministères qui n'est pas rédigé par les
agents administratifs qui auraient la
charge de regarder les prestations de
conseils donc je veux vraiment soulever
votre attention sur ce point parce que
je crois que ça serait un dévoiement de
cet objet ce rapport social unique qui
est bien utile notamment dans les lignes
directrices de gestion je mentionnais un
point supplémentaire qui sont les
temporalités diverses qui seraient
publiées dans les différentes
informations donc on aurait un rapport
annuel qui serait une annexe budgétaire
on aurait un rapport qui lui serait fait
tous les 5 ans sur la question des
compétences et puis on aurait au fil de
l'eau la publication de l'intégralité
des bons de commande là aussi je crois
que ça n'est pas de nature à rendre
effective utilisable au fond cette
matière ce qui est je crois la finalité
rechercher dans le texte un dernier mot
sur la publication des bons de commande
de façon exhaustive moi je suis
effectivement réservé sur ce point non
pas pour affaiblir les mesures de
transparence je vais faire des
propositions nettes et précises sur
cette question là mais je crois qu'il
faut regarder de façon précise
opérationnelle ce que serait la
publication effective de tous ces bons
de commande il y a eu en 2021 4854
commandes le travail je crois que vous
ne remettez pas en cause de bifhage un
certain nombre d'informations de
cavernage en sortant d'informations le
nom par exemple des agents publics c'est
un travail qui prend du temps au bas mot
à peu près 5 heures par prestation de
conseils ça voudrait dire qu'on
consacrerait 25000 heures de travail je
crois qu'il faut en être conscient pour
pouvoir simplement publier l'intégralité
des bons de commande là aussi je crois
qu'il y a une question de
proportionnalité qui n'est pas celle
recherchée par la loi un dernier point
dans les éléments moi qui me paraissent
pas convenir dans la loi telle qu'elle
est écrite c'est un point qui pourrait
mettre en cause la responsabilité des
agents qui auraient amené ce travail de
caviage de préparation des bons de
commande ça pourrait inclure leur
responsabilité devant la loi si il
commettait une erreur sur ce travail
assez monumental je crois qu'on peut en
convenir qui leur serait demandé et donc
quelle est la proposition que le
gouvernement fait c'est effectivement de
faire figurer l'ensemble des
informations utiles dans un document
unique donc j'ai pris l'engagement à la
tribune tout à l'heure d'en faire un
document qui soit gravé dans le marbre
et qui deviennent une annexe permanente
de nos textes budgétaires qui soient à
la disposition des assemblées chaque
année qui porterait les informations
suivantes la publication de
l'intégralité des commandes de l'État
intitulé de la commande ministère qui le
commande montant ça serait des
informations qui seraient exhaustives
qui devrait la stratégie menée ministère
par ministère pour contrôler le recours
aux prestations de conseils tel qu'elle
est publiée peut-être de façon
imparfaite dans ce premier document qui
aura vocation à être enrichie et qui
enfin qui viendra préciser les
transferts de compétences et donc la
stratégie de réinternalisation de
compétences qui sera opérée je m'arrête
une seconde sur ce point parce que oui
je crois qu'il est essentiel vous avez
raison de le souligner je crois même que
c'est l'enjeu essentiel de ce texte
quels sont les moyens que se donne
l'état pour réinternaliser un certain
nombre de compétences je dirais qu'à
trois étages dans cette fusée d'abord
les compétences qu'on réinternalise au
sein de la dictée j'ai annoncé la
création de 15 postes et je pense je
compte continuer cet effort de
réinternalisation ensuite c'est la
mobilisation
fonctionnaires tout à fait
capable vous l'avez mentionné les uns et
les autres et donc le travail mené avec
ta dièse de formation de fonctionnaires
bien on vous en donnerait la visibilité
après année après année et enfin la
mobilisation de nos corps d'inspection
parce que je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous avez dit parfois il peut y avoir
des redondances entre des missions
menées par des cabinets de conseils et
le travail mené par des corps
d'inspection donc l'ensemble de ces
informations sur l'Internet descente
compétences je prends ici d'engagement
qu'on les fasse figurer dans ce jaune
budgétaire un dernier mot madame la
présente à celle-ci parce que vous
l'avez mentionné oui j'assume le fait
qu'il puisse y avoir des exceptions à la
publication de telle ou tel bon de
commande non pas simplement pour des
questions de secret des affaires mais je
vais vous donner un ou deux exemples
très précis pour vraiment faire
réfléchir l'Assemblée sur ce que nous
nous apprêtons à publier il peut y avoir
des exceptions par exemple quand le fisc
travaille à l'optimisation de la lutte
contre la fraude fiscale en s'appuyant
sur un cabinet de conseils spécialiste
en intelligence artificielle et bien
j'espère convaincre des sénateurs pardon
communistes que à ce moment-là et bien
oui j'assume qu'on ne fasse pas
publicité de la stratégie d'optimisation
de la lutte contre la fraude fiscale et
je prends un exemple qui n'est pas un
exemple théorique puisque vous savez
qu'une mission a été menée pour mieux
traquer notamment mieux repérer les
piscines et les propriétaires de piscine
en s'appuyant effectivement sur des
cabinets de conseils pour mener ce type
de mission je prends un autre exemple
qui je crois et illustratif de ce que
nous pouvons aussi préserver il y a
parfois des cabinets de conseils qui
nous aident à travailler sur les
stratégies par exemple la stratégie
hydrogène de la France qui est un sujet
sur lequel nous sommes notre pays en
compétition avec d'autres pays bien moi
j'assume de dire que je ne sais pas
livré à livre ouvert à des puissances
étrangères l'intégralité du bon de
commande et des missions et des
intitulés que nous livrerons et donc le
principe que je voulais dire je resterai
jamais sans contre-proposition le
principe dans ce zone budgétaire ça
serait un principe de justification par
les ministères de la non publication
éventuelle en donnant la raison la
nature de la raison invoquée et donc
vous aurez ainsi dans ce jaune
budgétaire unifié toutes les demandes je
crois qu'ils sont formulées par
l'Assemblée à travers cette proposition
bas pardon j'étais un peu long mais cela
valait argumentation pour les articles 3
5 et 8 monsieur le président
la vie de la commission s'il vous plaît
madame
jusque là nous nous retrouvons
cependant tel que vous le proposez avec
l'amendement qui vise effectivement à
réécrire l'article 3 à supprimer
l'article 4 et à supprimer également
l'article 8 bon vous me permettrez tout
de même de de noter effectivement que
c'est à nos yeux un appauvrissement du
travail tel que validé par par la
commission puisque la suppression par
exemple de l'article 8 amènerait un
document qui ne comporterait plus de
cartographie des ressources humaines
dont dispose le ministère en matière de
conseil or justement est-ce ça a été
rappelé y compris par un certain nombre
d'intervenants à la tribune il y en a
justement plus que jamais besoin de plus
la liste des prestations vous venez de
le dire et c'est un choix et nous ne le
partageons pas la liste des prestations
serait amputées des données relatives à
la corcade auquel se rattache la
prestation de conseil ainsi que des
données relatives au marché au lot et au
bon de commande différents ces données
participent pourtant pleinement à
l'objectif de traçabilité que promeux la
proposition de loi vous permettez
également avec la rédaction de la
rédaction pardon de l'article 3
d'accroître les réserves à la
publication des données vous venez de le
dire
sur la suppression de l'article 4 vous
me permettrez de faire un parallélisme
avec la présentation commune des trois
amendements du Gouvernement et donc là
aussi d'émettre un avis un peu plus
global ce qui nous fera gagner du temps
par la suite sur la suppression de
l'article 4
simplement bien évidemment ce sera un
avis là aussi défavorable mais la
publication ordonnée ouverte des
informations relatives aux prestations
conseils des bons de commandes
constitueraient l'aboutissement à nos
yeux du mouvement de transparence et
d'ailleurs je souhaite rappeler à cette
occasion que la loi du 7 octobre 2016
pour une république numérique
prévoit que l'ouverture des données
publiques et la règle et que la mise à
disposition des données de référence ont
une facilité leur réutilisation
constitue une mission de service public
relevant de l'État sur la suppression de
l'article 8
j'y suis déjà je suis déjà intervenu
donc je n'y reviens pas et donc vous
l'aurez compris ce sera un avis
défavorable sur ces trois amendements
madame Goulaine oui je voudrais faire
une explication de vote globale puisque
le ministre a eu l'obligeance de de
faire de même sur les trois articles moi
je suis je voterai pas je suivrai pas le
gouvernement sur ces sur ces trois
articles je voudrais rappeler notamment
qu'en matière de fraude fiscale on a eu
énormément de difficultés à obtenir
notamment sur la fraude à la TVA le
moindre conseil extérieur alors qu'on
nous a expliqué en long en large et en
technicolor que les ressources internes
étaient suffisantes totales on est le
dernier pays de l'Europe en matière de
fraude à la TVA et que Madame Parly lors
de son audition devant notre commission
c'était engagé à nous donner le résultat
de ces consultations privées pour le
logiciel Louvois dont on sait que ça a
été un succès foudroyant donc moi je me
fie au travail de notre commission
d'enquête et je ne voterai pas les
amendements du Gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre merci de vos explications vous
avez donné deux exemples assez précis et
c'est bien de pouvoir donner des
exemples je pense qu'en matière de
stratégie industrielle des questions se
posent sincèrement vous avez évoqué la
question de l'hydrogène je pense que la
question spatiale la question des
télécommunications la question
énergétique bon ça voudrait un débat au
Parlement qu'on puisse regarder
quelle filière industrielle il nous faut
protéger d'intérêt étrangers par contre
vous donner le premier exemple
pardonnez-moi ça nous fait sourire ici
sur ces bandes sur l'évasion fiscale ce
qu'on veut bien savoir quel cabinet nous
aide et aide le ministère de l'économie
et des finances sur la question évasion
fiscale espérons que ça soit pas ma
Kinsey parce qu'autrement il pourrait se
mettre les premiers sur la liste puisque
eux-mêmes pratiques l'optimisation
fiscale plein pot non voilà il faut il
faut nous dire bah oui pardonnez mais
lorsqu'on fait pas d'impôts pendant 10
ans il y a une question donc on veut
bien savoir le cabinet qui nous aide
pour savoir si au moins eux sont en
adéquation sur la question fiscale vous
voyez donc on entend bien le deuxième
argument qu'on peut mettre en débat avec
avec ici le Parlement sur le premier
comme notre collègue madame Goulet on
pense quand même que c'est une question
régalienne et que il faut qu'on ait des
fonctionnaires suffisamment nombreuses
et nombreux pour pouvoir effectuer cette
mission et sur ces bandes nous n'avons
cessé de vous dire que la réduction du
nombre de personnels science précisément
cette question la fraude fiscale et
l'optimisation fiscale n'est pas simple
mais qu'elle mérite un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires pour pouvoir faire
véritablement leur travail d'autant plus
que la fraude fiscale pèse lourdement
évidemment dans le déficit de l'État
voilà je vous remercie monsieur le
président
vous avez vu je suis très respectueux de
la proposition de loi et j'essaye
vraiment d'argumenter mes positions en
donnant des exemples concrets je vous
avoue que ça n'empêche pas parfois avec
un peu de malice de bien choisir ces
exemples là et j'ai choisi un exemple
qui je savais vous ferez réagir sur un
sujet auquel je vous sais évidemment
attaché et croyez-le c'est bien partager
ici la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
j'ai pas pris un exemple en l'air en
l'occurrence j'ai pris un vrai projet
qui a abouti qui a même donné lieu à des
articles dans la presse sur la capacité
pour le fisc à mieux traquer ceux qui
mènent des fraudes et notamment les
possesseurs de piscine c'est un projet
qui a été mené avec l'appui de mon
administration et la pluie d'un cabinet
donc je voulais simplement ici vous
rassurer en vous indiquant que ce
n'était pas making c'est si tel était le
sens de votre question mais oui je
réitère cette affirmation dès lors que
le principe de non publication de
intitulé de la commande de son montant
et du ministère et justifier
c'est bien la proposition que je fais ce
soir dans le jaune budgétaire ainsi
d'ailleurs madame la rapporteur que
l'intégralité la question des
compétences donc ça n'est pas enlevé du
champ ça serait bien intégré dans ce
document budgétaire unique qui serait
porté à votre analyse dès lors que ce
principe est justifié je crois
sincèrement pas que ça soit un recul et
on peut assumer et c'est effectivement
un bon débat et vous avez eu l'amabilité
de citer les sujets industriels sur
lequel on peut avoir ce débat là mais ça
donnerait justement la bonne prise pour
expliquer que sur tel ou tel sujet il y
a des travaux mais que nous souhaitons
pas publier ou des bons de commande ou
même des intitulés de commande
oui sur la traque des piscines non
déclaré c'est quand même savoureux
s'exemple féministe excusez-moi de
rebondir Google devait 7 milliards à la
France ils ont transigé un milliard 7 je
crois ils ont fait un chèque on a
discuté et on a transigé effectivement
aujourd'hui Google on remerciement entre
guillemets va aider le gouvernement à
repérer les piscines non déclarées je
ferme la parenthèse ça devient
complètement cocasse deuxième question
est-ce que vous êtes prêt monsieur le
ministre a publié le rapport que
mckinzea produit sur le métier
d'enseignant qui a été cité à de
nombreuses reprises dans des échanges et
dans le rapport est-ce que vous allez
rendre ce rapport public
monsieur le ministre
je vous répondrai clairement sur le
travail qui est mené par le gouvernement
pour publier l'intégralité des documents
sur lequel la CADA a émis un avis
favorable de publication et un travail
en cours qui nécessite beaucoup beaucoup
de travail de la part de chacune des
administrations qui est coordonnée par
le secrétaire général de gouvernance
pour pouvoir publier ministère par
ministère l'intégralité des documents le
ministère de la transformation et de la
fonction publique a communiqué
l'intégralité des commandes qui étaient
demandées par les journalistes concernés
à la CADA et ce travail là se poursuit
et l'intégralité des documents qui ont
été demandés avec un avis favorable de
la CADA seront effectivement transmis
aux journalistes qui les ont demandé
bien
je peux mettre aux voix il y a plus de
monde de parole je mets aux voiles
amendement 32 du gouvernement qui a fait
l'objet d'un avis défavorable de la
commission
qui est favorable qui vote pour
contre
n'est pas adopté
donc nous en revenons au texte de
l'article 3 que je mets aux voix qui est
pour
contre
l'abstention est adoptée
à l'article 4
nous avons l'amendement 33 que le
gouvernement a déjà présenté et je crois
qu'on peut résumer que la position de la
commission est défavorable
il n'y a pas de demande d'expression
donc je le mets où voir c'est le même
vote
qui est pour
contre
il n'est pas adopté
du coup nous avons l'article 4 dans son
état naturel si j'ose dire que je mets
aux voix qui est pour
contre
il est adopté
à l'article 5 nous avons un autre
amendement 43 présenté par le
gouvernement
je le présent de brièvement monsieur le
Président parce que je veux dire ici que
je partage la finalité de l'article 5
qui est de mettre fin au mission probots
donc que ce soit dit extrêmement
clairement exactement pour les raisons
que vous avez indiquées je propose deux
modifications à ces articles une qui est
d'écriture si je puis dire pour venir
préciser la mention que vous avez
vous-même portée à l'article 268 bis ça
c'est vraiment un amendement de pure
légistique et puis sur les sujets
d'écriture pour permettre la réalisation
à titre gracieux de prestation de
conseils entre administration la
rédaction actuelle du texte ne le
permettait pas et donc rendez par
exemple impossible la réalisation d'une
mission gratuite par une université au
bénéfice d'une administration et donc je
proposais de lever cette exception et
puis deuxième point que je propose de
porter c'est établir une seule exception
à l'interdiction des missions pro bono
sur les situations les plus
exceptionnelles qu'on a négliger à
descendre dans des termes extrêmement
stricts en disant en cas de
circonstances exceptionnelle
comprémentant la vie ou la santé de la
population une guerre ou une pandémie
pourquoi parce que on peut comprendre
que dans ces moments-là il y a des temps
d'urgence qui ne correspondent pas tout
le temps au temps des démarches
administratives par exemple pour pouvoir
passer des commandes et donc c'est la
seule exception que je soumets à la mise
à fin des prestations pro-bonaux par des
prestataires privés
la première remarque viendra sur
effectivement la précision des
destinataires visés par l'interdiction
des prestations de conseil réalisateur à
titre gratuit puisque il nous semble que
si l'article 5 ne précise pas
explicitement que les prestataires et
les consultants sont visés par
l'interdiction posée le champ
d'application de la proposition de loi
et définit à l'article premier que donc
dès lors on peut déduire de cet article
premier que l'interdiction des
prestations de conseils réalisées à
titre gratuit vaut pour les prestataires
et les consultants sur le deuxième point
que vous venez d'évoquer monsieur le
ministre sur la dérogation proposée en
cas de circonstances exceptionnelles
promettant la vie ou la santé de la
population bon tout d'abord il existe
aujourd'hui dans les règles de la
commande publique qu'un acheteur peut
passer un marché public sans publicité
ni mise en concurrence préalable
lorsqu'une urgence impérieuse résultant
le circonstances extérieur et qu'il ne
pouvait pas prévoir ne permet pas de
respecter les délais mini mots exigés
par les procédures formalisés et surtout
il revient et nous l'avons vécu il y a
peu encore il revient à des éventuelles
lois d'urgence qui inévitablement se
réprise dès lors que nous serions dans
des circonstances qui compromettent la
vie ou la santé de la population il
revient aux éventuelles lois d'urgence
de revenir si besoin sur ce principe
général d'interdiction et donc nous ne
sommes pas pardon pour une inscription
en tant que telle dans la loi je vous
remercie
je me vois l'amendement 41 proposé par
le gouvernement et faisons l'objet d'un
avis défavorable de la commission
43 pardon
qui est pour
contre
abstention et pas adoptée
de Monsieur bellaroche de ses collègues
a pour but de compléter en fait cet
article 5 qui est déjà parfaitement
rédigé on y ajoutant en fait pour être
particulier qui consiste à interdire aux
prestataires aux consultants de fournir
des prestations de conseils à un client
qui a bénéficié de mécénat de leur part
dans les 5 années qui précèdent à fait
prévenir et d'empêcher en fait
l'instrumentalisation volontaire à un
moment donné du mécénat à des faits
commerciales de façon à préparer un
contrat voilà
il nous semble que déjà l'article 5 et
11 de la proposition de loi constitue un
cadre à la fois solide et équilibré pour
les prestations de conseils réalisées au
titre du mécénat et donc nous ne voyons
pas de raison particulière encadrées
davantage encore les prestations de
conseils réalisés au titre du mécénat
comme vous le proposez mes chers
collègues donc nous émettons un avis
défavorable gouverne
je soumets au vote l'amendement 17 avec
la vie défavorable de la commission et
le même avis du gouvernement qui est
pour
contre
abstention n'est pas adoptée
je me vois l'article 5
qui est pour
contre
il est adopté
après l'article 5
proposition d'amendement
11 présenté par Monsieur benaroche merci
Michel Président je voulais préciser que
l'amendement précédent avait été établi
avec une association qui s'appelle Serpa
qui travaille beaucoup sur ce sujet
l'amendement numéro 11 en fait c'est un
amendement additionnel qui a pour but en
fait de préciser
que
le recours prestataire au consultant
privé pour la rédaction des études
d'impact et la rédaction d'exposer de
motifs de projets de loi est interdit
nous posons effectivement ça a été dit
je crois à d'autres moments de ce débat
que cette rédaction doit être
exclusivement réalisée par les services
de l'État entre autres choses pour
éviter toute déposition du rôle de
l'État et des politiques en matière
d'orientation de politique publique je
citerai juste ça l'exemple pour pour
aller brièvement en 2018 le gouvernement
d'Édouard Philippe avait décidé de
lancer un appel d'offre pour
sous-traiter à une entreprise l'exposé
des motifs à cycle étude d'impact de sa
future loi sur les transports
ça avait un peu alerté l'opinion
publique sur les problèmes
d'externalisation au fait des processus
de rédaction de loi donc nous souhaitons
apporter cette précision en fait
la commission
je crois en tout cas je partage ce qui a
déjà été dit par d'autres anormales que
l'État ne soit pas en mesure de rédiger
lui-même les études d'impact et les
exposer des motifs des projets de loi
qu'il présente devant la représentation
nationale cela étant je souhaite d'abord
rappeler que le grand droit de l'article
2 de cette PPL crée en l'état une
obligation de transparence quant à la
participation de cabinet de conseil à la
rédaction de documents pour le compte de
l'administration ce qui inclut bien
évidemment les études d'impact les
exposer des motifs des projets de loi et
donc cette obligation de transparence
devrait assurément j'ai envie de dire
freiner cette pratique qui a été
fortement réprouvé comme vous le disiez
mon cher collègue y compris qui a pu
heurter aussi un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens je crois là pour le coup que
un certain nombre comme comme déjà
précédemment de mesures sont prises se
suffisent à elle-même et que cet
amendement serait super fêtatoire et
insistez peut-être sur
la capacité à croire dans les festivités
de cette proposition de loi qui comme je
le dis
entraînera finalement tout le monde a
travaillé
et agir différemment je n'en doute pas
je voudrais prendre un exemple un peu
parallèle au débat que nous avons ce
soir mais la remarque que vient de faire
notre collègue benaroche précédemment
pour préciser que l'amendement précédent
avait été travaillé avec l'association
Sherpa je crois que pour un certain
nombre nous pouvons dire il y a ici une
dizaine d'années bien peu d'amendements
dans l'exposé même de leur motif précisé
avec quelle association quel organisme
les amendements avaient pu être rédigés
étaient déposés par nos collègues ça
devient de plus en plus monnaie courante
à travers un certain nombre
d'amendements déposés ici de tous les
groupes d'ailleurs et de toute origine
preuve en est je crois que parfois il y
a la loi il y a la volonté et puis
ensuite il y a une pratique qui devient
monnaie courante et je crois que c'est
ainsi en tout cas que nous devons
peut-être être rassurés en l'état je les
mettrai un avis défavorable
vous avez raison Madame la rapporteur
c'est la vérité qui vous rendra libre
pour reprendre des stations bibliques du
Quester sur simplement pour dire que
j'ai la même opinion que la rapporteur
ce point et cette amendement ça me
permet simplement de souligner que le
gouvernement était pleinement favorable
aux mesures qui ont été portées dans les
premiers articles et notamment à la fin
de ce que je qualifierais des marques
blanches c'est à dire des situations on
sait pas qui tient le crayon est-ce que
c'est le cabinet de conseil est-ce que
c'est le cabinet du ministre est-ce que
c'est une administration et donc cette
avancée là est pleinement soutenue sans
aucune réserve par le gouvernement et je
pense qu'elle répond en grande partie à
l'amendement qui est proposée donc même
avec un rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues
j'écoute avec beaucoup de sympathie
naturellement ce que dit monsieur
benaroche
mais j'essaie de réfléchir à cette
question de l'étude d'un pacte il
s'agissant de l'exposer des motifs vous
avez mille fois raison il suffit que le
ministre l'écrit voilà mais alors pour
l'étude d'impact nous avons déposé une
proposition de loi avec Monsieur
Montaugé là-dessus parce que je ne sais
pas s'il vous arrive de lire les études
d'impact moi je dois vous dire que c'est
quelque chose de très ennuyeux on a
envie de s'endormir quand on lit cela
pourquoi parce que l'étude d'impact est
faite par les services du ministre qui
présente la loi
donc là forcément c'est l'état
mais alors
aucun
ministre ne va publier une étude
d'impact qui critiquera son projet de
loi c'est à dire que les services du
ministère disent que l'impact de la loi
est très bon en général ce qui fait que
cette littérature un peu compassée n'est
pas intéressante et je suis d'accord que
ce n'est pas forcément machin c'est ou
autre qu'il faut confier l'étude
d'impact moi je ferai plutôt confiance à
des organismes scientifiques par exemple
des universités le CNRS lINSERM enfin un
certain nombre de d'organismes qui ne
serait pas dans l'optique de dire
forcément du bien ce que feront les
fonctionnaires du ministère donc je
voudrais qu'on je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à cette question parce que je
crois que les études d'impact tels sont
aujourd'hui c'est une fausse bonne idée
c'est quand même une obligation
constitutionnelle
donc je mets je me vois l'amendement
numéro 11 de monsieur benaroche qui est
pour
qui est contre
et n'est pas adopté
on rencontre quand même
qui est pour
d'accord qui est contre
donc il n'est pas
l'article 6 la parole est à Madame
ministre chers collègues j'ai souhaité
prendre la parole sur cet article car il
constitue un pilier essentiel de la
proposition de loi pour mettre fin à
l'opacité dans le gouvernement fait
preuve aujourd'hui encore en effet le
document tant attendu par le Sénat et
obtenu début octobre sur le détail des
missions et leur prix laissent perplexe
les dépenses y sont toujours très
élevées puisque leur coût total
dépassera en 2022 son niveau d'avant la
crise sanitaire environ 230 millions
d'euros ce coût nous interroge sur le
maintien de certaines missions dont le
caractère superflu voire inutile avait
été pourtant largement documenté tant
par le Sénat que par les enquêtes
journalistiques enfin le contenu du
document reste trop évasif pour
contrôler les objectifs de ces
prestations à titre d'exemple on apprend
que l'entreprise italienne techno à
miette a réalisé 6 missions pour le
ministère de la transition écologique
d'un montant de 25,3 millions d'euros il
s'agit selon le document d'études
géophysiques pour l'implantation d'un
parc éolien au large de la Bretagne on
lit que le prestataire a mis à
disposition un navire et un équipage
pour étudier les zones d'implantation
réaliser des tests de forage en pleine
mer etc le exetera semble un peu léger
pour comprendre et justifier une dépense
de plus de 25 millions vous en
conviendrez c'est pourquoi il faut
impérativement inscrire dans la loi le
contenu l'évaluation et les conséquences
concrètes de des prestations fournies
merci
l'amendement 35 présenté par le
Gouvernement sur l'article 6 oui mais
c'est le président là aussi pour
soutenir pleinement la finalité de
l'article 6 qui est de renforcer le
principe d'évaluation des prestations de
concept je suis d'ailleurs remarqué que
ce principe là il était inscrit dans la
circulaire du 19 janvier 2022 par le
Premier ministre qui en prenait
effectivement l'engagement et c'est un
principe qui a été intégré dans
l'accord-cadre renouvelé la DTP que j'ai
eu l'occasion de présenter tout à
l'heure avec d'ailleurs un modèle type
établi par la DTP que je tiens à votre
disposition pour encadrer pour normer au
fond la façon dont on évalue les
prestations de conseils donc soutien
total à la finalité d'articles je porte
un amendement qui porte sur deux
modifications qui sont au fond des mises
en cohérence la première mise en
cohérence c'est avec le débat que nous
devons que nous venons d'avoir sur les
secrets protégés par la loi c'est
simplement de la cohérence complète je
refais pas un débat ici mais je pense
que c'est cohérent de le porter sur les
sujets d'évaluation de la même façon que
nous l'avons porté sur la publication
des missions de conseil la deuxième mise
en cohérence c'est une mise en cohérence
avec la loi de 1978 qui s'était penché
justement sur les documents publiables
par les administrations et qui avait
donné un article
l311-2 du code des relations entre le
public et l'administration qui justement
disait que les évaluations ne devaient
être publiées que pour des décisions qui
étaient prises par l'autorité et par la
puissance publique et donc ça mettait
une exception qui était déjà prévu dans
la loi de 78 sur les évaluations sur des
décisions ou des avis n'étaient pas
encore pris et rendu par l'État
notamment par le gouvernement pour une
prise de décision dans la sérénité et
donc je propose au Sénat de se mettre et
de garder la conformité et la vie du
législateur de 1978 sur cette question
là
dans subjusticiers un survivant c'était
mon premier texte
madame madame le rapporteur
effectivement cet amendement le
gouvernement cherche à exclure de
l'obligation de publication les
évaluations des prestations de conseils
qui porteraient atteinte à l'ensemble
des secrets protégés par la loi ainsi
que les évaluations qui porteraient sur
les prestations de conseils
préparatoires à une décision
administrative en cours d'élaboration
des laboration pardon excusez-moi la
rédaction de cet amendement semble
certainement un peu trop large en ce cas
englobe notamment le secret des affaires
qu'elle risque d'avoir pour conséquence
de priver d'effectivité une grande
partie des dispositions prévues à
l'article 6 qu'il existe déjà un certain
nombre de protection notamment sur les
décisions administratives en cours je
pense que c'est un vrai sujet en tout
cas qui est proposé en l'état ce sera un
avis défavorable mais avec la volonté en
tout cas de réfléchir et de trouver une
rédaction qui réponde aussi quand même
un certain nombre d'impératifs qui
pourraient nécessiter des protections
avec la loi 78 je trouve que c'est
vraiment dommage et en l'occurrence
affaiblir la loi de ne pas intégrer
cette modification là j'en profite pour
apporter une précision supplémentaire
c'est dès lors que la décision publique
a été rendue et prise cette exception à
la non publication de l'évaluation tombe
bien évidemment et l'évaluation est
publiée de façon pleine et entière
de vote monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre en
introduisant subrepticement le secret
des affaires qui jusque là de figure pas
dans le texte
vous ajoutez quelque chose qui peut être
très lourd de conséquence et qui peut
faire exploser tout l'intérêt du texte
parce que y compris les cabinets de
conseils pourront exciper à tout moment
du secret des affaires
et je crains beaucoup que ce que vous
nous proposez là soit quelque peu
déflagrateurs par rapport à l'exigence
de transparence qui est la nôtre
je soumets aussi là l'amendement 35
proposé par le gouvernement avec David
défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
et contre
il n'est pas adopté
du coup je mets au voile article 6
qui est pour
contre il est adopté
je me vois l'article 7
monsieur Vallet
monsieur le Président de l'explication
de vote pour préciser un petit peu les
choses et les éclaircir
et puis je voudrais bien en fait vous
entendre monsieur le ministre sur cet
article et savoir ce que vous en pensez
sur le fond bon en France il y a pas de
police de la langue voilà déjà faut
démystifier tout ça ne pas être dans la
caricature dans le privé sur les réseaux
sociaux les gens entre eux ils parlent
bien comme ils veulent il y a pas de
difficultés de ce côté là et encore
heureux et puis plus on rentre dans les
interactions sociales comme un sépament
du travail plus les règles apparaissent
et se précise ici de quoi parle-t-on on
parle des pouvoirs publics on est bien
dans ce couloir là c'est-à-dire que le
chef de l'administration le Premier
ministre puis les ministres avec lui
sont là pour faire appliquer un droit
qui découlent un certain nombre de
normes la Constitution la loi tout bon
ensuite par exemple les circulaires je
prends l'exemple des circulaires primo
ministériels quand on dit qu'on féminise
les titres madame la préfète par exemple
c'est comme ça et autrement et s'il y a
des préfets dans certains départements
qui continuent de se faire appeler même
le préfet elles sont en contradiction
avec ce que disent leur administration
de la même façon quand Édouard Philippe
par circulaire précise les choses sur la
question uniquement du point médian et
pas de l'écriture inclusive tous les
fantasmes qui vont avec de tout côté
d'ailleurs il en a parfaitement le droit
il demande simplement à son
administration de s'exprimer d'une
manière qui soit claire et pas d'une
autre donc ce que nous entendons par là
à travers cet article c'est en fait
faire en sorte de saisir une opportunité
de faire en sorte que la loi tout bon
soit précisé pour qu'on sache que non
seulement l'administration à
l'obligation de travailler en français
et de s'exprimer en français mais qu'en
plus elle que elle doit exiger de ce
qu'elle paye pour lui rendre des
documents qu'il en fasse autant donc on
ne pourra pas étendre ces dis position
par exemple aux grandes entreprises y
compris quand elles sont issues de
grands monopolyta auxquels ont qu'elles
ont une belle histoire publique je pense
notamment à la poste qui arrive à pondre
des idées aussi idiotes que ma french
Bank malheureusement on peut pas aller
sur ce genre de disposition ça viendra
peut-être un jour mais c'est pas le bon
véhicule législatif pour le faire et en
tout cas on en reste vraiment à ce que
l'administration s'exprime en français
il reste à une question qui est celle de
la bonne application et ça ça relève
quasiment uniquement de l'administration
et de ceux qui dirigent l'administration
et là-dessus bien vous pourrez compter
sur le Parlement pour contrôler cette
bonne application mais je suis curieux
de savoir ce que vous pensez sur le fond
de cette disposition
monsieur le ministre répondait à la
sollicitation aimable de Monsieur Vallet
je fais observer au Sénat que en une
heure trois quarts nous avons fait la
moitié du travail
alors je ferai pas de sobriété dans ma
réponse pour vous dire je suis tout à
fait favorable à cette article-là et
j'en profite pour saluer le travail de
la commission des lois et son président
qui a donné une accroche en l'intégrant
et en faisant référence à loi tout bon
ce que je pense lui donne une base
solide
oui je partage évidemment comme
l'ensemble des collègues l'objectif de
cette de cet article mais comme la
présidente assassin a dit en fait dans
son intervention lors de la discussion
générale l'article 2 de la Constitution
prévoit déjà que le français la langue
de la République donc il me semble que
cet article est déjà satisfait et je
dirais même plus parce que c'est
peut-être c'est avant la Révolution donc
peut-être que Madame assassin a oublié
mais en fait en France l'édit de
Villers-Cotterêts de 1539 est toujours
d'applications et il précise très
clairement que la langue de il ne
précise pas très clairement parce que
c'était du vieux français mais en le
temps traduisant que la langue de
l'administration c'est assez clair
depuis 1539 la langue de
l'administration française est le
français et ne peut pas être une autre
langue à l'époque le concurrence et
latin maintenant c'est l'anglais mais il
me semble que je suis pas contre le
principe que c'est déjà satisfait comme
on ne veut pas des lois bavardes c'est
peut-être inutile
je me vois l'article 7 qui est pour
du contre
baux
article 8 nous avons l'amendement 34 que
le gouvernement a déjà présenté qui a
fait l'objet d'un avis des favorable de
la commission il est pas discussion
commune donc on peut se mettre tout de
suite
qui est pour
qui contre
et les bras adopté ensuite nous avons un
amendement 18 de
de monsieur benaroche qui a la parole
18 a pour objet de préciser que dans le
rapport présenté au Parlement au Conseil
supérieur de la fonction publique dont
il est question dans cet article le
libellé des postes occupés et les
compétences attachées aux fiches de
poste des fonctionnaires soit précisés
il est également demandé au gouvernement
de motiver dans ce présent rapport les
recours qu'il peut faire prestataire ou
à consultant externe vous comprenez bien
le but définir les postes de les postes
permettent de savoir avec chaque poste
quelles sont les compétences nécessaires
et ensuite voir pour quel usage le
gouvernement va faire appel à des
prestataires en fonction justement de
ces compétences et des postes qui sont
occupés
de la Commission
avec deux amis défavorables qui est pour
contre
les
du coup je me vois l'article 8
pas l'intervention qui est pour
l'article 8
contre
il est donc adopté
je mets aussi où voilà l'article 9 je
vais pas l'objet de demande de parole
qui est pour
entre
il est adopté à l'article 10 monsieur
Bazin demandé la parole merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues nous abordons un
chapitre essentiel de la proposition de
loi qui concerne les obligations
déontologiques des cabinets de conseils
et des consultants comme je l'ai dit
lors de la discussion générale nous
assistons depuis quelques années à un
renforcement des règles dans toutes les
sphères de la société tant mieux je vous
rappelle une citation du président de la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique devant la commission
d'enquête le 26 janvier dernier je cite
l'intervention des cabinets de conseils
peut légitimement susciter des
inquiétudes en matière de déontologie
ces risques nous les avons documentés
avec la commission d'enquête et ils ne
sont pas virtuels ce matin même le
journal Le Monde publie est un article
sur les risques de conflits d'intérêt
dans la gestion du plan de relance
européen l'État a le droit est même le
devoir de connaître les autres clients
de ces cabinets de conseils qui ne
doivent pas pouvoir servir deux intérêts
divergents en même temps c'est pourquoi
nous sommes très circonspects face aux
six prochains le commandement qui seront
présentés par Monsieur le Ministre en
matière de déontologie les recul
souhaités par le gouvernement sont en
effet nombreux recul sur le périmètre
des déclarations d'intérêt qui ne
concernerait plus que les dirigeants des
cabinets de conseil reculent sur les
moyens de contrôle de la Haute autorité
qui ne pourraient plus faire de contrôle
sur place alors que la majorité des
autorités indépendantes le peuvent
reculent sur la saisine de la Haute
autorité pour la transparence par les
représentants des fonctionnaires recule
sur les amendes administratives qui
seraient remplacés par des sanctions
pénales beaucoup plus difficiles à
mettre en oeuvre chacun le sait recul
sur le contrôle du pantouflage lorsqu’un
consultant intègre l'administration et
réciproquement et enfin recule sur les
modalités d'entrée en vigueur vous ne
souhaitez pas que notre PPL est des
effets rétroactifs ce qui voudrait dire
que les nouvelles règles ne
s'appliqueraient ni à la corcade de
l'UGAP conclue l'été dernier ni à la
corcadre de la D IPP qui sera conclu en
fin d'année j'ose espérer qu'il s'agit
d'une erreur matérielle et que cela ne
reflète pas la volonté du gouvernement
vous comprendrez donc monsieur le
ministre que nous ne pourrons être
favorables à vos prochains amendements
la navette permettra d'améliorer encore
le texte mais nous souhaitons nous ne
souhaitons pas pardons pas revoir son
ambition à la baisse en particulier en
ce qui concerne la lutte contre les
conflits d'intérêts
donc nous avons examiné l'article
l'amendement 36 proposé par le
gouvernement qui va le présenter
merci monsieur le Président d'abord
je voudrais indiquer ici que le
renforcement de la déontologie et une
finalité du texte qui est aussi
recherchée par le gouvernement je
profite pour dire le soutien j'ai pas
pris la parole pour pas faire perdre de
temps dans le débat sur l'article 9 que
nous venons d'adopter et qui entraîne
des renforcements déontologiques pour le
texte je fais aussi remarquer que et
dans la circulaire du Premier ministre
du 19 janvier 2022 et dans l'accord
cadre renouvelée de la DTP nous avons
intégré des mesures renforçant le
contrôle déontologique et notamment les
déclarations sur l'honneur des
consultants sur lequel je vais revenir
mon point porte sur ces déclarations des
consultants à la fois sur des questions
de proportionnalité et d'effectivité des
finalités qui sont recherchées par la
loi la proportionnalité d'abord ce qui
est voulu ici c'est d'avoir une une
publication exhaustive pour l'ensemble
des consultants je fais remarquer ici
que le terme de consultants
entraînerait nécessairement et
probablement une appréciation sur
l'ensemble des salariés des cabinets de
conseils à peu près 120 000 salariés
dans les cabinets de conseils il y en a
15 % qui travaillent avec l'État et donc
cela voudrait dire qu'on aurait des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
concernées par des déclarations
d'intérêts exhaustive pour eux et pour
leur conjoint exactement les mêmes qui
sont demandés à des parlementaires ou à
des ministres que nous sommes ça veut
dire que le moindre consultant qui
arrive dans un cumulier de conseils qui
démarre en tant que Junior sur une
mission il est soumis exactement une
déclaration exhaustive ainsi que sa
conjointe sur ou son conjoint ou sur son
concubin sur ces activités
professionnelles j'y ajoute j'en profite
pour le faire je le referai pas sur
l'article 12 que vous y avez ajouté en
commission une possibilité
de contrôle sur place par la hatv qui
n'est même pas existante pour vous ou
pour moi en tant que parlementaire en
tant que mini c'est à dire que je je
j'insiste sur cet argument de
proportionnalité par la loi telle
qu'elle est rédigée aujourd'hui vous
faites peser sur des consultants juniors
voire même sur des
employés administratifs des cabinets de
conseils des dispositions qui sont plus
exigeantes que celles que nous nous
appliquons en tant que parlementaire ou
en tant que ministre je crois
effectivement qu'il y a des vrais sujets
de proportionnalité j'insiste sur le
risque constitutionnel que représente la
rédaction de l'article en l'état je
crois très sincèrement qui ne passerait
pas et fourche coding du Conseil
constitutionnel il y a déjà eu cette
question qui a été posée lors de
l'examen pour la transparence de la vie
publique le Conseil constitutionnel à
estimer que le recours élargit à une
telle obligation de déclaration pour les
conjoints entraîner une atteinte
disproportionnée au droit
constitutionnellement garanti à la
préservation de la vie privée ça ce sont
pour des questions de proportionnalité
et j'essaye vraiment très sincèrement de
vous convaincre de la bonne foi du
gouvernement sur ces questions là
j'insiste sur le sujet de l'effectivité
quel serait le résultat concret de la
loi telle qu'elle est portée aujourd'hui
nous aurions donc probablement des
dizaines de millions pardon des dizaines
de milliers c'est déjà suffisant de
déclarations exhaustive d'intérêts qui
serait fourni aux administrations non
pas au référents déontologues des
administrations mais probablement aux
acheteurs dans les administrations qui
leur arriveraient entre leurs mains
qu'en fera t-il quel serait les
possibilités de prise en charge par les
administrations de ces dizaines de
millions de déclarations exhaustives
d'intérêts qui leur arriveraient je
crois que nous aurions un réel problème
d'effectivité et qui d'ailleurs pourrait
mettre en danger y compris la
responsabilité des agents publics parce
que s'il y avait un conflit d'intérêt
effectifs par la suite on dirait mais
vous avez eu entre les mains cette
déclaration d'intérêt qu'on avait vous
fait il s'agit là d'un acheteur
quelqu'un qui est pas comme la chatte
PvP spécialisé dans liste des
déclarations d'intérêts sauf à penser
que vous voulez que l'intégralité des
déclarations d'intérêts remonte à
l'achat pvp et je pense qu'on aurait un
problème d'embolisation de l'achatvp
donc j'ai des vrais réserves sincères
effectivement sur la rédaction cet
amendement je reste là non plus pas sans
contre-proposition je propose le
gouvernement propose de centrer les
déclarations exhaustives d'intérêt sur
les dirigeants ainsi que sur les
cabinets de conseils qui parlent même
répondrai à la question que vous avez
posée vous avez dit à juste titre on
veut connaître les autres clients des
cabinets de conseils la rédaction telle
que proposée par le gouvernement
permettrait de le faire et donc centrons
les déclarations exhaustives d'intérêt
sur les dirigeants et sur les cabinets
de conseils et demandons pour le coup à
l'exhaustivité des consultants de
fournir mission par mission une
déclaration sur l'honneur de non
conflits d'intérêt sur la mission sur
lequel ils auraient à intervenir
document j'insiste sur ce dernier point
qui serait opposable juridiquement et
pénalement opposable si un conflit
d'intérêt était avéré et donc je crois
que la proposition que je fais n'est pas
du tout un affaiblissement en matière de
déontologie mais au contraire une
proposition pour rendre plus effective
la finalité de la loi telle que vous la
portez
merci Monsieur le Ministre madame la
reporter oui ce sera un avis défavorable
et je me remettrai par gain de temps aux
éléments apportés par le président
bassin basin pardon peut-être deux
points juste monsieur le ministre pour
pour préciser sur les éléments que vous
avez donné puisque effectivement le
Conseil constitutionnel tout d'abord
censure sur
l'élargissement aux parents et aux
enfants et là cela circonscrit
uniquement au conjoint ou au conjointe
et puis préciser tout de même que à la
différence des élus ou effectivement
leur déclaration et publiée et rendu
public là elle est remise à
l'administration puis contrôler si
besoin sur demande par la Haute Autorité
et que donc il n'y aura pas
une comment une remise en question de de
la vie privée comme cela semble être une
une grande inquiétude puisque les
cabinets de conseils eux-mêmes le disent
moi je voudrais simplement dire je sais
que j'ai donné déjà plusieurs fois cet
exemple là vous savez moi je me souviens
des débats que nous avons eu ici au
moment de la mise en place de la loi de
la transparence et des débats que nous
avions y compris dans les couloirs et
dans les pièces annexes où tout nous
avions tous eu très très peur de tous
les bands d'ailleurs de ce que ça allait
engendrer en matière de
déballement de la vie privée des uns et
des autres je garderai pour le secret
des murs toutes les blagues et boutades
qui ont pu être dites en dehors de cette
hémicycle pour autant aujourd'hui
finalement
certes ça peut être vécu parfois comme
une contrainte les élus dans leur très
grande majorité s'y plis il y a un
caractère public il y a un caractère
consultable dans les préfectures à la
demande des citoyens il y aurait
certainement des choses à rendre
peut-être plus perfectibles mais
finalement cela se fait ils l'ont ne
commande pas y compris à chaque
publication pour telle ou tel ministre
dans la presse la vie des uns et des
autres donc je crois qu'il faut pouvoir
rassurer et c'est finalement
généralisant la transparence que nous la
rendons que nous on a désacralisons
peut-être et rassureront ceux qui en
sont pour l'instant jugés comme les
victimes mais que demain je pense nous
aiderons
je me suis
si monsieur le Président de chemise
juste un mot rapide nous ne demandons
pas la publication de la déclaration
d'intérêt du conjoint monte juste qu'il
soit précisé sa profession et d'ailleurs
c'est ce que vous avez fait vous-même
dans le cas de l'accord câble de la
d.i.t.p donc ça doit pas soulever de
difficultés particulières mais on a
besoin de savoir en effet pour les gens
qui interviennent quels sont leurs
propres intérêts d'autre part l'acheteur
qui va éventuellement de destinataire de
cette déclaration d'intérêt si il
s'estime pas suffisamment armé pour en
juger je pense que les cas sont quand
même pas très nombreux bien il pourra se
retourner vers l'achat atvp ça a été
prévu donc c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons maintenir le dispositif tel
que nous l'avons proposé
jamais ouvert un monde de 36 du
gouvernement avec cet avis défavorable
de la commission qui est pour
contre
abstention et un paille n'est pas adopté
et je mets au voile 10
qui est pour
contre
l'article 11 nous avons
l'amendement numéro 22 présenté par
Madame Duranton
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement a pour objet de renvoyer à un
décret en Conseil d'État pris à préavis
public de la hache ah t pardon
excusez-moi VP la définition des
modalités de publication des
informations relatives aux actions de
démarchage de prospection et de mécénat
le dispositif que nous vous proposons
d'adopter s'inspire de celui prévu par
la loi du 11 octobre 2013 relative à la
transparence de la vie publique
la vie de la commission défavorable
monsieur le Président en assistant
simplement sur un point c'est que ce
décret sera rendu après avis public
comme la indiquée à la scénariste
Duranton de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et donc
il y aura bien un avis donné un travail
mené avec la Haute autorité pour rédiger
le décret d'application de cet article
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous avons confiance dans le
gouvernement mais la prise d'un décret
présente toujours un risque pour
rappeler un souvenir un peu délicat le
président de la hatvp évoque souvent les
représentants d'un terrain et la loi
saint pain de qui est bien écrite nous
rappelle-t-il mais il souligne aussi le
fait que le décret qui a été pris en
application on l'a complètement
dévitalisé le problème persiste depuis
maintenant plus de 5 ans donc si on
pouvait éviter de reproduire les mêmes
erreurs ce serait très bien
22 de notre collègue école Duranton qui
est pour
l'article 11 qui est pour
contre
il est à l'opté à l'article 12
l'amendement le gouvernement pardon nous
propose un amendement 37 quel ministre
va présenter
le président cet amendement porte sur
deux points d'abord rendre possible à
saisine de la chatte VP par une
organisation syndicale c'est un point
sur lequel j'ai une gêne d'abord parce
que en l'état du droit aucune
organisation syndicale ne peut saisir
une autorité administrative indépendante
ça serait un précédent absolu que nous
créons à travers la proposition de loi
je ne crois pas que ça soit le rôle des
représentants syndicats et j'ai un
respect absolu pour les organisations
syndicales que de saisir la Haute
autorité sur les sujets des cabinets de
conseil le rôle des organisations
syndicales c'est de protéger les agents
de la fonction publique en l'occurrence
c'est de représenter leurs droits et
leur intérêt et je crois que on
viendrait dévoyé le rôle des
organisations syndicales en proposant
une telle possibilité de saisine
deuxième sujet je l'ai déjà évoqué donc
je serais très bref sur le rôle et le
pouvoir donné à la Haute autorité de
contrôle sur place pour des salariés des
cabinets de conseil encore une fois nous
créons là un précédent et je crois une
inégalité devant la loi que en
l'occurrence je avec desquels je ne suis
pas du tout du tout à l'aise en donnant
ce pouvoir de contrôle sur place sur
l'ensemble des salariés qui n'existent
même pas ni pour les ministres ni pour
les parlementaires
présenté par le gouvernement qui fait
l'objet de la vie défavorable de la
commission qui est pour
qui est contre
l'abstention et des rejeter et nous
venons à l'article à l'amendement 25
de monsieur Sueur et de ses collègues
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègue il s'agit du
cas où
une demande il y a un refus
suite à une demande de communication de
pièces ou de documents par la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique dans ce cas il est proposé que
la Haute Autorité saisisse la commission
des sanctions qui est mise en oeuvre à
cette fin notamment et je tiens à
remercier particulièrement madame Cécile
cuquermann qui a fait des propositions
très judicieuses de manière à ce que
c'est amendement qui était imparfait
soit meilleur
par ailleurs sur les amants du texte
du Sénat l'amendement 25 avec le i
favorable de la commission une
défavorable du gouvernement
qui est pour
contre et donc adopter il y aura une
petite rectification à faire à la
deuxième ligne
je mets aux voiles amendement l'article
12 pardon
qui est pour
contre
[Musique]
sur les régimes de sanctions il s'avère
que le législateur c'était déjà pensé
sur ces questions et le bon régime de
sanction applicable sur les
représentants d'intérêt en l'occurrence
il avait admis une exception sur les
contrôles sur place exception qui avait
été donnée à la Haute Autorité de
pouvoir faire des contrôles sur place
chez les représentants d'intérêts mais
en l'occurrence malgré cette exception
avait été réaffirmé un pouvoir de
sanction qui était un trois sanction
pénal et qui n'était donc pas un pouvoir
de sanction porté par la chatte et
l'épée de pouvoir de sanctions
administratives donc il me semble qu'il
serait effectivement une dissonance par
rapport au rôle de l'achat PvP aux
droits tel qu'il est pensé aujourd'hui
par le législateur de créer ce pouvoir
de sanction spécifique à doc pour les
seuls cabinets de conseils après on peut
avoir un débat sur qu'est-ce qui est le
plus dissuasif moi je crois que les
sanctions pénales telles que définies
par la loi sont des sanctions qui sont
en réalité dissuasives j'entends parfois
que
serait au fond démuni de ce pouvoir de
sanctions et que son rôle serait du coup
inopérant ça n'est pas vrai l'achatvp a
déjà transmis des éléments au procureur
de la République un bon nombre de fois
pour être très précis il y a 178
dossiers qui ont été transmis par la
chattevp à la justice depuis 2014 il y a
eu 28 condamnations condamnations
effectives et définitive sur des
ministres sur des parlementaires c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement
effectif aujourd'hui et donc je crois
c'est un dispositif qui n'est pas du
tout inopérant au contraire qui me
semble être largement dissuasif
l'article 14 je porte un abonnement de
suppression qui est très largement
cohérent avec ce que je viens d'indiquer
puisque je suis contre la création de la
région de sanction Haddock donc d'une
commission qui lui est liée et puis sur
l'article 15 je crois effectivement que
ce sont aussi des amendements de
cohérence de cohérence avec le droit
européen le dispositif de sanctions
pénales prévoit aussi des mécanismes
d'exclusion des marchés publics et des
mises en cohérence avec le droit
européen sur des mécanismes déjà
existants d'auto-apurement qui sont
prévus par les textes européens et donc
c'est pour ça que je souhaitais vous
présenter l'ensemble de ces amendements
d'un bloc si je puis dire
sur l'amendement 38 la vie du
gouvernement la vie de la Commission
le Président je pense qu'en deux minutes
je ferai également un tir groupé si vous
me le permettez ce sera un avis bien
évidemment défavorable parce que au
contraire nous pensons et ce n'est pas
qu'une effectivement une question de
procédure mais que la sanction
administraite administrative sera en la
matière bien plus efficace parce que
plus rapide dans son dans son
application par rapport à une sanction
pénale qui prend beaucoup plus de temps
nous sommes et donc demeurons favorables
à la création d'une commission des
sanctions et par rapport à ce que vous
évoquiez monsieur le ministre oui parce
qu'il y a cas particulier cas spécifique
à travers cette question des cabinets de
conseils et je crois que depuis le début
vous le voyez bien l'objectif n'est pas
de généraliser d'autres champs mais de
garder le champ de définition initial de
cette proposition de loi il y a besoin
de de commission qui peuvent ne pas
exister dans d'autres cas et donc d'où
la volonté de maintenir la création de
cette commission des sanctions au sein
de la Haute autorité et par voie de
conséquences soit ce que je viens de
dire sur l'article 13 et 14 l'amendement
numéro 15 est également défavorable
toutefois je tiens à tout de même à
préciser que dans le respect du droit
européen la proposition de loi à
l'article 15 prévoit justement avec
Alice de régulation en s'abiant sur une
collaboration je cite active qui reprend
la disposition de la directive entre la
Haute Autorité d'une part et
l'administration qui a bénéficié de la
prestation de conseils donc pour ces
raisons ce sera des avis d'ores et déjà
défavorables sur ces trois amendements
présentés par le gouvernement
je mets d'ouvrir pardon
merci monsieur le Président simplement
un mot pour aller dans le sens de Madame
la rapporteur et simplement rajouter que
l'amendement du Gouvernement tel qu'il
est rédigé en fait supprime des
sanctions par exemple lorsqu'un cabinet
de conseils réalise une prestation
pro-bonho ou utilise le logo de
l'administration ce que ce qui pour nous
est inacceptable bien évidemment
donc je mets au voile amendement 38 du
gouvernement avec un avis défavorable de
la commission qui est favorable qui est
pour
qui est contre
l'abstention il est donc repoussé et un
amendement 31 de Madame Goulet qui va
nous le présenter monsieur le ministre
on peut dire qu'il est rédactionnel il
s'agit de remplacer total par consolidé
mais peut-être pas compris donc plus que
des favorable je demanderai un retrait
puisque avec l'expression totale plus
que consolidé nous faisons en parallèle
on se déforme avec ce qui est déjà
rédigé dans la loi dans l'article 20
notamment de la loi de 78 pour la Cnil
mais c'est également ce qui est utilisé
pour définir le montant de la sanction
PQR qui peut être prononcé par
l'Autorité des marchés financiers qui là
aussi parle de chiffre d'affaires annuel
total donc à rédactionnel quand même qui
nous met en difficulté c'est plus une
demande de retrait madame
du coup je mets aux voiles l'article 13
lui-même qui est pour
et contre
à l'abstention il est donc adopté
article 14 l'amendement 39 du
gouvernement qui fait partie de ceux que
vous avez présenté je crois monsieur le
ministre donc nous avons un avis
défavorable de la commission je suppose
que le vote du Sénat est le même que sur
les amendements précédents et donc
écarté et donc je soumets au Sénat
l'article 14 qui est pour
contre
et donc adopté
à l'article 15 nous avons un amendement
nous avons deux amendements identiques
de Madame Goulet puis de Madame associer
de ses collègues
des dispositions qui visent à entraîner
l'exclusion de la commande publique
honnête d'un viser l'article 434 13 du
code pénal qui est celui du faux
témoignage
l'histoire et l'expérience de cette
commission d'enquête nous montre que ce
genre de choses peut arriver donc il
s'agit de d'ajouter à liste des
infractions qui peuvent entraîner
l'exclusion de la commande publique les
personnes qui auraient été condamnées
pour se motif
qui a invoqué l'article 40 de du code de
procédure pinale pour suspicion de faux
témoignages ça n'est pas rien donc nous
estimons à l'instar de notre collègue
Nathalie Oulé que pas question de donner
le moindre euro d'argent public un
cabinet qui serait con de fin convaincu
de parjure dans ce genre de situation et
donc interdiction de soumissionner un
quelconque marché public voilà le sens
de l'amendement que nous proposons
quelle est la ville de la Commission
un mot pour dire que mon cabinet qui
n'avait besoin d'aucun cabinet de
conseils pour me donner cette position
m'indique qui aurait certainement des
difficultés d'écriture par rapport à la
conformité au texte européen mais ce que
je vous propose c'est dans un esprit
très constructif de pouvoir travailler à
l'occasion de la navette l'écriture de
cet amendement si on peut l'améliorer
donc avis de sagesse du gouvernement sur
cette amendement dont je partage la
finalité
je soumets au Sénat donc les deux
amendements neufs et 46
avec la vie favorable la Commission et
la vie de sagesse du gouvernement qui
est pour
merci qui est contre
l'abstention il est donc ils sont
adoptés
ensuite nous avons
sur l'article 15 l'article car
l'amendement 40 du gouvernement qu'il a
présenté si je me souviens bien qui a
fait l'objet dans la vie défavorable de
la commission
s'il n'y a pas de demande de parole je
soumets au vote
de l'Assemblée c'est le même vote
il est donc repoussé quand un article 15
lui-même je le mets aux voix qui est
pour
et contre
il est adopté
sur l'article 16 nous avons un
amendement 41 du gouvernement
la question du contrôle des
allers-retours entre le public et le
privé qui est le dernier débat que nous
aurons au fond sur sur le texte ce que
je note c'est que la rédaction de
l'article s'écarte très nettement de la
loi de transformation de 2019 et des
principes qui avaient été introduits non
pas par le gouvernement à l'époque mais
par le Parlement à l'époque sur
l'architecture de contrôle déontologique
dont la chatvp dit le plus grand bien et
et
contre mécanisme de contrôle que ce sont
approprié les administrations cet
article écrirait au fond deux
distorsions par rapport au mécanisme
créé dans la loi de transformation
première distorsion en considérant que
il n'y a plus aucune hiérarchie dans les
agents concernés c'est-à-dire que ça
concernerait contrairement à ce que dit
la loi de transformation qui était
centrée sur les postes à responsabilité
au sein des administrations qui
semble-t-il et l'exercice et l'objectif
et la finalité visé par le texte de loi
de pouvoir éviter les influences là
première distorsion absolument tous les
agents administratifs sont concernés par
le dispositif tel que vous l'avez créé
c'est à dire un agent administratif tout
en bas de l'échelle hiérarchique aurait
les mêmes prérogatives ou le même
contraintes en termes de contrôle par la
chattevp que les postes à plus forte
responsabilité première distorsion
deuxième distorsion vous créez un régime
Haddock pour les cabinets de conseils je
peux en comprendre la philosophie mais
donc on aura une distorsion qui
considérait que au fond il y a moins
d'enjeux déontologique moins d'enjeux
d'influence pour un haut fonctionnaire
qui représenterait et qui rejoindrait
par exemple l'industrie de l'armement et
qui viendrait du ministère des armées
que pour un simple fonctionnaire très
bas dans l'échelle de hiérarchique qui
rejoindrait un cabinet de conseils pour
diversifier son parcours professionnel
donc je crois là aussi que dans une
logique de proportionnalité et
d'effectivité du texte il vaudrait mieux
se reposer sur l'architecture créée par
la loi de transformation qui vise à ce
que les responsables
de l'administration puisse d'abord
regarder ces situations de conflit
puisse en référer au référendumontologue
et en cas de difficultés remonter à
l'achat TVP pour les postes concernés je
pense que c'est un mécanisme qui a fait
ses preuves qui fonctionnent et sur
lequel nous devrions pouvoir nous
reposer
la vie de la commission oui peut-être
sans surprise mais ce sera un avis
effectivement défavorable vous me
permettrez non pas par leurs tardif
parce que j'avais prévu de vous le dire
dans tous les cas mais de dire peut-être
que c'est un compromis un peu bancal que
que vous proposez monsieur le ministre
puisque d'un côté on tente doper on
tombe d'opérer entre le droit commun et
la dérogation qui est visée à l'article
16 j'aurais envie de dire tout
simplement soit effectivement le secteur
du conseil rend déjà dans le cadre des
dispositions prévues aux différents
articles cités du code général de la
Fonction publique et donc dans ce cas là
allons jusqu'au bout et supprimer cet
article 16 soit au contraire et c'est la
position en tout cas qui a été celle de
la commission il est nécessaire
effectivement de prévoir à disposition
spécifique pour l'activité de conseils
privés et même si j'entends les réserves
que vous avez mises nous souhaitons en
tout cas les laisser en l'état de de la
rédaction de cet article
et donc de gagner en tout cas en clarté
et lisibilité je vous remercie
défavorable
que que vous mentionnez en l'occurrence
elle part de l'intention d'améliorer le
dispositif actuel de l'architecture de
la loi de 2019 en mentionnant les enjeux
spécifiques liés au cabinet de conseil
et en s'appuyant sur la hatvp pour leur
demander de nous aider dans la rédaction
des lignes directrices de gestion
justement pour mieux travailler avec les
référents déontologues dans les
administrations et donc au contraire
c'est un mécanisme je crois tout à fait
effectif et améliorer que je viens la
proposer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je ne crois pas trahir l'esprit
de la commission d'enquête et ensuite de
tous ceux qui ont bien voulu signer la
proposition de loi en disant que ce que
nous visions c'est les responsables
publics d'ailleurs on le rappelle dans
l'exposé des motifs ce qui restera bien
le périmètre il semblerait que dans le
texte de l'article on est parlé d'agent
public c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir à
ce moment-là une difficulté je crois que
dans la navette ça pourra être amélioré
précisé en tout cas ce que nous visons
ce sont les responsables publics et pas
tous les agents publics clairement
ensuite on en a évalué le nombre dans
les précédentes années c'est un nombre
assez limité de personnes qui va se
compter en un peu plus d'une centaine à
l'année la transmission à la Haute
Autorité ne présente pas de difficultés
je pense d'examen et on a évolué à ce
sur ce sujet une véritable zone de
risque j'ai donné un exemple tout à
l'heure un responsable de cabinet de
conseils qui prend un poste à l'Elysée
et qui fait venir ce cabinet de conseils
pour réorganiser le service dont il a la
responsabilité ça c'est une vraie zone
de risque qu'on a besoin de d'avoir
délimité tout ça par une transmission à
avis de la chaîne TVP pour qu'elle fasse
ses excusions nécessaires par la suite
et qu'elle se donne les moyens du
contrôle ça nous paraît tout à fait
proportionné pour le coup et réalisable
dernier mot pour indiquer quand même que
le rapport de la commission des Léa des
lois pardon mentionne aussi la mention
agent public donc je crois que très
sincèrement l'article tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui n'est pas bien rédigé et
concernerait l'ensemble des agents
publics donc je crois qu'il y a quand
même un vrai problème de rédaction qui
est là et vous mentionnez un cas
particulier de recrutement par l'Élysée
d'un cas qui je crois n'aurait pas été
remis en cause par la hatvp et sur
lequel aucun conflit d'intérêt ensuite
n'a été mentionné sur le cas particulier
que vous visez donc je crois que le
dispositif tel que prévu par la loi en
l'occurrence c'est un cas particulier on
en avait échangé en amont de ce texte
n'aurait pas été visé par le dispositif
proposé j'ai eu l'occasion de le
vérifier
je mets où voit l'article l'amendement
41 présenté par le gouvernement avec la
vie défavorable de la commission qui est
pour
qui est contre une page adoptée
quand à l'article 16
je le soumets au vote qui est pour
contre il est donc adopté
[Musique]
je soumets également au vote du Sénat
article 17 qui ne fait pas l'objet
d'amendement qui est pour
qui est contre pas l'abstention il est
adopté à l'article 18
nous avons un amendement numéro 23 de
Madame Duranton et de ses collègues
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement vis-à-limité l'obligation de
réaliser un audit de sécurité au sol
contrat de la commande publique qui
nécessite un haut niveau de sécurité des
systèmes d'information nous souhaitons
ainsi assurer la compatibilité de
l'article 18 avec les directives
européennes relatives à la passation des
concessions et des marchés publics qui
prévoit que les exigences en matière de
recevabilité et de sélection des
candidatures ne sont destinés qu'à
garantir qu'un candidat ou un
soumissionnaire dispose de la capacité
juridique et financière ainsi que des
compétences techniques et
professionnelles nécessaires à
l'exécution du contrat
et la vie de la Commission
que vous avez mentionné vous-même je
crois que c'est un amendement qui nature
a favoriser les cabinets de plus petite
taille qui n'aurait peut-être pas les
ressources financières pour mener les
audits en sécurité informatique qui sont
exigées et donc c'est pour cette raison
que je mets un avis favorable
je mets aux voiles amendement ainsi
discuté le numéro 23 avec un avis
défavorable de la commission et
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
il y a pas d'abstention il est donc
repoussé
nous pouvons donc voter sur l'article 18
qui est pour
qui contre il n'y a pas d'abstention il
est adopté
à l'article 19 nous avons un amendement
qui je crois le dernier du gouvernement
qui est le 42 que le ministre nous
présente
oui c'est tout simplement d'un moment de
suppression de l'article 19 pour une
raison extrêmement simple c'est que
l'article 19 ne me paraît pas conforme
au droit régissant la relation
contractuelle et l'article 2 du Code
civil indiquant que la loi ne dispose
que pour l'avenir elle n'a point d'effet
rétroactifs votre assemblée avait eu à
examiner en 2017
le projet de Loire intelligent
l'ordonnance portant réforme du droit
des contrats vous aviez à l'époque
réaffirmé la protection
constitutionnelle des contrats en cours
je pense que vous la remettriez en cause
en adoptant l'article 19 tel que rédigé
la commission oui ce sera un avis
défavorable et nous savions j'ai envie
de dire des pointes de début il y a un
véritable débat le souhait en tout cas
tel qu'il a été retenu et que la
proposition de loi s'applique notamment
aux accords cadres de l'UGAP et de la
DTP qui vient d'être renouvelé récemment
ce qui concerne lugab ou qui fait
l'objet d'ailleurs d'un d'une procédure
de renouvellement actuel pour l'accord
des ITP je crois que ces accords cadres
nous le savons et d'où peut-être aussi
cette volonté à travers cet article 19
représente des sommes significatives qui
ne peuvent être ignorées le montant du
nouvel accord 4 de la TTP de la D IPP
par notre estime à 150 millions d'euros
hors taxes pour la période 2023 2027
avec un plafond à 200 millions d'euros
il semble donc excessif d'attendre que
ces accords cadres expirent dans quatre
ans pour que la proposition de loi
puisse s'appliquer enfin et pleinement
et donc en outre l'A d'applications
immédiate impliquant la modification des
accords cadres aurait pour conséquence
une rupture d'égalité entre les
prestations de conseil se rattachant un
accord cadre et celles contracté en
dehors de ceci pour toutes ces raisons
un avis défavorable
ment avec la vie défavorable du
gouvernement avec la vie défavorable de
commission sur le 42 qui est pour
qui est contre
donc l'amendement est repoussé et je me
vois l'article 19
qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
je vais mettre au voie l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de votre madame Duranton
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre chers collègues au nom du
groupe RDPI je souhaite saluer la
qualité de nos débats je me réjouis de
constater que l'objectif poursuivi par
la proposition de loi et largement
partagée sur les bancs de notre
assemblée les modifications apportées au
texte initial vont dans le bon sens à
commencer par celle relative au champ
d'application parmi les autres avancées
figurent l'interdiction pour
l'administration d'attribuer une adresse
électronique au consultant je
mentionnerai également l'obligation pour
les prestataires de conseils de produire
les conclusions d'un audit attestant
d'un niveau minimal de sécurité pour
ceux qui concerne les mécanismes de
transparence et de contrôle
déontologiques des ajustements sont
nécessaires pour ne pas dire
indispensable aussi nous regrettons que
nos amendements n'est pas été adoptés
nous regrettons également que également
le rejet des amendements présentés le
gouvernement à l'instar du ministre nous
souhaitons que la proposition de loi
chemine nous sommes en effet convaincus
que la navette permettra de trouver un
point d'équilibre et donc d'aboutir à un
dispositif
et proportionné la navette sera aussi
l'occasion de trancher la question des
modalités d'inclusion des collectivités
territoriales dans un champ
d'application vous l'avez dit Madame la
rapporteur le débat de ce soir est un
point d'étape et non un aboutissement
pour toutes ces raisons les groupes RDPI
votera pour la proposition de loi
ensuite madame goulet
de leur avancée pour dire la
satisfaction qu'on peut
ressentir après le travail qui a été
fait non seulement pendant la commission
mais aussi durant ces débats vous
remercier monsieur le ministre d'avoir
mentionné à plusieurs reprises la
navette ce qui nous donne évidemment
énormément d'espoir sur le suivi des
dispositions que nous nous apprêtons à
voter sur leur avenir à l'Assemblée
nationale et dans le cadre de la navette
dont il est absolument incontestable
qu'elle est nécessaire évidemment pour
rendre ce texte meilleur et plus précis
un regret toutefois c'est de ne pas
avoir voté l'amendement numéro 11 notre
collègue benaroche qui qui proposait
d'interdire les prestations
pour la rédaction d'études d'impact et
d'exposer des motifs d'une loi je pense
que ce sujet est vraiment extrêmement
important qu'il s'agit là d'une
délégation de ce qu'il y a de plus
régalien dans nos ministères
c'est-à-dire la rédaction de proposition
de loi les études d'impact je vois bien
ce que ce qu'a voulu dire notre
collection ça peut porter à discussion
mais franchement l'exposé des motifs et
les textes sachant que les cabinets
d'avocats n'offrent strictement aucune
garantie sur les liens d'intérêt pour ne
pas dire les conflits d'intérêt je pense
que ce sujet là sera vraiment à creuser
durant la navette et ça me semble aussi
extrêmement important donc nous vous
reverrons sur ces sujets nous reverrons
aussi sur le PLF dans quelques jours
pour un jour ou un orange budgétaire sur
les sujets dont nous avons parlé ce soir
donc nous voterons évidemment avec
enthousiasme le texte qui a été débattu
ce soir ensuite monsieur Bazin
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
ministre pour vous dire simplement que
le groupe les républicains votre altex
tel qu'il est sorti de nos débats ce
soir
rebondir comme un instant sur ce que
disait madame Goulet sur l'amendement
proposé pendant ce Bénin roche sur
l'étude d'impact moi on m'indique pas
moi qui ne suis pas du tout juriste mais
qui aura une difficulté parce que ça
relèverait d'une loi organique donc ça
fait c'est un exemple pour dire qu'il y
a un certain nombre de choses encore à
regarder on en est bien d'accord dans
les détails pour parfaire et polir cette
proposition de loi la navette est là
pour ça et nous lisons confiance
le principal c'est que l'esprit de
l'architecture de la proposition de loi
ont été conservées l'État
qui serait aveugle en matière de
déontologie serait en danger je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure et je crois que quand
tous ces dispositions là seront bien
stabilisées auront été définitivement
adoptés vous verrez monsieur le ministre
que toutes les administrations sont
porteront mieux parce qu'elles sont
sécurisées dans leur rapport avec
cabinet de consultants et de même les
ministres pourront aussi être plus
sereins et plus tranquille je pense
qu'on a fait un travail intéressant
vraiment sur le fond totalement
transpartisan on a encore une fois
conservé l'esprit et les objectifs de
cette proposition de loi c'est pourquoi
nous le voterons avec beaucoup de
satisfaction
je vais mettre au voile à proposition de
loi et j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe les
républicains sur l'ensemble du texte
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin et donc l'eau
résultat du scrutin votant 344 exprimé
331 pour le projet de la proposition de
loi 331 contre 0 la proposition est donc
adoptée
mes chers collègues je vais lever la
séance prochaine séance mercredi 19
octobre c'est à dire aujourd'hui à 15h
pour les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement la séance est levée